GOOD. I'LL CALL THE- ASSEMBLY
HIGHER EDUCATION COMMITTEE TO
ORDER- WITH THE ABSENCE OF A
QUORUM WILL BEGIN AS A SUB
COMMITTEE. SO WELCOME TO THE
COMMITTEE ON HIGHER EDUCATION'S
BILL HEARING WHETHER IT YOU'RE
HERE IN PERSON. WATCHING
VIRTUALLY OR ON THE PHONE LINES
I'M GLAD YOU'VEJOINED US FOR
TODAY'S PARENTS. I WILL NOT GO%
OVER SOME KEY ELEMENTS OF THE
STRUCTURE OF TODAY'S HEARING.
DUE TO THE ONGOING PANDEMIC
WE'RE STILL PRACTICING PHYSICAL
DISTANCE SCENE. IN THE HARIAN
AND THROUGHOUT THE CAPITOL
BUILDING. WE ARE ONLY ABLE TO
HAVE A LIVE IN THAT NUMBER OF
PEOPLE PHYSICALLY PRESENT TO
OBSERVE. AND PARTICIPATE DURING
THIS HEARING. IF YOU'RE HERE IN
PERSON PLEASE NOTE THAT WHILE
MASS ARE NO LONGER REQUIRED.
THEY ARE RECOMMENDED REGARDLESS
OF THE VACCINE STATUS. IF YOU'D
LIKE TO WEAR A MASK AND DO NOT
HAVE ONE. PLEASE NOTE THAT MASS-
AVAILABLE FREE OF CHARGE AT THE
SECURITY CHECKPOINTS AT THE
ENTRANCE OF THE CAPITOL BUILDING
. WE HAVE A FEW DIFFERENT
OPTIONS FOR WITNESS TESTIMONY
TODAY. IN PERSON- WRITTEN
TESTIMONY. YOU REALIZING THE
LEGISLATIVE SUPPORT PORTAL. IF
YOU'RE TESTIFYING IN PERSON ANY
MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC IN THE ROOM
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN THE
BILL PLEASE APPROACH THE
MICROPHONE AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME. I WOULD ASK THAT THE
PUBLIC NOT TOUCH THE MICROPHONE
YOU CAN EXIT THE HEARING ROOM
ONCE YOU FINISH TESTIFYING OR
RETURN TO YOUR SEAT. PLEASE BE
SURE TO RESERVE PHYSICAL
DISTANCING UPON LEAVING THE
CAPITAL INCLUDING LIMITING THE
NUMBER OF PEOPLE ON THE
ELEVATOR. TO THE INDICATED
NUMBER ON THE SIGNS POSTED BY
THE ELEVATOR DOORS. FOR WRITTEN
TESTIMONY PLEASE NOTE THAT WE
ARE ACCEPTING WRITTEN TESTIMONY.
THROUGH THE POSITION LETTER
PORTAL WHICH CAN BE LOCATED ON
THE COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE. FOR
LEAD WITNESS AND TWEENER
TESTIMONY PLEASE NOTE THAT THE
GUIDELINES FOR BILLS HEARD IN
THIS COMMITTEE IS TO ALLOW
TESTIMONY FROM TO LEAD WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT. AND TO LEAD
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION TO SPEAK
FOR NO MORE THAN TWO MINUTES
EACH. STAKEHOLDER GROUPS AND
ENTITIES THAT ARE NEITHER IN
SUPPORT NOR IN OPPOSITION WILL
BE ALLOWED TO GIVE TESTIMONY FOR
NO MORE THAN TWO MINUTES WHEN I
CALLED FOR TWEETERS. THE MEN
MEASURE HAS MORE THAN TWO
ENTITIES IN THE TWEENER CATEGORY
ONLY TWO WILL BE ALLOWED TO
SPEAK FOR TWO MINUTES EACH.
PLEASE NOTE THAT YOUR TESTIMONY
IS BEING TIME IF YOU APPROACH
TWO MINUTES. I WILL INTERRUPT
YOU AND ASK THAT YOU BRING YOUR
TESTIMONY TO A CLOSE. THANK YOU
FOR BEARING WITH US AS WE
IMPLEMENT METHODS TO CONTINUE TO
SERVE THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA
WHILE ALSO BEING MINDFUL AND
RESPECTFUL. OF THE PUBLIC HEALTH
CONCERNS WE ALL FACE. FOR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
MEMBERS IF YOU'D LIKE TO RESPOND
TO ROLL CALL ASK A QUESTION
PROVIDE A COMMENT. YOU MAY NEED
TO RAISE YOUR HAND AND ACTIVATE
YOUR VOLUME BUTTON- NEAR DYESS
MICROPHONES. FOR AUTHORS OF
BILLS EACH MEMBER PRESENTING
pAND CLOSING STATEMENT.
ADDITIONALLY AS I PREVIOUSLY
STATED YOUR LIPS LEAD WITNESS
WILL EACH HAVE TWO MINUTES TO
PROVIDE TESTIMONY. WE ORIGINALLY
HAD TWENTY SEVEN MEASURES ON THE
AGENDA TODAY HOWEVER THE
FOLLOWING MEASURES HAVE BEEN
PULLED FROM TODAY'S AGENDA. A.
B. TWENTY FOUR THIRTY SEVEN.
FILE ITEM SIX AND AB TWENTY SIX
SIXTY FOUR FILE ITEM TWELVE.
ADDITIONALLY THE FOLLOWING FIVE
MEMBERS ARE IN THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. AB TWENTY NINE TWENTY
FILE ITEM THREE AB TWENTY EIGHT
EIGHTY FILE ITEM SEVEN AB TWENTY
NINE SEVENTY THREE FILE ITEM
ELEVEN AB TWENTY FOUR TWENTY TWO
FILE ITEM SEVENTEEN AND A. B.
NINETEEN NINETY EIGHT FILE ITEM
TWENTY SIX. SO THAT LEAVES
TWENTY MEASURES TO BE PRESENTED
. THE MEASURES WILL BE TAKEN UP
AND FILE ORDER HOWEVER THE
FOLLOWING TWO MEASURES WILL NOT
BE ELIGIBLE TO BE TAKEN UP UNTIL
THEY ARE DISPENSED WITH. IN THE
ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON HEALTH AND
THAT'S A. B. TWENTY FIVE TWENTY
TWO FILE ITEM FOURTEEN AND A. B.
NINETEEN EIGHTEEN FILE ITEM
TWENTY THREE. I WILL PRESENT MY
BILL AB TWENTY EIGHT TWENTY LAST
. PLEASE NOTE THAT IT SSEMBLY
MEMBER JACQUI IRWIN WILL PRESENT
A. B. TWENTY SIX TWENTY SEVEN
FILE ITEM FOR ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BAUER QUE HAN-
AT THIS TIME ASSEMBLY MEMBER
JACQUI IRWIN- WILL BEGIN AB
SEVENTEEN OH FIVE FILE ITEM WITH. WELCOME MR WITH. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MISTER CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. EIGHTY SEVEN
OH FIVE HAS USHERED IN A NEW ERA
OF ACCESS AND COMPLETION OF
ENTRY LEVEL ENGLISH AND MATH
COURSES AT CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGES WITH TENS OF THOUSANDS
MORE STUDENTS NOW SUCCESSFULLY
COMPLETING TRANSFER LEVEL
CLASSES. IN FALL TWENTY FIFTEEN
MORE THAN A HUNDRED AND TWENTY
ONE THOUSAND STUDENTS WHO
ENROLLED IN MATH DIDN'T COMPLETE
THE TRANSFER LEVEL REQUIREMENT
WITHIN THE ONE YEAR TIME FRAME
AND THAT NUMBER WAS STILL OVER A
HUNDRED THOUSAND STUDENTS NOT
COMPLETING A TWO YEAR TIME
FRAME. THESE THROUGHPUT RATES
WERE CONSISTENTLY LESS THAN 30%
IN FALL OF TWENTY NINETEEN AFTER
AB SEVEN OH FIVE NEARLY SEVENTY
THREE THOUSAND OUT OF A HUNDRED
AND FORTY SIX THOUSAND STUDENTS
SUCCESSFULLY COMPLETED TRANSFER
LEVEL MATH WITHIN ONE YEAR WHICH
GIVES A THROUGHPUT RATE OF 50% I
WANT TO TAKE A MOMENT TO
RECOGNIZE THAT THESE ARE
EXTREMELY PROMISING IMPROVEMENTS
AND THEY WOULD NOT HAVE BEEN
POSSIBLE WITHOUT THE TIRELESS
WORK OF COMMUNITY COLLEGE
FACULTY. COUNSELORS
ADMINISTRATORS AND SUPPORT STAFF
ACROSS THE STATE. THIS MAJOR
CHANGE WAS NOT EASY. AND I HAVE
ENGAGED N GOOD FAITH
DISCUSSIONS WITH FACULTY AND
CAMPUS LEADERS TO BETTER
UNDERSTAND HOW THE SPIRIT OF
SEVEN OH FIVE WAS BEING
IMPLEMENTED. AS WELL AS SOME OF
WHAT SOME OF THE OBSTACLES AND
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES WERE. A.
B. SEVEN OH FIVE REPRESENTS MY
ATTEMPT TO INCORPORATE FEEDBACK
FROM A DIVERSE SET OF
STAKEHOLDERS INCLUDING BUT NOT
LIMITED TO FACULTY MEMBERS
STUDENTS. MATHIS CIVIL RIGHTS
ADVOCATES WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
PRACTITIONERS AND MOST CRUCIALLY
CHANCELLOR OAKLEY AND THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE WHICH ALSO
DESERVE RECOGNITION FOR THEIR
STEADFAST COMMITMENT TO STUDENT
SUCCESS. THIS BILL MAKES SEVERAL
SEVERAL IMPORTANT CLARIFICATIONS
TO THE ORIGINAL AB SEVEN OH FIVE
STATUTE. FIRST AND FOREMOST IN
THE UNIVERSE OF THOSE WHO THE
TRANSFER LEVEL REQUIREMENTS
APPLY TO. SO AB SEVENTEEN OH
FIVE EXPLICITLY EXEMPTS PROGRAMS
THAT DO NOT HAVE MATH OR ENGLISH
REQUIREMENTS AS EIGHTY SEVEN OH
FIVE WAS NEVER INTENDED TO
CREATE NEW REQUIREMENTS WERE
NINE EXISTED. IT EXAM STUDENTS
AND ADULT EDUCATION PROGRAM HIGH
SCHOOL STUDENTS IN DUAL
ENROLLMENT PROGRAMS AND STUDENTS
AND TECHNICAL CERTIFICATE OR
DEGREE PROGRAMS WHERE THERE IS
FIRST THAT WERE THERE ARE
SPECIFIC REQUIREMENTS THAT ARE
NOT MET BY INAPPROPRIATE
TRANSFER LEVEL COURSE AND THIS
IS ESPECIALLY CRUCIAL FOR OUR C.
T. E. PASSED- PATHWAYS. THESE
CHANGES ARE IMPORTANT BECAUSE
THEY MAKE IT VERY CLEAR THAT
DESPITE WHAT THE OPPONENTS HAVE
CLAIMED THE COLLEGES STILL OFF-
ARE ALLOWED TO OFFER AND GUIDE
STUDENTS INTO PRE TRANSFER LEVEL
COURSE WORK WHERE IT IS
APPROPRIATE. THERE IS ABSOLUTELY
A ROLE FOR COLLEGE LEVEL COURSES
BUT THEY NEED TO BE RELEVANT TO
A STUDENT'S GOAL OR CAREER PATH
IN FACT OUR EFFORTS TO RESPOND
TO GOOD FAITH CRITIQUES IS WIDE
NINETY THREE FACULTY
ADMINISTRATORS AND OTHER
COMMUNITY COLLEGE STAFF SIGNED A
LETTER OF SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL
. RESEARCHERS FOUND THAT THE
IMPLEMENTATION WAS ON EVEN
ACROSS THE STATE MEANING ACT
ACCESS TO TRANSFER LEVEL COURSES
AND SUPPORTS DEPENDS ON WHERE
YOU LIVE. CONVERSATIONS WITH
STUDENTS WHO WERE MY
CONSTITUENTS HAVE CONFIRMED. AS
THEY'VE SHARED STORIES OF
FACULTY AND COUNSELORS STRONGLY
RECOMMENDING REMEDIAL AND BELOW
TRANSFER LEVEL COURSEWORK. EVEN
WORTH THEY FEEL IT'S NOT
NECESSARY. IN FACT ONE COLLEGE
INCENTIVIZE STUDENTS TO TAKE
REMEDIAL COURSEWORK BY PROVIDING
PRIORITY REGISTRATION TO THOSE
WHO TAKE A PLACEMENT TEST THAT
CONSISTENTLY RECOMMEND STUDENTS
REPEAT. ALREADY COMPLETED
COURSES. ANOTHER STUDENT SHARED
HOW SHE CHOSE TO ADD A TEN NOT
THE CLOSEST COLLEGE OR THE
SECOND CLOSEST COLLEGE THAT WAS
A TO HER BUT INSTALL INSTEAD
ENROLLED IN THE THIRD CLOSEST
COMMUNITY COLLEGE WHICH WAS. AN
HOUR AWAY BECAUSE THAT'S WHERE
SHE FELT CONFIDENT. SHE WOULD BE
SUPPORTED IN TRANSFER LEVEL WORK
WITHOUT BEING PRESSURED INTO
ACCESS WORK THAT WOULD COST HER
TIME AND MEMBERS MONEY. WE HAVE
TO APPRECIATE THE POWER AND
INFLUENCE EDUCATORS AND
INSTITUTIONS HAVE ON STUDENTS
ESPECIALLY THOSE WHO ARE SUBJECT
TO IMPLICIT BIASES. AND STEREO
TYPE THREAT WE OWE IT TO OUR
STUDENTS TO HELP THEM CHOOSE THE
BEST CHOICE FOR THEIR INTENT
INTENDED GOAL. AND NOT INSIST ON
PRESENTING ALL POSSIBLE OPTIONS
AS EQUALLY LIKELY TO HELP THEM
SUCCEED. TODAY WITH ME TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL IS
DOCTOR ARE YOU SHALLOW VICE
CHANCELLOR FOR EDUCATIONAL
SERVICES AND SUPPORT AT THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE. AND SHE DIEGO A
COMMUNITY COLLEGE GRADUATE WITH
STUDENTS MAKING A CHANGE. THANK
YOU FOR JOINING ME. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR MEDINA AND
MEMBERS OF THE ASSEMBLY HIGHER
EDUCATION COMMITTEE MY NAME IS
DR RICE HELLO AND I SERVE AS
VICE CHANCELLOR OF EDUCATIONAL
SERVICES AND SUPPORT FOR THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE. ON BEHALF
OF THE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE I AM
PLEASED TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
AB SEVENTEEN OH FIVE I WOULD
ALSO LIKE TO EXTEND MY GRATITUDE
TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER IRWIN FOR HER
SUPPORT OF OUR COLLEGES FACULTY
AND STUDENTS. THE MORE THAN ONE
POINT EIGHT MILLION STUDENTS ARE
BY THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGES HAVE NUMEROUS GOALS BUT
NO MATTER STUDENTS GOALS PLACING
STUDENTS IN THE RIGHT COURSES
WHEN THEY ENROLL IN COMMUNITY
COLLEGE HAS A SIGNIFICANT IMPACT
ON THEIR ACADEMIC SUCCESS AND
THEIR FUTURE. PRIOR TO AB SEVEN
OH FIVE THE VAST MAJORITY OF
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGE
STUDENTS WERE PLACED IN REMEDIAL
COURSES FROM WHERE FROM WHICH
FEW SUCCESSFULLY TRANSITION TO
TRANSFER LEVEL ENGLISH AND MATH
COURSES. ATTRITION WAS HIGH
PARTICULARLY FOR AFRICAN
AMERICAN AND LATINO LATINO
STUDENTS THE PRIOR USE OF
STANDARDIZED TESTS FORCING
STUDENTS INTO LENGTHY REMEDIAL
COURSE SEQUENCES SIGNIFICANTLY
DELAYED STUDENTS ACADEMIC
PROGRESS AND FAR TOO OFTEN
COMPLETELY HALTED STUDENT
COMPLETION. AB SEVENTY FIVE
REFORM THOSE PRACTICES AND IS
PROVING TO BE ONE OF THE MOST
SIGNIFICANT EDUCATIONAL REFORMS
OF OUR TIME. DISMANTLING
STRUCTURAL BARRIERS THAT
PREVIOUSLY PREVENTED HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF STUDENTS FROM EVER
REACHING THEIR ACADEMIC GOALS.
THE TRADITIONAL PLACEMENT SYSTEM
AB SEVEN OH FIVE AND NOW AB
SEVENTEEN OH FIVE SEEK TO
REPLACE WAS A SYSTEM IN WHICH
STUDENTS HAD NO CHOICE. AND THE
CHOICE IS MADE FOR THEM WERE
COUNTERPRODUCTIVE TO THE SUCCESS
OF THOSE STUDENTS AND TO THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
THESE LAWS ARE LIBERATING
STUDENT CHOICE AND EXPANDING
STUDENTS OPPORTUNITIES. A. B.
SEVEN OH FIVE MADE IT POSSIBLE
FOR THOUSANDS MORE STUDENTS
ACCESS TRAINS LEVEL. AND
SIGNIFICANTLY MORE STUDENTS ARE
SUCCESSFULLY COMPLETING THOSE
COURSES NO MATTER THEIR PRIOR
HIGH SCHOOL PERFORMANCE AND
ACROSS ALL STUDENT SUBGROUPS.
DESPITE THAT SENT US SUBSTANTIAL
PROGRESS AS ASSEMBLYMEMBER IRWIN
STATED IMPLEMENTATION OF AB
SEVEN OH FIVE REMAINS AN EVEN AN
EQUITY GAPS PROCESS FAR TOO MANY
COLLEGES ARE STILL OFFERING
SIGNIFICANT NUMBERS OF REMEDIAL
COURSES OR NOT ENOUGH TRANSFER
LEVEL COURSES WHICH INFLUENCES
STUDENTS OPTIONS AND THEIR
CHOICES. THEREFORE WE WELCOME
AND SUPPORT THE RECOMMENDATIONS
OF ASSEMBLYMEMBER IRWIN TO
CLARIFY AND STRENGTHEN A. B.
SEVEN OH FIVE S. THAT WILL HELP
EVEN MORE STUDENTS TO ACCESS
THESE ESSENTIAL TRANSFER LEVEL
COURSES. AS AN OPEN ACCESS
SYSTEM SUPPORTING 1100% OF ALL
CALIFORNIANS WE ARE COMMITTED TO
SUPPORTING ALL STUDENTS AND
ENSURING THEIR SUCCESS BY
PROVIDING THEM WITH THE SUPPORTS
THEY NEED WE STRONGLY BELIEVE AB
SEVENTEEN OH FIVE WILL HELP US
TO FULFILL THAT MISSION. THANK
YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR MEDINA
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
JUDY AGO. AND IN THE TEN YEARS
SINCE I STARTED AT MOUNT SAN
ANTONIO COLLEGE I'VE GRADUATED
SUMMA **** LAUDE FROM UC SANTA
BARBARA. RECEIVE A HARVARD
FELLOWSHIP. BECOME A PP I SEE IN
TURN AND IN DOWN A CAL STATE
MASSIVE STUDENT AND PROGRAM
COORDINATOR FOR SOON TO MAKE A
CHANGE. NO SMACK WHICH IS A
BLACK IN LATIN ACCIDENT LED.
ORGANIZATION THIS IS ALL BECAUSE
I'D FACULTY LIKE RAINY WILSON
BELIEVE HIM CAPACITY MY
CAPABILITY FOR ANY LEAGUE
INSTITUTION EVER DID. AND IT
NEVER WOULD HAVE HAPPENED IF I
HAD EVER GONE SECOND MEDIATION
ARE LIKE MANY OF MY PEERS TO
DEAL FACULTY WHO DO NOT BELIEVE
WHAT THEY'RE CAPABLE OF. SADLY
THAT IS THE CASE FOR MANY
STUDENTS AND OUR CALIFORNIA
CALLED SYSTEM BUT NOT BEEN SO
LUCKY. AND THAT IS WHY I'M HERE
TO ADVOCATE FOR AB SEVENTEEN OH
FIVE AS A NECESSARY UPDATE TO AB
SEVEN OH FIVE. ACCORDING PEOPLE
I SEE EIGHTY SEVEN OH FIVE MORE
THAN DOUBLED NUMBER STUDENTS
PASSING TRANSFER OVER ENGLISH
AND MATH. IT IS VERY FIRST TERM
OF IMPLEMENTATION. UNFORTUNATELY
THIS RISING TIDE HAS NOT LIFTED
ALL BOATS EQUITABLY. AND
IMPLEMENTATION HAS VARIED
GREATLY ACROSS OUR GREAT STATE.
A TWO THOUSAND TWENTY ONE REPORT
FOR THE CALIFORNIA SOLUTION
PROJECT FOUND AT LEAST HALF OF
COLLEGES CONTINUE TO HAVE
POLICING PRACTICES THAT
DISPROPORTIONATELY HARMED AND
SET BACK BLACK AND LATINX
STUDENTS. THIS IS NOT BELIEVING
WHAT STUDENTS ARE CAPABLE OF.
AND THIS IS WHY WE NEED AB
SEVENTEEN OH FIVE. YOUR CLASSES
LOWER COMPLETION RATES FOR EVERY
GROUP RESEARCH SO FAR. AND YET
SOME OPPONENTS CLAIM THAT THESE
CLASSES ARE IMPORTANT CHOICES
THAT STUDENTS SHOULD HAVE. BASED
ON MY DIRECT WORK WITH SMACK I
CAN HARDLY SAY THAT STUDENTS
ONLY ONE CHOICES THAT ARE PROVEN
TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY'RE ABLE
TO GET TO THEIR TRANSFER NAFTA
MICHAEL'S ON TIME AS QUICKLY AS
POSSIBLE. AND THERE TYRA CONTI
HAVING TO FIGHT TO GET THAT DONE
. THE BEAUTY OF CALIFORNIA'S
HIGHER EDUCATION SYSTEM AND OPEN
ACCESS TO SOME OF THE CALIFORNIA
GOT COMMUNITY COLLEGE SYSTEM.
LIES ENTRANCE TUNES LIES ABOUT
BELIEVING WHAT THE PEOPLE OF
INVEST IN EXPANDING THAT
CAPACITY AND THE CAPABILITY.
WITH AB SEVENTEEN OH FIVE WE CAN
HELP MAKE SURE THAT THE NEXT
GENERATION HAS AN EVEN GREATER
CHANCE TO REALIZE THEIR DREAMS
THAN I DID A DECADE AGO. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME. THANK YOU. DO
WE HAVE A WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. IF THE TWO WOULD
COME UP AND I THINK WE HAVE TO
MAKE ROOM FOR THEM. AT THE TABLE.
AGAIN TWO MINUTES EACH. THANK
YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER MEDINA AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE ON
HIGHER EDUCATION MY NAME IS
JENNY MAY VICE PRESIDENT OF THE
ACADEMIC SENATE FOR CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES I THANK YOU
FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK
WITH YOU AND I TOO WAS A
COMMUNITY COLLEGE TRANSFER
STUDENT. THE S. TRIPLE C.
REPRESENTS A LOCAL ACADEMIC
SENATES OF A HUNDRED SIXTEEN
COMMUNITY COLLEGES REGARDING
AREAS OF CURRICULUM DEGREE AND
CERTIFICATE REQUIREMENTS AND
STUDENT SUCCESS WE ARE COMMITTED
TO CLOSING LONG STANDING
OPPORTUNITY AND ACHIEVEMENT GAPS
THAT CONTINUE TO PROCESS FOR
TRADITIONALLY UNDERREPRESENTED
STUDENTS WE APPRECIATE THE
INTEREST IN SUPPORT OF THIS
COMMITTEE TO ENSURE EDUCATIONAL
PROGRAMS ARE IN PLACE THAT MEET
THE DIVERSE LEARNING AND SUPPORT
NEEDS OF THE STUDENTS WE SERVE.
OLD PLACEMENT PRACTICES WERE-
EVEN UNFAIR AND
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED
STUDENTS OF COLOR WE FULLY
SUPPORT ACCESS TO TRANSFER LEVEL
COURSEWORK AND THE GAINS ARE
COMMENDABLE THAT SAID ACCESS TO
ALL LEVELS OF COURSE WORK IS
ESSENTIAL AS OPPOSED TO A ONE
SIZE FITS ALL SOLUTION THAT
STUDENTS HAVE THE BEST CHANCE OF
ACHIEVING THEIR GOALS. AS
DIRECTED BY THE DELEGATES THE A.
S. TRIPLE C. IS OPPOSING AB
SEVENTEEN OH FIVE AS THIS BILL
WOULD REQUIRE THAT ALL STUDENTS
WITH FEW EXCEPTIONS ARE PLACED
AN ENROLLED IN TRANSFER LEVEL
ENGLISH AND MATHEMATICS EVEN
WHEN THOSE COURSES ARE NOT
REQUIRED FOR THE STUDENTS
EDUCATIONAL PROGRAMS
SPECIFICALLY THE DELEGATES ARE
REQUESTING TO MAINTAIN THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE MISSION AND TO
NOT DENY STUDENTS ACCESS TO A
PRE TRANSFER CORE THAT MEETS THE
STUDENT'S EDUCATION NEEDS OR
GOALS SUCH AS THOSE IN CAREER
AND TECHNICAL EDUCATION PROGRAMS
OR FOR SKILL BUILDING. NEXT
SINCE THIS BILL WOULD ALSO
REQUIRE COLLEGES TO ENROLL
STUDENTS IT IS IMPERATIVE THAT
ALL ENROLLMENT DATA IS INCLUDED
ON THE TRANSFER LEVEL GATEWAY
COMPLETION DASHBOARD WE THINK
WESLEY AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER- ONCE
OFFICE FOR OTHERS HOPE TO
CONTINUE TOGETHER IN SEARCH OF A
STUDENT CENTERED SOLUTION THAT
WILL CLOSE GROWING EQUITY GAPS
THANK YOU YOU. THANK YOU.
GERMANY NINE COMMITTEE MEMBERS
MY NAME IS DESIREE MONTENEGRO
I'M AN FAA SEE SEE SEE BOARD
MEMBER AND FACULTY AT CERRITOS
COLLEGE AT LONG BEACH CITY
COLLEGE AND IT BY A LITTLE BIT
OF A COLLEGE TODAY I AM GRATEFUL
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE AS
A WOMAN OF COLOR I HAVE
EXPERIENCED FIRST HAND THE
VICIOUS CYCLE OF REMEDIATION IN
ENGLISH AND IN MATH REMEDIATION
NOT ONLY SET ME BACK AT LEAST
TWO YEARS IT REDIRECTED ME- FROM
AWAY FROM A STEM CAREER
UNFORTUNATELY MANY STUDENTS OF
COLOR WOMEN AND NON BINARY
INDIVIDUALS ARE
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED. BY
REMEDIATION AS A RESULT STUDENTS
ARE DISCOURAGED OR CYCLED OUT OF
PURSUING HOMOGENEOUS CAREER
FIELDS LIKE THOSE IN STEM. OR
THEY JUST DROP OUT AND LUCKILY I
PERSISTED AND I FOUND A CAREER
THAT WAS EQUALLY PASSIONATE
ABOUT. BUT NOT ALL ARE SO LUCKY
. AB SEVEN OH FIVE WAS A MUCH
NEEDED CHANGE THAT HELP THE MANY
STUDENTS WHO HAD SIMILAR
EXPERIENCES JUST LIKE ME HOWEVER
AB SEVENTEEN OH FIVE IS FLAWED
IT'S A FLAWED BILL THAT WILL
HAVE UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES FOR
OUR STUDENTS PASSED AS IS THIS
LAW WOULD CREATE A ONE SIZE FITS
ALL APPROACH TO OUR STUDENTS
THAT OVERLOOKS THEIR UNIQUE
ACADEMIC AND CAREER OBJECTIVES
IN DOING SO YOU MAY BE DOING THE
VERY THING THAT YOU ARE TRYING
TO PREVENT WITH THIS
LEGISLATION. FACC REQUESTED
AMENDMENTS FOCUSED ON SUPPORT
AND RESOURCES NEEDED FOR
STUDENTS TO BE SUCCESSFUL SUCH
AS SMALLER CLASSES A TEN TO ONE
RATIO PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT
SPECIFICALLY FOR PART TIME
FACULTY EMBEDDED FACULTY TUTORS
IN THE CLASSROOM AND UPDATED
CLASSROOMS TO SUPPORT ACTIVE
LEARNING UNFORTUNATELY THESE
AMENDMENTS WERE REJECTED WITHOUT
THESE CHANGES WE COULD BE
SETTING OUR FACULTY UP FOR
FAILURE ESPECIALLY THOSE ADJUNCT
FACULTY LIKE MYSELF. THAT ARE
NOT SUPPORTED BY OUR COLLEGES TO
TEACH A BROAD RANGE OF STUDENTS
. I WANT ALL MY STUDENTS TO BE
SUCCESSFUL BUT I NEED THE TOOLS
TO ENSURE THAT MY STUDENTS. CAN
HAVE THE SAME OPPORTUNITY THAT
I'VE BEEN ABLE TO FACILITATE FOR
MYSELF IF AB SEVENTEEN OH FIVE
IS PASSED AS IS THE RESULT WOULD
BE ANTITHETICAL TO THE HEART OF
THIS LEGISLATION. AND I WOULD.
ACTUALLY CREATE MORE BARRIERS
FOR STUDENTS TO PREPARE FOR
TRANSFER AND TO PURSUE CAREERS
EARN FAMILY SUSTAINING WAGES.
OPTIONS DEVELOP AGENCY AN AGENCY
IS WHAT PROPELLED MY RESILIENCE
AND MY ULTIMATE SUCCESS AS AN
ADJUNCT FACULTY TODAY. I AND MY
COLLEAGUES WILL CHAMPION OUR
STUDENTS REGARDLESS OF WHAT THE
OUTCOME. BUT YOU HAVE THE- TO
MAKE THE NECESSARY CHANGES TO
DATE TO THIS LOSS SO THAT YOU
CAN DO THE SAME. I IMPLORE YOU
TO CONSIDER THE FACTS. IN TWENTY
NINETEEN TO TWENTY TWENTY A
HUNDRED THOUSAND STUDENTS WHO
WERE PLACED DIRECTLY INTO
TRANSFER LEVER LEVEL MATH AND
ENGLISH CLASSES WERE
UNSUCCESSFUL AND EVEN MORE
DROPPED OUT. AB SEVENTEEN OH
FIVE DOES NOT PROVIDE ADDITIONAL
SUPPORT FOR THE STUDENTS AND
WOULD LIKELY ELIMINATE SAFETY
NETS OFFERING A WIDE RANGE OF
COURSES TO SERVE THE TOP ONE
HUNDRED PERCENT. OF STUDENTS IS
NOT A BAD THING NOT ALL STUDENTS
ARE TRANSFER STUDENTS AND AS
ADJUNCT FACULTY MEMBER I AM
ALWAYS ASKS TO DO MORE WITH
LESS. WRAP UP YOUR TIME IS UP
PLEASE. I WOULD ASK ME TO DO
EVEN MORE WITH EVEN. LESS THANK
YOU THANK YOU. I KNOW KNOW THERE
ARE ANY- TWEETERS. WHEN IT COME
UP TO THE TABLE. LET'S SEE IN
ANY AYE I'VE FAILED TO CALL FOR
THE ME TO FOLKS IN SUPPORT SO
THERE ARE WITNESSES WHO WOULD
LIKE TO GO TO THE MICROPHONE IN
SUPPORT IF YOU SAY YOUR NAME THE
ORGANIZATION THAT YOU'RE WITH.
COME UP TO THE MICROPHONE YOUR
NAME YOUR POSITION ORGANIZATION
THAT YOU'RE WITH. YOUR ARE YOUR
CALLING ON THE CASE THE LAST
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE BILL THANK
YOU. TO THE MICROPHONE UP HERE
RIGHT HERE. JUST YOUR NAME MY
NAME IS TRULY A HARGROVE- I AM A
STUDENT- AT CCS F. AND I AM AN
EQUITY ADVOCATE SORRY- AND I AM
A EQUITY ADVOCATE STUDENTS
MAKING A CHANGE IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL I AM IN SUPPORT OF THE
THANK YOU. SORRY. RIGHT TO THE
POINT- HI HOW ARE YOU MY NAME IS
MARJORIE BLAND AND I MUST AS
EVIDENCES THE STATE UNIVERSITY
MAJORING IN SOCIOLOGY AND WITH A
MINOR CRIMINAL JUSTICE I'M ALSO
SEE CASF AYNAX ALUMNI CITY
COLLEGE SAN FRANCISCO AND I ALSO
ATTENDED CONTRA COSTA COLLEGE
I'M IN FAVOR AND I'M ALSO THE
DIRECTOR TO MAKE A CHANGE I'M IN
FAVOR AB SEVENTEEN OH FIVE THANK
YOU. GETTING MY NAME'S JOHNSON.
VICE PRESIDENT LEGISLATIVE
AFFAIRS FOR THE STUDENT SENATE
FOR CALIFORNIA COMMUNE COLLEGES
WHO REPRESENTS ONE POINT EIGHT
MILLION STUDENTS AND ARE THE
OFFICIAL VOICE OF COMMUNICORP TO
DANCE. WE ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU. MY NAME IS
NOT NEARBY BUT I MEAN YOU SEE
DAVIS STUDENT AND I'M A TRANSFER
FROM DE ANZA COLLEGE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE BILL. THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME'S TARKAS HIM I'M
STUDENT AT UC DAVIS AND A
TRANSFER FROM CHEEKY CALLERS IN
THE WONDERFUL INLAND EMPIRE- I'M
THE TRANSCEND AFFAIRS OFFICER
AND THE VICE CHAIR OF GOVERNMENT
RELATIONS FOR THE UC
SINICIZATION WHERE IN STRONG
SUPPORT THIS BILL. THANK YOU I'M
I'M GONNA REMIND THE WITNESSES-
TO PLEASE NOT TOUCH THE
MICROPHONE IS MAYBE WE CAN HAVE DM MEMBERS KATRINA LYNDON ON
BEHALF OF THE CAMPAIGN FOR
COLLEGE OPPORTUNITY. IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB SEVENTEEN OH FIVE
THANK YOU. ARE NOT AVAILABLE ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA EDGE
COALITION IN SUPPORT YOU. KATIE
HERN- AND PROFESSOR OF ENGLISH
AT SKYLINE COLLEGE AND CO
FOUNDER OF THE CALIFORNIA
EXPLORATION PROJECT AN
ORGANIZATION OF COMMUNITY
COLLEGE FACULTY ENGLISH. IN
ENGLISH MATH AND ESL AND WE ARE
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
SEVENTEEN OH FIVE THANK YOU SO
MUCH THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHATON STEVEN SENIOR STAFF
ATTORNEY WITH PUBLIC ADVOCATES
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
SEVENTEEN OH FIVE THANK YOU. HI
A ALEXANDER READS DEPUTY CHIEF
OF STAFF TO THE LIEUTENANT
GOVERNOR OF THE PROUD CO
SPONSOR. THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIRING COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MAYES AND JOB ALONG WITH
IMPROVE YOUR TOMORROW IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL. THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS CUTTING A
PART OF THIS HERE ON BEHALF OF
ORGANIZATIONS I COULDN'T MAKE IT
DUE TO THE LACK OF TELEPHONE IT
COMMENT I'M HERE IN SUPPORT WITH
CALIFORNIA COMPETES. THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON TURN MEMBERS
DONNA HOFFMAN CALLING IN WITH
READY NATION AND COUNCIL FOR A
STRONG AMERICA. IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. ANY OTHER
WITNESSES SAID IN SUPPORT IN THE
HEARING ROOM. WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
AS CHAIR MEMBERS MICHAEL YOUNG
WITH THE CALIFORNIA FEDERATION
OF TEACHERS ARE CRIPPLING
OPPOSITION THANK YOU THANK YOU.
STEPHANIE GOLDMAN ON BEHALF THE
FACULTY ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES AS
WELL AS THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION FOR POST SECONDARY
EDUCATION IN OPPOSITION. MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS- DAVID HAWKINS
WITH THE CALIFORNIA COMMUTE
COLLEGE INDEPENDENCE- AT THIS
TIME WE MUST OPPOSE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. NO OTHER WITNESSES NO
OTHER ONES IN OPPOSITION. ARE
THERE ANY TWEETERS AT ALL ON
THIS BILL. THE SCENE NINE. WE
WILL GO THEN TO- COMMITTEE
MEMBERS QUESTIONS OR PROBLEMS.
THANK YOU- I AM A COMMUNITY
COLLEGE STUDENT TRANSFER- WHO
TOOK MY FAIR SHARE OF REMEDIAL
MATH CLASSES- WAS NOT THE BEST
AT MATH OR WHAT I WILL SAY
THOUGH I GOTTA BE PLEASANT
STATISTICS AND HOW TO PARTY
AFTER MY FINAL MATH CLASS- I DO
THOUGH HAVE SOME CAN SHARE SOME
CONCERNS- WITH THE OPPOSITION
INCLUDING MY HE CALLED IN MY
DISTRICT HAS SOME CONCERNS WE
SHOULD NEVER MAKING IT MORE.
COMPLICATED THIS FINISHED THEIR
SEARCH PROGRAMS ARE CHIU- IN ANY
OUR PIECES OF LEGISLATION COMING
OF THIS BODY I WANT TO THANK YOU
FOR WORKING ON THIS I WOULD
HIGHLY ENCOURAGE YOU CONTINUED
TO WORK ON THE BILL. I'M GOING
TO SUPPORT IT BECAUSE  THINK
THAT WE'RE MOVING IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION BUT I AM GOING TO
REVIEW ROOM RESERVE MY VOTE ON
THE FLOOR. I'M IN HOPES THAT WE
CAN MAKE THIS BILL BETTER.
THANKS VERY MUCH ASSEMBLY MEMBER
I'D I'D- WE ALSO WANTED TO BE A
VERY EXPLICIT IN IN THE-
PROGRAMS THAT ARE EXEMPTED SO AT
AND IT WAS NEVER AS I READ
EARLIER WAS NEVER RECALL- MEANT
TO CREATE ADDITIONAL REQUIRE.
HUNTING PROGRAMS IN MULTI
DUCATION HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS IN
DUAL ENROLLMENT AS STUDENTS IN
TECHNICAL SIR TO A CERTIFICATE
OR DEGREE PROGRAMS SO ANY
PROGRAM WHERE IT IS THAT LEVEL
OF MATH IS NOT REQUIRED IS
ACCEPTED BUT WE WILL CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH YOU BECAUSE WE DO WANT
YOUR SUPPORT. IS THAT BECAUSE-
THE EX. REMEDIAL WHICH CAN TO
REALLY ELONGATES THE AMOUNT OF
TIME- ONE SPENDS IN COMMUNITY
COLLEGE TWENTY FOUR THIS BILL
BEFORE STEP SEVEN OH FIVE PASSED
THE AVERAGE STUDENT SPENT SIX
YEARS IN COMMUNITY COLLEGE
THAT'S A LOT OF STUDENTS THAT
WE'RE LOOKING AT A MOVING ON TO
FOUR YEAR PROGRAM ESPECIALLY FOR
STUDENTS THAT DON'T HAVE THE
MEANS THAT IS THAT TIME THEY
CANNOT AFFORD TEN INCOME COLLEGE
SO WE'RE JUST THAT THE NOT. THE
TO P. SYRUP TO BIG THAT THAT
SEVEN OH FIVE SIX BUT WE TO MAKE
SURE THAT EVERY STUDENT IN STATE
. WELL TO BENEFIT SEVEN OH FIVE
SO THESE ARE JUST A CLEAR-
WORKING WITH THE FACT WITH FACT
IN THE DIFFERENT- FACULTY GROUPS
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE GOT IT
RIGHT AND I'M NOT SURE IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO ADD ANYTHING.
AFTER YOU COVERED. DR JOY.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ROLE IN I WHAT
DOES TO EXPRESS MY FEELINGS
TOWARDS THIS ONE- AS A FORMER
UNIVERSITY AND THEN ALSO
COMMITTED COLLEGE OF FACULTY
MEMBER- I AM I GUESS IN THIS
CASE- A TWEENER. I UNDERSTAND
THAT YOU APPOINT THE SO THAT-
COLLEGES STUDENTS ARE SHOULD BE
GIVEN OPPORTUNITY FOR THEM TO OF
FACED- ACTUALCLASSES- AND THE
BASED UPON THEIR ABILITY TO PASS
OFF A- AND- A MOVEON IN A SHORT
TIME AS SHORT AS POSSIBLE. AND
THAT THE- THE- OPPOSING- THE
ORGANIZATIONS- I DO SEE THE-
MANY COMMUNITY COLLEGES SET
THEMSELVES THE SENATE THE OR SO
OPPOSED TO THIS BILL. AND THEN
ON I THE NAY- COTTAGE PROFESSOR
WAS ATTENDING ME- DEPLORING. OF
ON. OF ENTER FRESH. AND THAT
THEY ARE SPENDING SO MUCH TIME
AND THE RESOURCES- TO REMEDY
THOSE OF STUDENTS. SO I THINK
THAT THIS A REMEDIAL CLASSES FOR
OR REGION ON THE DESIGNED TO
HELP THEM TO SUCCEED. BUT THE
OBVIOUS TO HAS BECOME THE AREA
IT TAKES TOO LONG TIME AND THE
SOME PEOPLE NEVER GET OUT OF IT
YEAH VERY LARGE PERCENTAGE OF
STUDENTS. THAT START TO LEVELS
BELOW REMEDIAL DROP OUT YOU ARE
ABSOLUTELY CORRECT AT THE SAME
TIME. AS YOU HEARD AWHILE AGO
FROM THE OPPOSITION- STATEMENTS-
THAT THE OVER A HUNDRED THOUSAND
STUDENTS OF FAITH IN THE ART OF
A REGULAR CLASS THAT TRANSFER
OVER GLASSES. SO WHAT IS THE
REAL ANSWER- WHEN I TALK TALK
KOREAN LANGUAGE AT THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES- OBVIOUSLY NO MATH NO
ENGLISH WASN'T NECESSARY AND
THEY HAVE TO LEARN. THE NEW
FOREIGN LANGUAGE IS ALL. I
WONDER WHAT BASED UPON THEIR
DECLARED- THE MAJOR OR WHAT
DIRECTION WHAT THAT THEY WOULD
LIKE TO SPECIALIZED SO WE CAN
MAKE A SOME CATEGORICAL
REQUIREMENT SO REMEDIAL MATH
ENGLISH MAY BE NECESSARY IF FOR
LAWYERS OR WHATEVER WE NEED TO
GOOD THINGS. NSIA THEY ARE
TECHNOLOGY TO OVER NEED THE AT
MATH KIA. OF OH OH I'M SORRY
YEAH. SO YOU YOU CAN SEE IS MAY
SO- IN REALLY NEED A GOOD SHOP-
NOVARRO AND I'M K. OR US REAL OF
WARREN AND NOT READ. SO YOU WITH
ABOUT THAT THAT DIRECTION HOW
YOU CAN. BASED UPON. WHICH DOES
DOES WERE ABSOLUTE- WE AT ALL
THOSE- AT. THAT DIDN'T THAT THAT
- LEVEL ESPECIALLY THE TWO YOUR
REYES AND- ALL. SAY WHAT OKAY
PROBABLY A TWO THIRDS OF THE OFF
. A MAN. AND PUT HIM INTO THE
STATISTIC THAT YOU STATED THE
NUMBER OF. THAT ARE-FEELING IS
TAKEN OF CONTEXT YOU HAVE TO
REMEMBER THAT THERE WERE MANY
MANY MANY MORE STUDENTS THAT
THAT. THAT DIDN'T MEDIA TO IT IN
ANSWERABLE US THE WAY YOU LOOK
AT THE P. NUMBER OF STUDENTS
THAT NOW PAY OUT OF PLAN. IT ASK
. WE THOSE WOULD HAVE YES PLEASE
PLACE IN OUR MEDIA AND THIS IS
NOT A THIS IS NOT WITHOUT HELLO
WHEN SEVEN OH PATH PACK WEEK
SAID THE COULD BE KALRA. SO
ADDITIONAL UNIT CLASSES TAKEN AT
THE SAME TIME THAT HELPED
ENHANCE THE LEARNING IN THOSE
TRANSFER LEVEL CLASSES WE HAVE
MONEY FOR TUTORING SO STUDENTS
CAN GET AT THE SAME TIME WHAT WE
DON'T SO THEY COULD TAKE THE
TUTORING AND HELP THEM- THAT
HELP- THE- ACHIEVE SUCCESS IN A
TRANSFER LEVEL CLASS WHAT WE
DON'T WANT IS STUDENTS TAKING
REMEDIAL CLASS AFTER MEDIAL
CLASS AND NOT DOING ANY BETTER
IN TRANSFER LEVEL CLASSES YOU.
THE DATE IT SHOWS THAT THOSE
STUDENTS THAT HAVE BEEN THROUGH
THIS OF THESE REMEDIAL CLASSES-
DROPPED OUT. OR IF AND THEN THEY
TRANSFERRED THEY THEY PASSED
FRANCE FOR LEVEL CLASSES AT A
MUCH LOWER RATE SO- I AGREE WITH
ALL THE CONCERNS YOU HAVE-
EXPRESSED AND WE THINK THAT
WE'VE TRIED TO. ADDRESS ALL OF
THE WITH. WITH SEVENTY FIVE I'M
SURE YOU WOULD LIKE TO ADD YES.
WHEN I MET. ASSEMBLY MEMBER ARE
IS SHE RIGHT SO WHEN YOU HEAR IS
THE LIKE THAT A HIGH THOUSAND
STUDENTS DID NOT PLASTER
TRANSFER LOW LEVEL COURSES
ASSEMBLY MEMBER- WAS SAYING OF
THESE STUDENTS- WHO WE- JUST
WOULDN'T SEEN IN TRANSFER LEVEL.
RIGHT WE HAD SOMEONE POPPING.
THEY WERE. STUCK IN BDO RIGHT
NOW THEY WERE SAYING STUDENTS
TRANSFER LEVEL IT IS TRUE NOT
ALL STUDENTS WILL PASS A
TRANSFERABLE COURSE ON THEIR
PERSON M- BUT RESEARCH SHOWING
THAT EVEN FOR THOSE STUDENTS TO
TAKE. AND LEVEL. ON THEIR TAMPA
ARTIST. TAKING LIKELY TO PASSED
. LEVEL ON THAT SO IT THEN THEY
HAD STAR IN REMEDIAL AT. AND SO
TO GET TO HEART OF WHAT HEAR YOU
EXPRESS WHICH IS OF CONCERN- DOT
CHOI IT'S IT REALLY THE- OF YES
STUDENTS COME WITH DIFFERENT
LEVELS OF PREPARATION- WHAT AB
SEVEN OH FIVE IS MAKING CLEAR IN
AB SEVENTEEN OH FIVE. UNTIL TO.
CLEAR WHILE. BROUGH BUT WE HAVE
. THAT HAVE NOT PROVEN MEDIA. IS
NOT THE ANSWER THAT PROBLEM SO
WHAT IS THE M. GETS THE THING.
OTHER EVEN WITH AB SEVENTY OH
FIVE FOCUS STUDENT SUPPORT IN
TRANSFER LEVEL AND- WE'VE DONE
SOME OF THAT WORK THE CALIFORNIA
MEDICAL LEDGES- BUT WE HAVE JUST
SCRATCHED THE SURFACE THERE IS
SO MUCH MORE THAT WE CAN AND
WILL DO. TO ENHANCE STUDENT
SUPPORTS WELL IN TRANSFER LEVEL
COURSES ALSO THAT WILL CONTINUE
TO SEE EVEN SOME OF THOSE
CONCERNING NUMBERS DIMINISH.
THEM IS SUMMARIZE. IT JUST OF.
IT ADDS A SENSE OF THE- BOB PASS
RATE THE- WHEN THEY PLUNGE. THE
REAR OF COURSE UP- WOULD BE
HIGHER. THAN THROUGH THE
REMEDIAL CLASSES SO WHO ARE NOT
GIVEN THAT OPPORTUNITY. SO US
AND SELL REMEDIAL CLASSES ALFA.
RESENTED THE UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES SO LET'S GIVE IT A
TRY HERE YOU KNOW I COME FROM IN
A NON ENGLISH SPEAKING COUNTRY
MUST OFFER. I FINISHED MY IN A
COLLEGE AND INTO GRADUATE SCHOOL
AND A BUT I HAD THE THROUGH THE
MONTHS OF- ENGLISH ORIENTATION
PROGRAM. OUT WITHOUT ANY SUCH
PREPARATION IF I JUMPED INTO IT
THE I MIGHT HAVE VALUE I DON'T
KNOW IT MIGHT HAVE TAKEN A LOT
LONGER SO THE ORIENTATION
LANGUAGE PROGRAM. I DIDN'T HELP
US SO I THINK THAT THAT WAS ALL
REGIONAL INTENT DOUBLE REMEDIAL
CLASSES UP BUT THAT THIS HAS-
DRENCH THE TOO LONG AND THE-
CONSEQUENCES TO WERE NOT THE
REALLY- RESULTING IN A GOOD
DIRECTION SO- STATISTICALLY-
PASS RATE WHEN THEY JUMP INTO
THE ACTUAL CLASSES- DEPENDING
UPON WHAT CLASSES SAID THEY ARE
TAKING THE SUCCESS RATE. HI
LESTER SOME I GET MY- CORRECT.
AND NOT ALL AND SIMPLE OF. I
HAVE A CUP OF QUESTIONS- SO OH
FIVE. DIDN'T GET RID OF REMEDIAL
CLASSES IS THAT CORRECT. SO
SEVEN SEVEN OH FIVE WHAT IT DID
IS ALLOWED FOR USING OF VARIOUS
MEASURES NOT JUST RELYING ON THE
PLACEMENT TEST RIGHT TO PUT
STUDENTS IN IN TWO CLASSES RIGHT
- AND ONE OF THE REASONS ARE YOU
BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD I
UNDERSTAND IS A- THAT. WE
HAVEN'T SEEN- THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES- SUPPORT MOVES INTO
THIS DIRECTION- ANALYSIS IS
WOULD THAT BE A FAIR STATEMENT.
THERE'S MANY A COMMUNITY
COLLEGES THAT HAVE FULLY
EMBRACED OF SEVEN OH FIVE AND
THE NUMBERS COMING OUT OF THOSE
COLLEGES ARE REALLY ASTOUNDING
BUT THERE ARE STILL- GROUPS OF
COLLEGES THAT HAVE NOT OF FULLY
EMBRACED- SEVEN OH FIVE BUT YEAH
OBVIOUSLY THE CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE YES IT IS IF I CAN ADD TO
THAT I WOULD SAY THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE SYSTEM DID FULLY LEAN
INTO IMPLEMENTING EIGHTY SEVEN
OH FIVE TO THE LETTER OF THE
LAW. INSTANT WITH THE STRICT.
AND WOULD PLACEMENT THAT'S WHY
YOU'RE SEEING THE ADDITION OF
THE LANGUAGE AROUND ENROLLMENT
IN AB SEVENTEEN OH FIVE- SO IN
SOME INSTANCES IT WAS AN
APPROACH OF WELL THE OPTION IS
THERE A STUDENTS CAN BE PLACED
THERE- BUT IT IS LEFT OPEN I
WOULD SAY TOO MANY DOORS- TO ONE
STUPID CHOICE SO THAT STUDENTS
WERE STILL IN. IN THESE COURSES
AND IF DIDN'T OR THEY FISH WELL.
THEY WERE THERE WAS LIMITATION
THE COLLEGES THAT- BUT THERE DE
ROOM FOR. MORE TOWARDS THE
SPIRIT OF THE LAW AND WHAT IT
SOUGHT TO ACHIEVE SO THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THIS BILL AND
SEVEN OH FIVE IS WHAT. THE
STRONG FOCUS ON NOT JUST
PLACEMENT BUT ENROLLMENT
ACTUALLY FLAGGING THAT THE
DESIRE OF THIS BILL IS NOT
SIMPLY THAT STUDENTS HAVE AN
OPTION- THAT THEY COULD BE PLACE
BUT THAT UP YOU'RE ACTUALLY
ENSURING. THAT WE ARE COUNSELING
THEM IN SUCH A WAY THAT THEY ARE
ROLLING IN THE COURSES THAT ARE
BEST FOR THEM I'D ALSO BRING
SOME IMPORTANT CLARITY ABOUT
WHERE THE SUPPLIES IN WHERE IT
DOESN'T BECAUSE THERE WAS
CONFUSION. WITH IN BUILD UP
THAT'S CLEARED FOR- IT ALSO
BRINGS- IN IMPORTANT FLAG TOWARD
CONCURRENT SUPPORT AND ALLOWING
COLLEGES TO REQUIRE CONCURRENT
SUPPORT A WHICH IS A VERY
IMPORTANT CHANGED AS WELL. I'M
GONNA. IF THERE'S ANYBODY WHO
SPOKE IN THE OPPOSITION WHO
WOULD LIKE TO RESPOND TO MY
QUESTION. AS TO WHY COLLEGES
HAVE NOT. MORE READILY EMBRACE.
SEVEN OH FIVE. OR SUPPORTED THE
SENTIMENT THE FEELING BEHIND
SEVEN OH FIVE. SO I'M NOT SURE
WHY THERE IS THAT SENTIMENT OR
FEELING BEHIND THAT- THE
ACADEMIC SENATE HAS WORKED WITH
FACULTY STATEWIDE UP AND DOWN
THE STATE TO FULLY IMPLEMENT AB
SEVEN OH FIVE FACULTY ARE IN
FULL SUPPORT IN GETTING STUDENTS
AND COUNSELING THEM INTO TAKING
THOSE TRANSFER LEVEL COURSES.
BUT WE DO HAVE STUDENTS THAT
HELP FOR SOME REASON THEY DON'T
WANT TO TAKE ON SUCH A FULL LOAD
OF HAVING TO TAKE A TRANSFER
LEVEL COURSE IN ADDITION TO A
SUPPORT COURSE OR THE EXTRA
WORKLOAD THAT'S REQUIRED. TAKING
JUNE MAY HAVE CHILDREN CARE FOR
THEY MAY HELP PARENTS TO CARE
FOR. THEY THEY JUST DO'T HELP
THE TIME SOME STUDENTS HAVE BEEN
OUT OF SCHOOL FOR A LONG TIME
AND THEY WANT TO EASE BACK IN.
WE'RE LOSING OUR STUDENTS IS.
THE COLOR AND WE WERE HEARING
FROM OUR FACULTY THAT ARE
WORKING WITH THE STUDENTS WERE
HEARING FROM THOSE STUDENTS.
THEY CAN'T CALL IN AND GIVE YOU
TESTIMONY RIGHT NOW BUT BUT WE
BUT I THINK YOU MAY HAVE HEARD
FROM SOME OF THE STUDENTS. BOB I
. BROWN'S WHERE STUDENTS ARE NOT
REQUIRED TO TAKE A TRANSFER
LEVEL COURSE TO MEET THOSE
REQUIREMENTS HELLO BUT MOST ALL
REQUIREMENTS CAN BE MET WITH THE
TRANSFER LEVEL COURSE AND THAT'S
THE BEAUTY OF WHAT I'M DOING
COMMUNITY COLLEGES IS THAT WE
GIVE STILL MANY WAYS TO MEET
THEIR REQUIREMENTS BUT WITH THIS
BILL STUDENTS WOULD BE COLLEGE.
UP TO RALPH. FOR LEVEL INSTEAD
OF THE PRE TRANSFER LEVEL THAT
MEETS THE REQUIREMENTS. I FULLY
APPRECIATE WANTING TO PREPARE
STUDENTS IN CASE DAY THEY WANT
TO GO TO TRANSFER INSTITUTION.
I'M REALLY. AND IT'S NOT JUST ME
IT'S OUR DELEGATES IT'S THE
FACULTY WERE WORKING WITH THEIR
THERE'S CONCERN WE COULD.
ADDITIONAL BLOCKS AND CREATE
ADDITIONAL- BARRIERS FOR
STUDENTS WHO ARE TRYING TO GET
THEIR LOCALIZATION AT DEGREES
THEIR CERTIFICATES. AND TRY TO
MOVE ON AND BE SUCCESSFUL. THE
IT'S FOR A BILL THE CLASS BUT
IT'S ALSO COLLEGE CREDIT CLASS
SO AND BECAUSE REMEDIAL CLASSES
IS NOT REALLY COLLEGE CREDIT SO
THERE'S SEVERAL LEVELS THERE'S
ONE LEFT HELLO IS TELLING AND
MATHEMATICS THAT COUNTS FOR THE
LOCAL. IT COUNTS FOR COMMUNITY
COLLEGE. CALL WHEN STUDENTS TAKE
A TRY LOW COURSE THAT TRANSFERS
TO THE FOUR YEAR INSTITUTION AND
COUNTS THERE SO WE'RE SEEING AN
ADDITIONAL NUMBER OF STUDENTS
THAT NOW HAVE A SUBSTANTIAL
GREAT NO TO ALL TRANCE CRYPT NAY
TRANSFER- INSTITUTION. BROWSE
WHEN THEY ABLE TO TAKE PRE
TRANSFER COURSE THAT MET LOW
NEED DIDN'T GET A RAISE AND GET
THROUGH THAT NOT KEEP ON WITH
THE AND- TO WRITE ABSOLUTE THE
DATE SHOWN THAT WE NOW SEE THE
STUDENTS BUT FACT NURSE SOLVE.
DATA FRANCE. FIRST FOR ME MANY
YEARS SEEN THEY NEED HELP WE
REALLY WITH LIKE TO WERE WITH
THE TO IMPROVE THIS TO THE NEW
OF OUR STUDENTS. YOU Q. KNOW I
I'D TURN OVER TO MIKE. MR LEVINE
ASK IF HE HAD A QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS HE SAID HE LIVED WELL-
I DON'T TIRE OF SAYING YOU KNOW
THAT I WAS A CLASSROOM TEACHER.
THIRTY FOUR YEARS. A LOT OF THEM
THE HIGHEST. I WAS A COMMUNITY
COLLEGE TEACHER COLLEGE OF THE
DESERT. VALLEY COLLEGE AT RISK
COLLEGE RIGHT HIS. WHO IS A
TEACHER. I SHOULD. EVERYONE'S
CAN. I ABOUT PREPARATION AND- I
SURE THAT YOU KNOW I IT IS
CERTAINLY I EXPERIENCE IT MYSELF
I THINK THE FIRST TIME THAT I
TAUGHT A CALIFORNIA HISTORY
CLASS- AT THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE-
FOR OUR C. E. AND- YOU KNOW SO
ADULT. RIGHT WHAT'S WHO HAS
DIFFICULTY. WITH THE MATERIAL
RIGHT JUST DIFFICULTY IN AND
BEING ABLE TO COMPREHEND. AND
GET THROUGH THE MATERIAL SO I
KNOW THE CHALLENGES RIGHT I
TAUGHT US HISTORY AND ALL THOSE
DIFFERENT COLLEGES FOR MANY
SEMESTERS. AT BALANCE AS THEY
VERY WELL- REMIND ME EXCEPT
1100% OF ALL STUDENTS RIGHT
WHETHER THEY'RE RIGHT OUT OF
HIGH SCHOOL OR NOT IN HIGH
SCHOOL. AND I WAS A COMMUNITY
COLLEGE TRUSTEE FOR THIRTEEN
YEARS. AND IN THOSE THIRTEEN
YEARS I GOT TO KNOW STUDENTS AND
GET TO KNOW STUDENTS WELL. AND
TO ME I SHARE THE AUTHOR'S
FRUSTRATION IN IN THAT I SAW
COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS. WHO
WERE THERE MAYBE OVER SIX YEARS
YOU KNOW INTENDING TO GET OUT
INTENDING TO GET OUT SO WHEN THE
AUTHOR BROUGHT UP SEVEN OH FIVE
I WOULD BE MUCH SUPPORTED IT I
SUPPORT THE- COMMUNITY COLLEGE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE. BEANS THEN
THE CLASSES. BUT I HAVE NOT-
HEARD A REAL GOOD REPORTS ON HOW
WELL THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES-
CAMPUSES ARE DOING IN DOING WHAT
I THINK THE AUTHOR HAD INTENDED
. COMMUNITY COLLEGE IS A TWO
YEAR COLLEGE. AND IN MY THIRTEEN
YEARS AS A TRUSTEE THE ONE GROUP
OF PEOPLE THAT I HEARD FROM THE
LOUDEST END OF THE FAILURE OF
COMMUNITY COLLEGE TO AND I SAY
THE FAILURE YOU KNOW THE
INABILITY OF COMMUNITY COLLEGE-
TO GET. THROUGH MY THIRTEEN
YEARS AS A GOOD COMMUNITY
COLLEGE TRUSTEE WAS THE LATINO
CAUCUS- THERE ARE MANY ISSUES
VERY BIG ISSUES FACING COMMUNITY
COLLEGE AND COMMUNITY COLLEGE
STUDENTS AND COMMUNITY COLLEGE
FACULTY OVER THE YEARS WE HAVE
BEEN TALKING ABOUT THOSE YOU
KNOW WE TALK ABOUT ASK YOU KNOW
SUPPORT. FOR G- INSTRUCTORS- YOU
KNOW THE RATIO OF PART TIME TO
FULL TIME IS HORRENDOUS. YOU
KNOW HAVING A SYSTEM COMMUNITY
COLLEGE SYSTEM I'M JUST
REPEATING THAT RELIES ON PART
TIME FACULTY MAKES NO SENSE. YOU
KNOW THAT SHOULD BE CHANGED. IT
STUDENTS SHOULDN'T SUFFER.
STUDENTS SHOULDN'T SUFFER AND
HAVING TO REMAIN IN COMMUNITY
COLLEGE FOR YEARS AND NOT BEING
ABLE TO GET OUT AND I ALSO SHARE
EVERYONE'S CONCERNED WITH LATINO
AND BLACK STUDENTS. WE SEE BLACK
MALES AS- A RARITY NOW IN HIGHER
EDUCATION AND OUR FOUR YEAR
COLLEGES YOU KNOW THE WE ARE
MAJORITY OF STUDENTS OF COLOR.
IN COMMUNITY COLLEGE BUT
COMMUNITY COLLEGES NEED TO DO
BETTER. FOR OUR STUDENTS
ESPECIALLY FOR STUDENTS OF COLOR
I SUPPORT THIS BILL I SUPPORT
WHAT THE AUTHOR IS TRYING TO DO.
I IN FACT I ASKED TO BE ADDED AS
A CO AUTHOR AND I WILL BE
SUPPORTING THE BILL. I'M AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME SO I HOPE TO BE
ADDED AS A AS A CO AUTHOR AND AT
THE APPROPRIATE TIME WILL HAVE A
MOTION AND WILL VOTE ON THE BILL
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS BILL
FOR. THANK YOU- MR DENY JUST BYE
BYE BYE EXCITED TO HAVE YOU
ADDED WITH THE LIEUTENANT
GOVERNOR ON THAT AT THE SAME
TIME I REALLY REALLY
APPRECIATED. WANT TO THANK G. D.
THAT IS IT HE IS AN INSPIRATION.
AND I DIDN'T GIVE YOU THE
OPPORTUNITY TO CLOSE. PLEASE
CLOSE YOU KNOW IT'S BEEN A
PLEASURE TO SERVE ON THIS
COMMITTEE WITH YOU YOU'VE BEEN
SUCH A LEADER AND CHAMPION FOR
STUDENTS ESPECIALLY IN
SUPPORTING THEIR- BASIC NEEDS-
HELPING STUDENTS MORE QUICKLY
COMPLETE THEIR EDUCATIONAL GOALS
WHICH IS WHAT HAPPENS UNDER THIS
BILL WILL SAVE THEM TIME. AND
MONEY I REALLY WANT TO THINK
YOUR COMMITTEE FOR- IMPROVING.
SEVENTEEN OH FIVE IT'S- HE
APPRECIATED. AND I ALSO WANT TO
MENTION TO THE OPPOSITION WE ARE
WORKING VERY HARD TO SECURE
EXTRA RESOURCES FOR THE CAMPUS
FACULTY AND STUDENTS TO SUPPORT
THESE CHANGES THROUGH. AB ELEVEN
EIGHTY SEVEN WHICH IS CURRENTLY
PENDING IN THE SENATE AND WILL
ENABLE A COLLEGES TO CLAIM A
PORTION OF CREDIT FOR STUDENTS
RECEIVING SUPERVISED TUTORING
AND CREDIT BEARING COURSES AND
WE'RE ALSO. I'M SPEARHEADING A
SIXTY THREE MILLION DOLLAR
BUDGET- ALLOCATION SUPPORTING CO
REQUISITE AND PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT FOR FACULTY. AND
WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR IPHONE AT THE RIGHT TIME
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MR THANK
YOU FOR BRINGING THE BILL. SO WE
WILL GO NOW TO FILE ITEM TO. MR
ARAMBULA FILE ITEM TO TWENTY
THREE FIFTEEN DOCTOR ARE AMONG.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS.
AB TWENTY THREE FIFTEEN
MINIMIZES THE CHANCE THAT A
STUDENT IS DEAD NAMES WHILE
ATTENDING THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGE BY ENSURING
THAT STUDENTS AND FACULTY WHO
ARE ATTENDING A CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGE CAN DESIGNATE
THEIR OF FIRMS WERE CHOSEN NAME
AND PRONOUNS WHILE ATTENDING A
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGE.
USE OF A STUDENTS ASSIGNED AT
BIRTH NAME RATHER THAN THEIR
CHOSEN OR AFFIRM TO NAME IS
KNOWN AS DEAD NAMING.
SPECIFICALLY FOR TRANSGENDER OR
NON BINARY INDIVIDUALS BEING
DEAD NAMES BY INCORRECT STUDENT
RECORDS CAN LEAD TO UNWANTED
OUTING. BULLYING DISCRIMINATION
VIOLENCE AND A LOSS OF
EMPLOYMENT OPPORTUNITIES BY
REQUIRING FOR ALL CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGE CAMPUSES TO
UPDATE THEIR INTERNAL SYSTEMS TO
ACCOMMODATE ANY INDIVIDUAL'S OR
FIRM'S NAME AND IDENTIFY THEIR
PRONOUNS OUR PUBLIC SYSTEM CAN
AVOID THE ACT OF DEAD NAME.
THERE ARE TWO WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY THREE
FIFTEEN TODAY TOMMY MARTIN
LEGISLATIVE DIRECTOR FOR A
QUALITY CAL. AND STEPHANIE
GOLDMAN THE ASSOCIATE DIRECTOR
FOR THE FACULTY ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
WITH PERMISSION OF THE CHAIR
THEY WILL BE READING STATEMENTS
FROM OUR WITNESSES WHO ARE NOT
ABLE TO BE HERE IN PERSON TODAY
. SO EACH WITNESS TWO MINUTES.
MAYBE IN WHEN YOU'RE READY THANK
YOU GOOD AFTERNOON SHERRIN
COMMITTEE MEMBERS TOMMY MARTIN
ON BEHALF OF EQUALITY CALIFORNIA
WE'RE PROUD CO SPONSOR OF THE
BILL WHICH ENHANCES- THIS
LEGISLATURE'S RECORD OF I
ENSURING THAT COLLEGE STUDENTS
AND GRADUATES HAVE ACADEMIC
RECORDS THAT REFLECT THEIR
AUTHENTIC SELVES- THE OTHER
AUTHOR MENTION I'LL BE SHARING
TESTIMONY FROM ONE OF OUR
WITNESSES WHO COULDN'T BE HERE
TODAY AND PERSON. SHE SAYS GOOD
AFTERNOON SHARING COMMITTEE
MEMBERS I'M ERIN POLLARD THE
MANAGER OF STUDENT EQUITY AT
IRVINE VALLEY COLLEGE A
COMMUNITY COLLEGE IN IRVINE
CALIFORNIA I'M ALSO A LICENSED
MARRIAGE AND FAMILY THERAPIST
LICENSED PROFESSIONAL CLINICAL
COUNSELOR AND HAVE SPECIALIZED
IN GENDER AFFIRMING CARE FOR
TRANS AND NON BINARY PERSONS FOR
THE PAST FOURTEEN YEARS. I LED
THE CREATION OF A NAME
INCLUSIVITY PROGRAM IN MY
DISTRICT AND I'M CURRENTLY
WORKING ON IMPLEMENTING PRONOUN
OPTIONS FOR STUDENTS I ALSO
TEACH AND TRAIN OTHER COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISTRICT AND HOW TO
CREATE THESE PROGRAM. FIRST HAND
KNOWLEDGE OF CREATING AND USING
THESE PROGRAMS AS WELL AS
WITNESSING THEIR IMPACT ON OUR
QUEER AND TRANS STUDENTS. THIS
BILL IS CRITICAL TO CREATING
SAFE CAMPUSES FOR OUR TRANS AND
NON BINARY STUDENTS. IT IS
IMPORTANT THAT THE COMMITTEE
UNDERSTAND THAT ACCESS TO EASILY
CHANGE ONE'S NAME THROUGHOUT
THEIR CAMPUS SYSTEMS. IS A
SAFETY AND PRIVACY ISSUE FOR OUR
TRANS AND NON BINARY STUDENTS.
THIS IS NOT SIMPLY ABOUT COMFORT
OR PREFERENCE. OUTING A STUDENT
BY USING THEIR LEGAL NAME OR
DIED NAME CAN PUT OUR
TRANSCENDENCE AND REAL PHYSICAL
DANGER. AT RISK FOR HARASSMENT
BY OTHERS HAVE SERIOUS SOCIAL
IMPLICATIONS AND SIGNIFICANT
SIGNIFICANTLY IMPACT THEIR
MENTAL HEALTH. IN FACT THIS IS
ACKNOWLEDGED BY THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION. AND
AVAILABLE ON THEIR WEBSITE WHICH
STATES THAT A TRANSGENDER OR
GENDER NONCONFORMING STUDENT.
MAY NOT EXPRESS THEIR GENDER
IDENTITY OPENLY AND ALL CONTACTS
INCLUDING AT HOME. REVEALING A
STUDENT'S GENDER IDENTITY OR
EXPRESSION TO OTHERS MAY
COMPROMISE THIS. THUS PRESERVE.
PRIVACY IS OF THE UTMOST
IMPORTANCE THE RIGHT OF
TRANSGENDER STUDENTS TO KEEP
THEIR TRANSGENDER STATUS PRIVATE
IS GROUNDED IN CALIFORNIA'S ANTI
DISCRIMINATION LAWS AS WELL AS
FEDERAL AND STATE LAWS. AND
WHILE MANY OF OUR CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGE CAMPUSES HAVE
VOLUNTARILY CREATED NAME
INCLUSIVITY PROGRAMS THAT
PROVIDE STUDENTS THE ABILITY TO
CHANGE THEIR UNOFFICIAL FIRST
NAME AND CAMPUS SYSTEMS. AS WELL
AS THE ABILITY TO ADD THEIR
PERSONAL PRONOUNS MANY HAVE NOT.
THIS LEGISLATION WOULD BRING THE
REST OF THE CCC SYSTEM INTO
ALIGNMENT WITH OUR SYSTEM VALUES
OF PROTECTION WELL G. B. T. Q.
PLUS STUDENTS. WE MUST ENSURE
THAT STUDENTS ARE NOT
EXPERIENCING THE CATASTROPHIC
PERSONAL IMPACTS OF BEING OUTED
AND A NAMES ON OUR CAMPUSES
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON STEPHANIE GOLDMAN
ASSOCIATE DIRECTOR OF THE
FACULTY ASSOCIATION OF THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
PROUD SPONSORS OF THIS BILL. I'M
READING THIS TESTIMONY ON BEHALF
OF OUR WITNESS WHO CANNOT ATTEND
IN PERSON TODAY. MY NAME IS HOW
CAN I GO AND I'M THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE SAN FRANCISCO
CITY AND COUNTY'S OFFICE OF
TRANSGENDER INITIATIVES I'M ALSO
PART OF. PART TIME FACULTY AT A
LOCAL COMMUNITY COLLEGE WHERE I
TEACH IN THE HEALTH EDUCATION
DEPARTMENTS. I'M TESTIFYING
BEFORE YOU TODAY IN SUPPORT OF
AB TWENTY THREE FIFTEEN BECAUSE
THIS BILL IS UTTERLY AT
LIFESAVING. FOR TRANSGENDER NON
BINARY CALIFORNIANS AS IT
AFFORDS GENUINE ACCESS TO
EDUCATION AND EMPLOYMENT
OPPORTUNITIES TO MEMBERS OF OUR
COMMUNITY. THE SAD REALITY IS
THAT TODAY AND EVERY DAY ACROSS
COMMUNITY COLLEGE CAMPUSES
STUDENTS AND EMPLOYEES ARE OUTED
AS TRANSGENDER. DEAD NAMED
HARASSED AND ULTIMATELY EXCLUDED
FROM EDUCATIONAL AND EMPLOYMENT
OPPORTUNITIES. FOR TRANS GENDER
NON BINARY PEOPLE SYSTEMATIC
THAT NAMING IS SO HARMFUL THAT
WE LEAVE CLASS AND NEVER RETURN.
FURTHER BEING DEAD MEMES MAKES
US TARGETS FOR VIOLENCE FOR. 22%
OF COLLEGE OF OCCASIONAL SCHOOL
STUDENTS. WERE OUT OR PERCEIVED
AS TRANSGENDER IN CALIFORNIA ARE
VERBALLY PHYSICALLY AND OR
SEXUALLY HARASSED BECAUSE OF
BEING TRANSGENDER. BEING
EXCLUDED FROM EDUCATION
EMPLOYMENT SETTINGS MEANS BEING
SHUT OUT FROM ECONOMIC STABILITY
BECAUSE COMMUNITY COLLEGES ARE
OFTEN THE ONLY AFFORDABLE AND
ACCESSIBLE WAY FOR CALIFORNIANS
TO GAIN. THE EDUCATION NEEDED TO
FURTHER OUR CAREERS. IT'S NOT
SURPRISING THEN THAT OUR
COMMUNITY EXPERIENCES
UNEMPLOYMENT AND MORE THAN THREE
TIMES THE RATE OF THE GENERAL
POPULATION. THIS BILL WOULD
CHANGE THAT. AB TWENTY THREE
FIFTEEN WILL ELIMINATE THE
PERVASIVE DEAD NAMING OF
TRANSCEND NINE BEARING EVERY
PEOPLE IN THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
SYSTEM. AND ENSURE THAT ALL
COMMUNITY COLLEGES ASSIST PLACE
HONOR STUDENTS AND EMPLOYEES
CORRECT NAMES AND PRONOUNS.
MAKING SAFER. I'M EXAGGERATING
WHEN I THE THIS BILL WILL SAVE
LIVES I WORKED IN THE
TRANSGENDER ADVOCACY FOR SIXTEEN
YEARS AND I'VE WITNESSED IN MY
COMMUNITY THE SERIOUS
CONSEQUENCES BEING EXCLUDED.
FROM EDUCATION AND EMPLOYMENT
SETTINGS I PERSONALLY LOOK
FORWARD TO THE DAY WHEN TRANSIT
NINE VERY MERRY STAFF STUDENTS
AND FACULTY OF THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES FEEL SAFE COMING TO
CLASS. THANK YOU. ANY WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION. SEEING NONE OF
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT COME TO THE
MICROPHONE. MISTER CHAIRMAN
BIRDS SAID DAVID HAWKINS
CALIFORNIA COLLEGE INDEPENDENT
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. MICHAEL
YOUNG WITH THE CALIFORNIA
FEDERATION OF TEACHERS ALSO IN
SUPPORT. DAVID BRYANT CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE PLEASED TO BE IN SUPPORT
ALSO ONE OF THE SUPPORT OF
LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR LENNY CAN
UNLOCK AS A MEMBER OF OUR BOARD
OF GOVERNORS. NANCY WITH THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL EMPLOYEES
ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT THANK
YOU. AGAIN ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. ANY ANY TWEETERS. I
SEE NINE ACTIONS COMMENTS FROM-
THE DICE FROM THE COMMITTEE. I
THINK THERE ARE I UNDERSTAND NOW
WHAT YOUR BILL IS- INTENDING TO
DO I WONDER- AS SHE IS SO HAS
THERE BEEN ANY PROBLEM. HI I
THINK WE'VE HEARD ABOUT THE
DIFFICULTIES THAT MANY FEEL
ABOUT BEING OUTED BEING BULLIED
AND WHEN WE DON'T UP PROPRIA
LEAVE REFLECT THE NAME THEY WANT
TO BE IDENTIFIED. BY IN TO
BELIEVE IT'S IMPORTANT TO
RESPECT PEOPLE'S WISHES ON HOW
THEY WISH TO BE ADDRESSED. AT
THE TIME OF- APPLICATION COLLEGE
APPLICATION THE STATE. YOUR NAME
AND THE GENDER. RIGHT WHY IN THE
MIDDLE OF THE SCHOOL. DO THEY
HAVE TO CHANGE I BELIEVE WE SAW
AN ADVANTAGE AND THERE WAS A
SILVER LINING FROM THE PANDEMIC
WHERE MANY PEOPLE WHO WERE
PARTICIPATING IN ONLINE SCHOOL
WERE ABLE TO IDENTIFY
THEMSELVES. WERE ABLE TO NAME
THEMSELVES AND PLACE THEIR
PRONOUNS IN THEIR SCREEN IN
THEIR BOX THAT IS NEW AND
DIFFERENT THAN HOW WE WERE
TRADITIONALLY TEACHING IN
COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND MANY
STUDENTS FOUND COMFORT IN THAT
IN BEING ABLE TO IDENTIFY AND-
USED THEIR CHOSEN NAME AS WELL
AS THEIR CHOSEN PRONOUNS AND
BELIEVE THAT IT'S AN IMPORTANT
SILVER LINING FOR US TO CAPTURE
FROM THE SPEND. MAKE AT ALL TO
MILLIE STUDENTS FELT SAFER WHEN
THEY WERE ABLE TO USE THEIR OWN
AFFIRM TODAY. SO STRANGE. I WANT
TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING
IT FORWARD I BELIEVE YOU'RE
BUILDING ON OUR FORMER
COLLEAGUE- MR CHU. AND I'M
PLEASED TO SEE THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE IN
SUPPORT I THINK THIS BILL MAKES
SENSE AND I WILL BE SUPPORTING
THE BILL IF YOU'D LIKE TO CLOSE
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT WHEN THE
TIME IS APPROPRIATE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NINE. THANK
YOU. YEAH OKAY. SO WE WILL NOW
MOVE. TO- ITEM NINE FILE ITEM
NINE MISS SAID WANT THIS. FOR
CAN WE DETER GOALS. OKAY I'M
RESERVE FUND GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS FOR ALLOWING ME TO
PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
FOUR FIFTY NINE TODAY I DO WANT
TO THANK YOUR COMMITTEE STAFFER
ARE ALL OF THEIR DILIGENT
WORKING ASSISTANCE ON THIS
IMPORTANT BILL AS NOTED IN THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS I AM ASKING
THAT THIS COMMITTEE AMEND THIS
BILL TO REFLECT THE LANGUAGE
OUTLINED ON PAGE THREE OF THE
ANALYSIS. AS AMENDED AB TWENTY
<c.cyan>OUR FIFTY NINE WILL REQUIRE THE</c>
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
AND REQUEST THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA TO REQUIRE EACH OF
THEIR RESPECTIVE CAMPUSES. THAT
PROVIDE STUDENT HOUSING TO POST%
DATA ON STUDENT HOUSING
INCLUDING THE NUMBER OF STUDENTS
ON THE HOUSING WAIT LISTS ON A
MONTHLY BASIS AT EACH CAMPUS. ON
EACH CAMPUS IS WEBSITE. I WANT
TO NOTE THAT THIS BILL ONLY
APPLIES FOR PUBLIC INSTITUTIONS
OF HIGHER LEARNING. AB TWENTY
FOUR FIFTY NINE WILL ALSO
REQUIRE EACH SEGMENT TO SUBMIT
AN ANNUAL REPORT TO THE
LEGISLATURE COMPILING THIS DATA
FOR THEIR ENTIRE SEGMENT. OUR
STATE HAS GENERALLY STARTED
MEETING STUDENT HOUSING NEEDS AS
A RESPONSIBILITY OF HIGHER
EDUCATION INSTITUTIONS. HOWEVER
SINCE CAMPUSES DO NOT REGULARLY
ORIGINALLY PROVIDE DATA ON
OCCUPANCY RATES IN A WEIGHTLESS
FOR STUDENT HOUSING ON THE
CAMPUS TO CAMPUS BASIS WE ARE
UNAWARE OF WHETHER OR PUBLIC
INSTITUTIONS OF HIGHER LEARNING
OUR MEETINGS THOSE HOUSING
NEEDS. ACCORDING TO AN L. A-
REPORT FROM TWENTY TWENTY ONE.
YES YOU REPORTED THIRTEEN
CAMPUSES WHAT WAIT LISTS
TOTALING EIGHT THOUSAND SEVEN
HUNDRED STUDENTS DR YOUR IS UP
FROM A WAIT LIST OF FIVE
THOUSAND EIGHT HUNDRED AND
TWENTY NINETEEN. IN THE FALL OF
TWENTY TWENTY ONE EIGHT UC
CAMPUSES REPORTED WAIT LIST
TOTALING MORE THAN SEVEN
THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED STUDENTS.
SOME CAMPUS SUPPORT WEIGHTLESS
CREASES ABOVE PRE PANDEMIC
LEVELS. THIS BILL WILL HELP
PROVIDE MORE TRANSPARENCY TO
THIS LEGISLATURE INTO OUR
STUDENTS BY ENSURING THAT THIS
IMPORTANT DATA IS REGULARLY
UPDATED AND PUBLICLY AVAILABLE
ON THE INTERNET. THIS WILL ALSO
THIS WILL ALLOW THE LEGISLATURE
TO EXERCISE PROPER OVERSIGHT
OVER PUBLIC INSTITUTIONS OF
HIGHER LEARNING. ACCURATELY
ASSESS EACH CAN ASSIST STUDENT
HOUSING NEEDS OUR STUDENTS
PARTICULARLY FINANCIALLY UNDER
RESOURCE STUDENTS ALSO NEED MORE
COMPLETE AND ACCURATE
INFORMATION TO MAKE WELL
INFORMED HOUSING DECISIONS. AT
THEIR RESPECTIVE CAMPUSES THIS
WILL HELP ELIMINATE FRUSTRATION
AND CONFUSION EXPERIENCED BY
STUDENTS ON A HOUSING CAMPUS A
WAITING LIST. AND THEY HAVE TO
DECIDE WHETHER TO SEEK
ALTERNATIVE HOUSING OPTIONS THE
TRANSPARENCY PROVIDED BY THIS
BILL WILL ONLY IMPROVE OUR
POLICY MAKING AND THIS
LEGISLATURE AS WELL AS ALLOW OUR
STUDENTS TO HAVE THE INFORMATION
THEY NEED TO MAKE GOOD HEALTH
DECISIONS. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU. I
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. ANY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. NOT SEEN
ANY ANY WITNESSES. IN OPPOSITION
ANY WITH ANY ANY- IN THE HEARING
ROOM WOULD WANT TO. SPEAKING
SUPPORT NOPE AND NONE IN THE
HEARING ROOM ON A SPEAKING
OPPOSITION ANY TWEETERS NO. OKAY
WE GOT SOMEBODY. GOOD AFTERNOON
MR SHARE MEMBERS TO TENDER MOLLY
HERE ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
STATE UNIVERSITY SYSTEM- WE DO
NOT HAVE AN OFFICIAL POSITION ON
THIS BILL AT THIS TIME BUT HAVE
BEEN ENGAGED WITH CONVERSATIONS
WITH THE AUTHOR'S OFFICE AND
LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING. TO
WORK OUT WORK WITH THEM ON THIS
LEGISLATION AS THE BILL MOVES
FORWARD THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
THE COMMITTEE. SEEING NONE IF
YOU'D LIKE TO CLOSE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
AND I THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING THE BILL FORWARD AND WE
WILL BRING IT UP WHEN WE HAVE A
REPORT. I THINK YOU HAVE ONE
MORE BILL TO PRESENT FILE ITEM
TEN A. B. TWENTY FOUR NINETY ONE. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
THIS BILL IS VERY SIMILAR TO MY
EIGHTY. SEVEN TEN FROM TWENTY
NINETEEN WHICH THIS COMMITTEE
APPROVED UNANIMOUSLY THREE YEARS
AGO IN RECENT YEARS THE COST TO
ATTEND COLLEGE HAS GROWN. AT A
RATE FOUR TIMES GREATER THAN THE
RATE OF INFLATION. FOR STUDENTS
THAT OUR PUBLIC HEART EDUCATION
INSTITUTIONS HOUSING AND OTHER
NON. I TUITION EXPENSES MAKE UP
THE MAJORITY OF THE COST OF
ATTENDANCE. THE ACCESSIBLE AND
TRANSPARENT DATA WE PROVIDE TO
STUDENTS ON THE PERSPECTIVE COST
OF ATTENDANCE INFLUENCES THE
CHOICES THEY MAKE ABOUT WHICH
COLLEGE TO ATTEND WHETHER OR NOT
TO TAKE LOANS TO PAY FOR THEIR
HIGHER EDUCATION. UNDER EXISTING
LAW THERE IS NO STANDARD SYSTEM
WIDE PROCESS TO CALCULATE
HOUSING COSTS COLLEGES HAVE
CONSIDERABLE DISCRETION IN THIS
pAREA. THIS LACK OF ACCURATE AND
READILY ACCESSIBLE INCONSISTENT
HOUSING COSTS DATA MEANS THERE
IS NO GUARANTEE OUR STUDENTS
WILL BE ABLE TO REALLY COMPARE.
THE COST OF ATTENDANCE BETWEEN
DIFFERENT INSTITUTIONS OF HIGHER
EDUCATION. INSTITUTIONS OF
HIGHER LEARNING SHOULD BE
UPDATING THEIR HOUSING COSTS ON
A FREQUENT BASIS IN ORDER TO
KEEP UP WITH THE STATE'S EVER
FLUCTUATED HOUSING MARKET. ONLY
THEN WILL OUR STUDENTS TO BE
ABLE TO HAVE ACCURATE COST. OF
ATTENDANCE INFORMATION. THERE IS
NO SMALL MATTER AN ACCURATE DATA
ON STUDENT ON HOUSING COSTS WILL
LEAD TO PROSPECTIVE AND CURRENT
STUDENTS TO MAKE AN ACCURATE
BUDGET BUDGETING DECISIONS. THIS
CAN LEAD STUDENTS EITHER COME UP
SHORT OR ABLE TO PAY FOR COLLEGE
OR LEAD STUDENTS TO TAKE ON MORE
LOANS AND THEY NEED. LEADING TO
EXCESSIVE STUDENT LOAN DEBT.
THIS PROGRAM DISPROPORTIONATELY
AFFECTS MANY LOW INCOME STUDENTS
AND STUDENTS OF COLOR WHO LIKE
WE DO NOT HAVE THE UNLIMITED
RESOURCES. AT THEIR DISPOSAL TO
FIND THEIR DREAMS OF ATTENDING.
A COLLEGE. AND TIE AND ATTAINING
A COLLEGE DEGREE. AB TWENTY FOUR
NINETY ONE WILL HELP SOLVE THIS
ISSUE BY REQUIRING INSTITUTIONS
OF HIGHER LEARNING TO USE THE
FEDERAL DEPARTMENT. OF HOUSIG
AND URBAN DEVELOPMENT FAIR
MARKET RENTS DOCUMENTATION
SYSTEM TO STANDARDIZE THE
HOUSING COSTS FOR STUDENTS.
PURSUANT TO FEDERAL LAW HI TO
HAS RELIABILITY. PUBLISHED
ANNUAL UPDATE TO THE FAIR
HOUSING RENT SYSTEM SINCE FOR
THE LAST FORTY FIVE YEARS. THE
FAIR MARKET IN. MARKET RENTS
DATA IS PUBLICLY AVAILABLE AND
MORE ACCURATELY PORTRAYS A COST
FOR HOUSING AND SURROUNDING
COMMUNITIES THEN STUDENT
SURVEYS. CALIFORNIA STUDENTS
SHOULD NOT BE PRICED OUT OF
THEIR COLLEGE DREAMS OR FORCED
TO TAKE OUT MORE LOANS AND THEY
NEED BECAUSE WE- ARE THE STATE
HAVE FAILED TO PROVIDE THEM WITH
ACCURATE DATA ON HOUSING. ON
HOUSING CROSS ACROSS THE STATE
THIS BILL WILL HELP OUR STUDENTS
ESPECIALLY LOW INCOME STUDENTS
AND STUDENTS OF COLOR. AS WE
HELP PAINT AN ACCURATE PICTURE
OF THE FINANCIAL RESOURCES THEN
THEY THAT THEY PERSONALLY NEED
TO MAKE IT ALL THE WAY THROUGH
TO THE COMMENCEMENT. FOR THESE
REASONS I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU ANY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. IN THE
HEARING ROOM ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. ANY POINTERS. C.
NINE QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
THE COMMITTEE. C. NINE I THANK
THE AUTHOR AGAIN FOR BRINGING IT
FORWARD THE BILL FORWARD AND I
WOULD ASK IF SHE WOULD CONTINUE
TO WORK WITH THE SEGMENTS- TO
HELP ALLEVIATE SOME OF THEIR
CONCERNS CERTAINLY AND WITH THAT
IF YOU'D LIKE TO CLOSE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR TO VOTE. ON
THIS BILL TODAY THANK YOU AND
WILL BRING IT UP WHEN WE HAVE A
CORE. THANK YOU THANK YOU. AND
SEE NO OTHER AUTHOR IN THE ROOM
I'M IN A CALL NOW. YES MISTER
RAMOS. MISTER ROBERTS OF YOU'D
LIKE TO COME FORWARD. AND THAT
IS FILE ITEM. TWENTY TWENTY FOUR
AB. NINETEEN THIRTY SIX. THE
REVOLUTION WELCOME MISTER RAMISH.
BEGIN WHEN YOU'RE READY. THANK
YOU THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR-
THANK YOU FOR A KNOWLEDGE INTO
THE AUTHORS IN THE ROOM- I
WANNA- THANK YOU FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY PRESENT A. B.
NINETEEN THIRTY SIX. AB NINETEEN
THIRTY SIX WAS STRIKE THE NAME
OF HASTINGS FROM THE UNIVERSITY
OF CALIFORNIA COLLEGE OF THE LAW
. THIS BILL WOULD ALSO- BRING
TOGETHER THROUGH A COLLABORATIVE
CONSULTATION PROCESS AMONG THE
ROUND VALLEY INDIAN TRIBES THE
YUKI- COMMITTEE AND THE COLLEGE
OF THE LAW. IT WOULD ALSO ENACT
RESTORATIVE JUSTICE POLICIES FOR
THE YUKI AND ROUND VALLEY INDIAN
PEOPLE. I WANT TO THANK THOSE
WHO WILL BE SPEAKING FOR THEIR
ON GOING COMMITMENT THAT HAS LED
TO OVER TEN MEETINGS WHERE WE
WORKED THROUGH SOME TOUGH ISSUES
. WHERE WE ARE COMMITTED TO
CONTINUE TO WORK TOGETHER ON THE
RENAMING AND THE REMAINING
ISSUES THE STANDARD FRONT OF US
. A LITTLE BACKGROUND SIR ERNEST
HASTINGS PAID FOR MALICIOUS THAT
BROUGHT GENOCIDE AND ATROCITIES
UPON THE CALIFORNIA INDIAN
PEOPLE IN EDEN VALLEY IN ROUND
VALLEY M. BROUGHT TURMOIL TO THE
UKEE INDIAN PEOPLE. HOWEVER THE
DAILY MEANS THAT HASTINGS USED
TO BUILD HIS WEALTH AND HOW FUN
FOUND THE LAW SCHOOL HAS
RECEIVED LITTLE SCRUTINY UNTIL
NOW. STARTING IN OCTOBER OF TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY ONE. THE SCHOOL
AGREED TO MOVE FORWARD TO
SEPARATE FROM THE NAME OF
HASTINGS SINCE THAT POINT IN
TIME I HAVE COORDINATED TEN
MEETINGS THAT HAVE BROUGHT
FORWARD THE COLLABORATION OF
DISCUSSION WITH ROUND VALLEY
INDIAN TRIBES THE U. K. INDIAN.
IN THE LAW SCHOOL ALTOGETHER
WORKING TO ENSURE THAT WE ARE
MOVING FORWARD IN A PATH. FOR
TOO LONG THE VOICES OF THE
CALIFORNIA INDIAN PEOPLE HAVE
BEEN LEFT OUT OF DISCUSSIONS AND
DECISIONS THAT CENTER AROUND
HISTORIC TRAUMA. IN ACTIONS
INFLICTED UPON THEM DURING THE
STATE'S HISTORY. AB NINETEEN
THIRTY SIX INSURERS THAT THE
VOICE OF THE CALIFORNIA INDIAN
PEOPLE ARE AT THE TABLE TO HAVE
THEIR VOICES HEARD. BACK IN
EIGHTEEN SEVENTY EIGHT NO ONE IN
THE LEGISLATURE ASKED THE UKEE
AROUND VALLEY TRIBAL PEOPLE IT
HASTINGS WAS A GOOD NAME FOR THE
LAW SCHOOL. AB NINETEEN THIRTY
SIX FOR THE FIRST TIME INSURERS
THAT THE VOICE THAT HAS BEEN
LEFT OUT OF PREVIOUS DISCUSSIONS
IS PRESENT TO ADDRESS AND SPEAK
DIRECTLY TO THE RESTORATIVE
JUSTICE COMPONENTS THAT ARE
NEEDED. A RESTORATIVE JUSTICE
THAT STARTS TO ACKNOWLEDGE A
TRAUMATIC HISTORY OF THE PAST IT
ALSO LOOKS FORWARD TO A FUTURE
OF HEALING. AB NINETEEN THIRTY
SIX IN COLLABORATION WITH THE
STAKEHOLDERS WILL CONTINUE THIS
WORK. MY OWN CLAN THERE YOU HAVE
IT THEN PEOPLE OF SAMBAR DINO
COUNTY WAS ALMOST EXTERMINATED
GEN EIGHTEEN SIXTY SIX IN THIS
ERA IN THE SAMBAR DINO MOUNTAINS
SO IT IS PERSONAL TO ME TO
ENSURE THAT CALIFORNIA'S FIRST
PEOPLE HAVE A VOICE AT THE
TABLE. MANY TIMES IT IS
DIFFICULT TO UNDERSTAND THE
CONTINUED IMPACT OF THAT TRAUMA
. BUT I DO KNOW THAT IT BEGINS
WITH KNOWLEDGE MENT OF THE HORDE
PASSED AND THAT HAVING OUR
PEOPLE AT THE TABLE WILL
ESTABLISH A MUTUAL RESPECT. AND
SAID OF COURSE TOWARDS A
POSITIVE FUTURE. THE PROCESS MAY
TAKE TIME BUT THEN AGAIN IT'S
TAKEN MORE THAN A HUNDRED AND
FORTY YEARS FOR US TO REACH THIS
POINT TODAY. THIS IS ABOUT MORE
THAN SIMPLY MOVING ON OR
CHANGING THE LETTER HEAD OR THE
NAME ON THE LETTERHEAD. IT IS
ABOUT HELPING TO BUILD A NEW
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN THE STATE.
ITS INSTITUTIONS AND
CALIFORNIA'S FIRST PEOPLE. WITH
ME TODAY TO TESTIFY. ARE THE
COMPONENTS- WITH ME IS IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL WE HAVE THE
PRESIDENT. OF ROUND VALLEY
INDIAN TRIBES PRESIDENT- JIM
RUSS AND ALSO TESTIFYING IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL IS YUKI VICE
CHAIR COMMITTEE MEMBER MONA ON A
DOT SAID. AND ALSO WILL TESTIFY
ARM WITHIN THE TWEENER POSITION
AS CHANCELLOR AND DEAN BAGMAN OF
THE LAW SCHOOL. THANK YOU
WELCOME TO THE WITNESSES AND
JUST A REMINDER THAT EACH WILL
HAVE TWO MINUTES. MAY BEGIN
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN MEDINA AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS ON BEHALF OF
THE UK COMMITTEE I'D LIKE TO
THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER WE'RE
ALMOST FOR INCLUDING THE YOU KEY
IN THESE DISCUSSIONS
HISTORICALLY WE HAVE NOT BEEN
INCLUDED. IN ISSUES INVOLVING
NATIVES I'M HONORED TO REPRESENT
MY ANCESTORS THE U. K. WHO HAVE
LIVED IN THE RECOUNT AND AROUND
THE ROUND VALLEY AREA FOR OVER
TWELVE THOUSAND YEARS THAT YOU
KEY AREN'T THE ORIGINAL
INHABITANTS WHO FELT THE FULL
BRUNT FORCE OF SERENA'S HASTINGS
GENOCIDAL PLAN THAT STRIPPED US
OF OUR LANGUAGE CUSTOMS
TRADITIONAL. TO DID THE K. FILL
THE POOL PRO BUT SO DO THE
EIGHTEEN SO LOW. HIS PROMINENCE
INFLUENCE THE LEGISLATURE TO
PASS LAWS THAT FINANCE MASSACRES
AND ENSLAVE THE U. KING. IN THE
LAST FEW MONTHS ASSEMBLY MEN
RAMOSE HAS FACILITATED MEETINGS
WITH THE COLLEGE COUNCIL AND YOU
KING WE HAVE NEGOTIATED AND
AGREED UPON OVER TWENTY
RESTORATIVE JUSTICE INITIATIVES
. THE LAST HURDLE IS THE NAME
CHANGE MY ANCESTORS WOULD BE
HONORED IF WE CHOSE A YOU CAN
NAME. MANY UNIVERSITIES AND
GRADUATE SCHOOLS HAVE INDIAN
pHAVE INDIAN NAMES IT'S TIME WE
TURNED. THE NOTION OF FOR THANK
WHICH ON ITS HEAD LET ME REMIND
EVERYONE THAT THE ONLY NON
FOREIGN LANGUAGE IN THE UNITED
STATES ARE THE INDIGENOUS
LANGUAGES. THE RESTORATIVE
JUSTICE MEASURES INCLUDING THE
NAME CHANGE WILL AID IN THE
HEALING OF SOME OF THE SUFFERING
FROM THE ATROCITIES ASSOCIATED
WITH SERENA'S HASTINGS. THE IN A
TO GIVE ME THE U. K. COMMUNITY
HAS SUFFERED THE EFFECTS. OF
LOSS OF HOMELANDS GENOCIDAL
MURDERS OF THE ANCESTORS AND
GENERATIONAL PAIN AND TRAUMA
FROM HASTINGS ACTIONS FOR NEARLY
ONE HUNDRED SEVENTY YEARS I ALSO
AT THE STATE LEGISLATURE AND THE
COLLEGE ALLOW THE UK TO CHOOSE A
NAME FOR MORE LANGUAGE. IN ORDER
THAT THE LAW SCHOOL INCLUDING.
ALL WHO ATTEND OR SPEAK OF THIS
INSTITUTION BE PARTICIPATING IN
THE RESTORATIVE JUSTICE PROCESS
WHENEVER THE LAW SCHOOL IS
MENTION BY SPEAKING AND HELPING
. RIVERSIDE THE U. K. LANGUAGE
THE LOCAL SCHOOLS LATIN MOTTO IS
. BEYOND JUST DATA WHICH MEANS
LET JUSTICE BE DONE. THE
CALIFORNIA STATE LEGISLATURE HAS
THE OPPORTUNITY TO RIGHT THE
WRONGS OF THE EIGHTEEN SIXTY
LEGISLATURE BY. APPROVING A. B.
NINETEEN THIRTY SIX THANK YOUNG. NEXT WITNESS WHENEVER YOU'RE
READY. GOOD AFTERNOON AND THANK
YOU- CHAIRMAN MEDINA AND OTHER
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE THANK
YOU FOR THIS TIME TODAY- MY NAME
IS JAMES RESTS ON THE- TRIBAL
PRESIDENT AROUND ONLY INDIAN
TRIBES. AND MINERAL MEMBER
AROUND ALL INDIAN TRIBES I AM
TODAY I SPEAK UP ON BEHALF THE
TRIBAL COUNCIL AND I SPEAK UP IN
SUPPORT OF AB NINETEEN THIRTY
SIX. AND AS HAS BEEN MENTIONED
ALREADY I JUST WANT TO ECHO THAT
WE'VE SPENT A LOT OF TIME OVER
THE PAST FEW MONTHS WORKING. ON
THE RESTORATIVE JUSTICE ISSUES
THAT ARE INCLUDED IN THE BILL WE
FEEL IT'S VERY IMPORTANT THAT
THOSE ARE INCLUDED IN THE BILL.
AND AS AS WE MOVE FORWARD AND AS
WE LOOK TOWARDS WORKING IN A
MORE IN A POSITIVE MANNER- WITH
THE COLLEGE AND ALSO WITH ARE
YOU COMMITTEE THAT WE HAVE
APPOINTED. SO SO I DO- ONE ECHO
THAT- I DO WANNA MENTION EXCUSE
ME I DO WANT TO MENTION ARAMBULA
IS ONE OF THE OLDEST LARGEST
RESERVATIONS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. AND WE FEEL LIKE
THAT FOR MANY MANY YEARS OUR OUR
RESERVATION OUR TRIBE AND MANY
TRIBES THROUGHOUT THE STATE HAVE
HAD NO VOICE AT ALL. SO ONE OF
THE GOOD THINGS ABOUT THIS BILL
IS THAT WE'VE BEEN AT THE TABLE
AS- MONA HAS ALREADY MENTIONED
THAT WE'VE HAD A VOICE AT THE
TABLE AND WE'VE BEEN INVOLVED
AT. THE END I THINK MONA I
THANK- SOMEONE RAMOS AND ALSO-
DEFACEMENT FOR COMING TOGETHER
AT AND KEEP MOVING AND KEEP
WORKING TOWARD THIS AND- THIS IS
NOT EASY WORK TO DO IT'S A VERY
DIFFICULT WORK BECAUSE OF THE
SUBJECT MATTER. AND SO THAT'S
BEEN VERY TENSE AT TIMES AND BUT
WE'VE ALWAYS MANAGED TO BE
PROFESSIONAL AND BE POSITIVE AND
TRY TO MOVE THROUGH AS A AND
COULD TO GET THE WORK DONE THAT
WE KNOW THE NEEDS TO BE DONE. SO. ANYWAY SO ONCE AGAIN I. AS FOR
YOUR SUPPORT. AND OF NINETEEN
THIRTY SIX AB NINETEEN THIRTY
SIX AND- AND I JUST WANNA RE
EMPHASIZE THAT WE FEEL IS VERY
IMPORTANT FOR THE RESTORATIVE
JUSTICE. INITIATIVES THAT WE'VE
BEEN WORKING ON TO BE INCLUDED
IN THERE WHICH IN THIS.
MINUTE CALL NOW FOR OTHER.
BEFORE I GO TO THE TWEENER-
OTHERS WHO MAY BE IN THE HEARING
ROOM AND SUPPORT WHO GO TO THE
MICROPHONE. GIVE US YOUR NAME.
THE ORGANIZATION YOU'RE WITH.
AND YOUR SUPPORT. YOU MAY BEGIN. YEAH WE MY NAME IS APRIL
MIGUEL I'M THE- A GREAT
GRANDDAUGHTER OF ADELINE AND OF
MANY AND LELAND FULL WILDER
ANIME YOU CAN DESCENDANT AND I
REPRESENT AMERICAN INDIAN
CULTURAL CENTER OF SAN FRANCISCO
AND I SUPPORT AB ONE NINE THREE
SIX. THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIRMAN MEDINA AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS JOE OUR
VISA RODRIGUEZ. I COME HERE FROM
MAJOR MONTANA ON THE LUMINOUS OF
HEASTIE HASTINGS I GRADUATE
NINETEEN EIGHTY ONE. MY PRACTICE
PRIMARILY REPRESENTS NATIVE
PEOPLE IN MONTANA ALTHOUGH I'M
ALSO LICENSE IN CALIFORNIA. AND
I REPRESENT THE UC HASTINGS.
ALUMNI FOR JUSTICE AND
ACCOUNTABILITY WE'RE ABOUT FORTY
MEMBERS AND WE ARE HERE TO STAY
ARE STRONG SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
FOR ALLOWING ME TO BE HERE MY
NAME IS CATALINA LOZANO I
GRADUATED FROM UC HASTINGS IN%
NINETEEN EIGHTY ONE. I'M HERE ON
MY OWN BEHALF TO VOICE MY STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB NINETEEN THIRTY
SIX THANK YOU THANK YOU. MY NAME
IS DEB HART AND I'M UKEE
DESCENDANT. AND I ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT AND- I AB NINETEEN
THIRTY SIX THANK YOU. HI GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS OMAIR FOOT
SENIOR I AM A COMMITTEE MEMBER
RON BY THE RESERVATION I WAS
BORN AND RAISED THERE AND MY
FATHER WAS BORN THERE- RIGHT NOW
I'M A TRIBAL COUNCIL MEMBER SO
I'D STRONGLY ONE HUNDRED
PERCENT- AB NINETEEN THIRTY SIX
OF THEM WHOLEHEARTEDLY
APPRECIATED THANK YOU. BUT THANK
YOU- GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME
JOURNAL BRITAIN ENROLLED MEMBERS
AROUND VALLEY INDIAN TRIBES IN
RIGHT NOW CITY IN TRIBAL COUNCIL
MEMBER I'M HERE TO SHOW MY
SUPPORT FOR A BI NINETEEN THIRTY
SIX. THANK YOU. LINDA SAX
CITIZEN A CHEROKEE NATION
CONSIDERED A MENDOCINO COUNTY AN
ITEM IN SUPPORT OF AB NINETEEN
THIRTY SIX THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS AFRIKA
VARGAS AND- I'M PROUD TO HAVE
WORKED WITH THE YOU CAN
COMMITTEE AND ARAMBULA TRIED FOR
SEVERAL MONTHS HERE AND
INSISTING ON THIS ISSUE. BUT
REPRESENTING. THE TOUCHY TRIBE
ALSO THE TO A RIVER TRIBE
INSTRUCTS APART THANK YOU THANK
YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE FRANK
MOLINA ON BEHALF OF THE SAN
MANUEL BAND OF MISSION INDIANS
IN THE SOUTH YOU KNOW SPANISH
COMMISSION IN SOME STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
NOT SEEN ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT. ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION. AND YOU MAY COME
TO THE TABLE AND WE'RE GONNA ASK
THE TWO WITNESSES TO MAKE ROOM
FOR THE WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. AND AGAIN TWO MINUTES EACH.
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY. SOME WITH
A TWO MINUTE STARTS WHEN YOU
BEGIN I PUSH THE BUTTON. THANK
YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. MY NAME IS RICHARD
FLYER I AM A JUDGE SUPERIOR
COURT TO THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
RETIRED- I AM ALSO A HASTINGS A
LOAN FROM A NINETEEN SEVENTY
ONE. I'M IN FAVOR OF RESTORATIVE
pPROVISIONS OF THIS BILL WILL
PROVIDE JUST. MENDOCINO COUNTY.
HOWEVER I AM AGAINST THE
RENAMING OF MY LAW SCHOOL. WHICH
IS PART OF THIS BILL. THIS PART
OF THE PROPOSED BILL IS ILL
ADVISED AND FAULTY. FIRST IT
WON'T RESTORE ANYTHING TO THE
NATIVE AMERICANS IN WILL
CERTAINLY ANTAGONIZE SOME OF THE
GRADUATES OF LAW SCHOOL. NEXT IS
ONLY BECAUSE JEALOUSY IN
BICKERING BETWEEN THE TRIBES THE
SCHOOL AND EVEN THE TWO HOUSES
OF YOUR LEGISLATURE. RIGHT NOW
THERE ARE TWO COMPETING BILLS
YOUR BILL AND THE BILL IN THE
SENATE ON THIS VERY RENAMING.
SOME OF THE TRIED MEMBERS
THEMSELVES ACCORDING TO- TO DEAN
FAGAN AT OUR LAST MEETING
THEMSELVES DO NOT EVEN WANT TO
RENAMING. THIRD THE RENAMING IS
BASED UPON FALSE FACTS AND
INFORMATION. CHIEF JUSTICE
HASTINGS WHO IS THE FIRST CHIEF
JUSTICE OF THE CALIFORNIA
SUPREME COURT DIDN'T KILL ANY
NATIVE AMERICANS ALL OF HIS
OPINIONS WRITTEN OPINIONS BY THE
SUPREME COURT AND OTHER ITEMS
THAT HE DID IS A ATTORNEY
GENERAL SO A DISCONCERTING NEED
A COUNTY WERE IN FAVOR OF NATIVE
AMERICAN RIGHTS. AND USING HIM
AS A NINETEENTH CENTURY
SCAPEGOAT WILL REDUCE THE
CREDIBILITY AND ACCEPTANCE OF
THIS BILL. LASTLY THIS RENAMING
PORTION OF THE BILL. IS ILLEGAL
AND WILL LEAD TO LITIGATION
WHICH WILL DELAY THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF RESTORATIVE
JUSTICE. FOR ALL THSE REASONS I
WOULD URGE YOU TO DELETE THE LAW
SCHOOL RENAMING PROVISION OF A
BILL. CERTAINLY OF ANY OF THE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE HAVE
QUESTIONS OF ME I'D BE GLAD TO
RESPOND TO THEIR THEIR
QUESTIONS. MUCH OF THE
INFORMATION I'VE GAINED IS BY
LOOKING AT THE ORIGINAL RECORDS
OF YOUR LEGISLATURE. AND EAT THE
STATEMENTS THAT WERE MADE UNDER
OATH BY PEOPLE INVOLVED IN IN
THESE MATTERS IT A PLATE OF
INVESTIGATION HEARD IN THE
NINETEENTH CENTURY. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR TIME THANK
YOU. NEXT WITH. YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN MY NAME IS CHRIS
WHITMAN I'M ALSO AN ALUM FROM
HASTINGS CLASSES IN SEVENTY
THREE- AND MY COMMENTS OF ALSO
REFER ONLY TO THE RENAMING OF
THE SCHOOL- SURRENDERS HASTINGS
DISNEY DID NOT AS CLAIMED IN THE
BILL. PROMOTE OR FINANCE NATIVE
AMERICAN HUNTING I. OR FUND
BOUNTIES RESULTING IN THE
MASSACRE OF HUNDREDS OF YUKI MEN
WOMEN AND CHILDREN NEITHER DID
pTHE SEIZURE OF LAND. NOR DOES HE
BEAR SIGNIFICANT RESPONSIBILITY
FOR IRREPARABLE HARM CAUSED TO
THE U. P. PEOPLE AND THE NATIVE
AMERICAN PEOPLE OF THE STATE.
HASTINGS DID NOT KILL OR
KNOWINGLY PARTICIPATE IN THE
KILLING OF OR WANTON VIOLENCE
AGAINST ANY NEED OF
CALIFORNIANS. HE ASKED THE
UNITED STATES MILITARY TO
RESPOND TO HIS AND OTHER
SETTLERS CONCERNS ABOUT ATTACKS
AND DAMAGE UPON PROPERTY.
INCLUDING HIS OWN BUT SUCH
ASSISTANCE WAS REFUSED. THEN
FOLLOWING THE PROCEDURE REQUIRED
BY STATE LAW AT THE TIME HE
STINKS PREPARE TO PETITION THE
GOVERNOR REQUESTING THAT A
MILITIA BE FORMED TO STOP THE
KILLING VIOLENCE AND PROPERTY
DESTRUCTION THAT HAD ERUPTED
BETWEEN NATIVE PEOPLE IN RECENT
SETTLERS. THE GOVERNOR INITIALLY
REFUSED BUT LATER EXCEEDED TO
THAT REQUEST HOWEVER THE LEADER
OF THE EAGLE RIVER RANGERS AS
THEY CAME TO CALL THEMSELVES DID
NOT FOLLOW THE GOVERNOR'S ORDERS
AND NATIVE PEOPLE WERE INDEED
WANTONLY KILLED IN. STINGS THAT.
ANY OF THE MALICIOUS ACTIVITIES.
AFTER THE UNITED STATES ONE
CALIFORNIA FROM MEXICO TITLE TO
THE LAND. IN THE ROUND VALLEY
WAS SEEDED BY THE UNITED STATES-
TO THE UNITED STATES BY TREATY.
IN EIGHTEEN FIFTY THREE CONGRESS
GAVE FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND ACRES
OF THAT LAND TO THE NEW STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WHICH IN EIGHTEEN
FIFTY EIGHT. IT'S PURCHASE FROM
WHICH HIS PURCHASE OF HUNDRED
ACRES IN THE EDEN VALLEY AT THAT
TIME A BIRD MEMBERS OF THE U. P.
TRIBE OCCUPIED SOME OF THAT
LAND. BUT HE STINKS TESTIFIED AT
THE LEGISLATIVE HERE. SIXTY THE
HE- HIS INTENTION TO MOVE THE U.
K. OFF HIS LAND. AT THE MARCH
SECOND ASSEMBLY SELECT NATIVE
AMERICAN AFFAIRS COMMITTEE
HEARING A LETTER FROM TO YOU THE
FAMILIES WAS RED. CITING THE
SPIRIT OF FORGIVENESS AND
REDEMPTION TRUTH AND HEALING AS
REASONS FOR REQUESTING THAT THE
COLLEGE'S NAME REMAIN AS IT IS
AND LIKE JUDGE FIRE I'M HAPPY TO
RESPOND TO ANY QUESTIONS THANK
YOU. ANY OTHER BUSINESSES IN THE
HEARING ROOM AND OPPOSITION LIKE
TO COME TO THE MICROPHONE I GIVE
YOUR NAME- AND YOUR POSITION ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
C. NINE WILL GO NOT TO THE
TWEENER POSITION AND AGAIN TO
MATCH. THANK YOU CHAIR MEDINA
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE- MY
NAME IS DAVID FAGAN ON THE
CHANCELLOR AND DEAN AT UC
HASTINGS LAW AND SAM. I WANT TO.
THANK IN PERSON TO TRUST YOU
COULD COMMITTEE MEMBER MONA ON
DHICIN AND ESPECIALLY IN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER JAMES RAMOS FOR
THEIR EFFORTS AND WORKING WITH
THE COLLEGE. TO CRAFT WORDS IN
THAT WOULD PROVIDE A BLUEPRINT
FOR THE SCHOOL AND THE TRIBES
AROUND THAT WAY TO WORK TOGETHER
IN MUTUALLY BENEFICIAL WHERE
IT'S- OUR- GOALS ARE TO.
CONCRETE TO RESTORE GOSSIP AND
TO REMOVE NAME HASTY. IT IS PART
OF A LONG. PROCESS THIS PROCESS
OF RESTORATIVE JUSTICE AMONG OUR
COMMUNITIES BEGAN IN TWENTY
SEVENTEEN WHEN I FIRST LEARNED
OF THE HISTORY OF FOUNDERS
ACTIONS IN AROUND BROWN ABOUT
RESULT IN THE DEATH HUNDREDS OF
YOUR DOUBLE MEMBERS. YOU
APPOINTED CAN. HIS BIGGEST
COMMITTEE WHICH EXAMINED THE
TRUE STRIDES HE I. GETTING FIT
IS. EACH OUT FIVE BROWN. AND.
RESTORATIVE F. IT- ABERRATION
WITH LEADERS THIS WORK TO THE
BILL AUSTIN FRENCH BETWEEN
COMMUNITY IS A NUMBER OF
INITIATIVES WERE STARTED OVER
THE LAST FOUR YEARS YOU COULD
HAVE A MULTIPLE CONSULTATION
BETWEEN COLLEGE OFFICER AND
LEADERS THE STAFF HAVE AN
INDIGENOUS LAWCENTER AT THE
SCHOOL SAYS STOP HIGH VISIBLE
SPACE IN THE LOBBY THIS MAN
ADMINISTRATION BUILDING FOR A
COMMEMORATION OF THE PEOPLE. AND
THE CORONATION STREET PER FILE
SAID NONPROFIT LEGAL SERVICES IN
TRIBAL COURTS TO WORK ON
INDIGENOUS IT IS EASY BUT SOME
IN THIS STORE CONTACT FOR THIS
WORK. IF IN NINETEEN THIRTY SIX
IN THE US CONTINUATION OF THE
EFFORTS OF THE COLLEGE IN ROUND
VALLEY TRIBES START MORE THAN
FOUR YEARS AGO WE SUPPORT HAVING
THOSE EFFORTS CONTINUE TO GROW
ORGANIC. CALIFORNIA I JUST. AIMS
FOUND A- I FURTHER WERE CAN BE.
NUMBER RAMOS HAS SAID HOWEVER WE
ARE ONLY ABOUT 80% IN AGREEMENT
WITH THE LANGUAGE NOW IN THE
BILL. AND THE 20% REMAINING NOT
INSUBSTANTIAL OUR SCHOOL IN THE
BROAD BASED COMMUNITY ENTRUSTED
SERVERS AND REPRESENTS HAVE
CONCERNS REGARDING SOME OF THE
LANGUAGE NOW IN THE MEASURE BUT
WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
ALL PART TO REFINE THAT LAW PAGE
THERE OR WE ARE. WHAT WE'VE MUCH
THE PROCESS THAT HAS BEEN
UNDERTAKEN WHICH HELP YOU GET
YOUR THE THAT IS NOW AN- IS
COMMITTED. TO WORK APPROVED ALL
CORPORATE INPUT FROM ALL
STAKEHOLDERS INTERESTED PARTIES
WE EXPECT THAT THE FINAL BILL
REMOVE THE NAME HASTINGS FROM
THE LAW SCHOOL. SEVERAL POINT
THE RESTORED OF JOB
OPPORTUNITIES THAT ARE
APPROPRIATE FOR A LAW SCHOOL TO
UNDERTAKE THAT. IN YOUR POSITION
HERE IN THE HEARING ROOM. C.
NONE QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
THE COMMITTEE. QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE. IT
WOULD WOULD YOU PLEASE OF HI
IT'S DAVID FAGAN ON THE
CHANCELLOR AND DEAN AT UC
HASTINGS LAW IN SAN FRANCISCO.
THANK YOU. ALL YEAH YEAH. I
UNDERSTAND WHY YOU'RE HERE ARE
THESE OTHER GENTLEMEN HERE.
THEIR THEIR THEIR BUSINESSES IN
OPPOSITION MISTER MOVIE AND YOUR
AND HE'S A TWEENER GOT IT OKAY
AND HOW DID WE IDENTIFY THE
OPPOSITION. ON I THINK THEY JUST
CAME FOR HE SPEAKS FOR EVER
PEOPLE I JUST GOT UP THERE OKAY
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU. OKAY I
COMMENTS MORE THAN ANYTHING ELSE
IN IN THE FIRST IN THE FIRST
BILL IDENTIFIED MYSELF AS A
HISTORY- CALIFORNIA HISTORY I
TAUGHT AT UC RIVERSIDE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE. WHAT CALIFORNIA HISTORY
BUT I TAUGHT U. S. HISTORY I WAS
JUST ONE SEMESTER BUT I TAUGHT
US HISTORY FOR MANY MANY YEARS
AT THE HIGH SCHOOL LEVEL. I WAS
TO MY MASTERS IN HISTORY AT UC
RIVERSIDE WAS ACTUALLY A PHD
STUDENT IN HISTORY AT UC
RIVERSIDE. BUT UNLIKE MY GOOD
FRIEND- BILL MEDINA I NEVER
FINISHED I CAME HERE INSTEAD.
BUT ALL MY WORK AS A TEACHER.
AND AS A STUDENT OF HISTORY. US
HISTORY LITTLE BIT CALIFORNIA
HISTORY. I REMEMBER READING
ABOUT THE GOLD RUSH AND READING
ABOUT THE GOLD RUSH AND THE
STRIFE DURING THE GOLD RUSH DAYS
I IMAGINE RIGHT HERE IN THIS THE
CALIFORNIA RELEASED. AND I DO
REMEMBER THAT. BUT THE EVENTS
THAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT HERE IN
THIS BILL WITH HASTINGS I NEVER
SAW NEVER READ NEVER REALLY
HEARD ABOUT IT UNTIL THIS BILL
CAME UP AND AS I GOT READY FOR
THE HEARING YOU KNOW I ENDED
THERE'S A NEW YOUR IN STORE A
DAY. NOVEMBER FOR TWENTY ONE
THIS AND HE STRUGGLED. KIND OF
SIMILAR EXPERIENCE AS MY OWN.
WHERE HE WENT TO HIS DAUGHTERS-
ELEMENTARY TEXTBOOKS YOU KNOW
DID NOT READ ANYTHING ABOUT THIS
EITHER. IN A DAUGHTER TEXTBOOKS
. BUT HE DOUBTS MUCH DEEPER THAN
I DID AND IN HIS ARTICLE HE
DESCRIBES THE INVOLVEMENT OF
HASTINGS. AND I COULD JUST READ
HERE. JUST A PART OF THE STATE
SPONSORED KILLINGS CARRIED OUT
ACROSS THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
AND HE IS WRITING IN THE NEW
YORK TIMES I BELIEVE THERE WAS
A- MORE RECENT ARTICLE BEFORE
THAT IN- ONE OF THE LOCAL
NEWSPAPERS INCLUDING MAYBE THE
SAN FRANCISCO CHRONICLE. WELL I
. MEMBERS THE MODEL OF THE NEW
YORK TIMES ALL THE NEWS THAT'S
FIT TO PRINT. I BELIEVE THAT
PRETTY STANDARD HIGH STANDARD ON
. ON OF RESEARCHING THEIR FAX.
SO I DO NOT DOUBT THE FACTS THAT
ARE IN THIS ARTICLE NOR THE
FACTS THAT ARE BROUGHT OUT BY-
IT AND I I'M SORRY I CAN'T
REMEMBER HIS NAME IN THE BOOK-
CALIFORNIA GENOCIDE- RIGHT SO I
DO NOT DOUBT THAT SCHOLARSHIP
THAT RESEARCH IN BOTH THE
ARTICLE AND THE BOOK. OUR
BROTHER IS A GRADUATE OF THE
FORMER BALL TALK. NOW KNOWN AS
BERKELEY LAW. HIS DEGREE. FROM
NOW BERKELEY LAW IS NO LESS
VALUABLE BECAUSE OF THE NAME
CHANGE IT IS STILL A PREMIER-
LAW SCHOOL IN THE UNITED STATES
I'M NOT SURE THE RANKING BUT IT
IS AND IT WAS NOT DIMINISHED BY
THE CHANGING OF THE NAME. IN MY
TEN YEARS NOW HERE IN THE
CALIFORNIA STATE LEGISLATURE-
I'M GRATEFUL TO MY COLLEAGUES-
MISTER RAMOS. FOR HIS WORK IN
EDUCATING ALL OF US. I AM
GRATEFUL TO THE GOVERNOR OF THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA WHO A YEAR
TWO YEARS AGO. IN ANOTHER PAPA
G. TO THE NATIVE AMERICANS FOR
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA- SO THIS
BILL. IS A IN MY OPINION A MOVE
IN THAT SAME DIRECTION. I
SUPPORT IT. I SUPPORT- AS I DID
WHEN WE WERE- DEBATING AND
TALKING ABOUT THE TEACHING OF
HISTORY IN THIS COUNTRY IN THE
STATE I HAVEN'T FULLY SUPPORT OF
FULLER TEACHING A MORE ACCURATE
TEACHING OF WHAT HAS HAPPENED IN
THIS COUNTRY IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND THE NATIVE
AMERICAN EXPERIENCE. PLAYS A
LARGE ROLE IN THAT THIS BILL IS
A MOVE IN THAT DIRECTION I
STRONGLY SUPPORT THE BILL AND
WOULD ASK TO BE A CO AUTHOR AND
WITH THAT I WILL LET TO ROPS
CLOSED. THANK THANK YOU- THE
CHAIRMAN DENIED THANK YOU FOR
YOUR WILLINGNESS TO BE A CO
AUTHOR. ON THIS BILL AS WE
CONTINUE TO MOVE FORWARD IN A
AND- IN THE SPIRIT OF- ENSURING
THAT A VOICE THAT HAS BEEN LEFT
OUT LEFT OUT OF DOCUMENTS AS
SOME MIGHT BE. LEFT OUT NONE THE
LESS OF THE HISTORY AND THE
COMPONENT OF HOW IT TRULY
IMPACTS CALIFORNIA PEOPLE. THE
VOICE THE VOICE THAT MANY- AB.
TEACH JOHN OR EVEN WITHIN THE
SCHOLARLY PROFESSION WHAT THE
RESEARCH DOES NOT HAVE THE BOYS
OF CALIFORNIA PEOPLE. ENGINE
MALLEY WROTE A BOOK ON THE
GENOCIDE AMERICAN GENOCIDE
FOCUSED ON. THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND WE KNOW THE
HISTORY AS INDIAN PEOPLE WE'VE
KNOWN THE HISTORY OF THIS
INDIVIDUAL FROM THE LAW SCHOOL.
NOW IS THE TIME FOR THE VOICES
OF CALIFORNIA PEOPLE TO BE HEARD
NOT ONLY THE PRESENT VOICES
BEING HEARD IN THIS ROOM TODAY.
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. VOICE STILL REMAIN
BURIED IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THAT ARE. M. WHO.
TELL THEM THAT ABOUT WHAT
HAPPENED TO OUR PEOPLE HERE IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
CALIFORNIA'S FIRST PEOPLE I
THANK YOU I THANK YOU CHAIRMAN
FOR COMING ON AS CO AUTHORS AND
WE WOULD BE OPEN TO ANY OTHER CO
AUTHORS AT THIS TIME TO COME
FORWARD FROM THIS COMMITTEE NOW
IS THE TIME TO LET THAT VOICE BE
HEARD OF CALIFORNIA'S FIRST
PEOPLE AND I URGE AN AYE VOTE.
GOOD YEAH. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN I THINK MR ROBERSON AND
I'D- I WAS YESTERDAY I
COMMITTED- WHEN YOU ASK ME ON
THE FLOOR IF I WAS GONNA BE
VOTING FOR YOUR BILL AND I WAS
GLAD TO DO IT AND- VOTED FOR
YOUR BILL THIS MORNING- IN IN
ANOTHER COMMITTEE A DIFFERENT
BILL- WHERE. EIGHTY WHEN I WHEN
I TALK TO FOURTH GRADE. THE
CAPITAL OR OR WHETHER I'M
TALKING TO- ANY CONSTITUENT WHO
ASKED ME ABOUT THE FAVORITE PART
OF MY JOB. I USUALLY SAY YOU
KNOW WE'LL TELL THEM IT THESE
ARE ALL TRUE ANSWERS ONE AS I
LIKE TO HELP PEOPLE. BUT THE
OTHER THING ABOUT MY JOB THAT I
REALLY LOVE IS I CAN LEARN
SOMETHING NEW EVERY DAY. EVERY
DAY- SO YOUR BILL EARLIER AND
WATER PARKS AND WILDLIFE I LEARN
SOMETHING NEW SOMETHING THAT WE
I TOOK FOR GRANTED WAS OBLIVIOUS
ABOUT. THAN I COULD I LEARNED
SOMETHING ABOUT IN REAL
RECOGNIZE THAT THERE IS AN
IMPORTANT CHANGE THAT CAN BE
ABSOLUTELY TRUE HERE BUT- YOU
KNOW WHAT I WAS ASKING ACTUALLY
WHO THESE WITNESSES WERE I WAS
JUST VERY CONCERNED I MEAN IT.
POPPING A POPE THEIR OR SUPPORT
A BILL THERE'S NO ONE ELSE
THERE. ANY YAHOO CAN JUST STEP
UP AND SAY. I OPPOSE THIS BILL
AND- PROVIDE TESTIMONY OR-
ALTERNATIVE FACTS WHICH WE'VE
HEARD A LOT ABOUT I THINK THE
CHAIR MADE A REALLY GOOD CASE
FOR. YOU KNOW WHAT WE HAVE
LEARNED HOW THERE'S SO MUCH
HISTORY THAT DOCUMENTS WHAT
HASTINGS INVOLVEMENT WAS- IN
CHARGE REALLY OFFENDED TO HEAR.
AN ALTERNATE VERSION OF HISTORY
THAT IS OPPOSED TO WHAT IS
DOCUMENTED- AND I WANTED TO MAKE
SURE THAT I'VE WASTE. HOW
OFFENDED I WAS BY THAT. YOU CAN
LOVE THE NAME HASTINGS ALL YOU
WANT BUT DON'T COME HERE AND TRY
TO TELL US THE HISTORY IS
DIFFERENT FROM WHAT IS
DOCUMENTED- WHAT I THINK IS
REALLY IMPORTANT AND I THINK
THIS WEEK IS JUST LIKE SUCH A
GREAT WEEK FOR US TO. BE DEALING
WITH THESE ISSUES. IS THOUGH NOT
HOWEVER. SOMEONE WAS ABLE TO GET
AWAY WITH EVIL. NO MATTER HOW
LONG AGO IT WAS NO MATTER HOW
MUCH MONEY THEY MADE OR GAVE. TO
MAKE THEMSELVES LOOK BIG. WE CAN
CATCH UP TO THAT AND WE CAN HOLD
THEM ACCOUNTABLE IN SOME WAY AND
I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR NOT WITH
THIS BILL AND I AND I'D BE
GRATEFUL VEHICLE AUTHOR THANK
YOU SO MUCH- ANYTHING ELSE IN
CLOSING MR OF. THANK YOU THANK
YOU FOR THE CONVERSATION AND
THANK YOU FOR THE TESTIMONY OF
ARAMBULA INDIAN TRIBE. JIM ROSS
AND UKEE VICE CHAIR OF THE
COMMITTEE MONA- THAT'S AN END TO
THE CHANCELLOR AND DEAN WHO
CONTINUES TO MEET WITH US WITH
OVER. TEN SOME ALREADY- FOR THE
COMING WEEKS TO CONTINUE THE
DIALOGUE AND I WOULD JUST WANNA
LEAVE YOU WITH THIS WITH THE
COMMITTEE. THERE IS A LOT OF
DISCUSSION IN THOSE JEANS THAT
ARE ON BUT THE THING THAT EVERY
A- IS THAT HEY. THE ROOM. ASK
FOR YOUR VOTE THANK YOU SENATE
THE PROGRAM TIME WE WILL BRING
IT UP THANK YOU SO READING. WE
WILL NOW GO TO. FILE ITEM. EIGHT
MISCARRY. JAMES. JUMPING ALL
OVER THE PLACE. I'M JUMPING ALL
OVER THE PLACE- MISTER LIVING
HEARD THAT HE WAS A JUDGE. ON
OKAY. WITH YOUR BIRTHDAY. TODAY. OKAY YOU KNOW WHAT. IT I WAS
GOING TO CALL THE MEMBERS. I
MISS CATT EAGLES FILE ITEM EIGHT
AB TWENTY FOUR THIRTEEN YOU MAY
BEGIN WHEN YOU'RE READY. THANK
YOU- AND MEMBERS I AM PROUD 2%
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY FOUR
THIRTEEN WHICH WOULD ALLOW
CERTAIN CLASSIFIED SCHOOL OR
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT
EMPLOYEES TO REMAIN UNPAID
STATUS WHILE ON A- PERSON NOT TO
GET IN THE BILL IT GOING TO.
CLEAR AND CON WITH AN DISTINCT
BUT DAVE COLLECTIVE BARGAINING
AGREEMENTS CLASSIFIED SCHOOL
EMPLOYEES ARE BUS DRIVERS
CUSTODIANS CLERICAL WORKERS AND
MAINTENANCE STAFF THAT WORK FOR
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL DISTRICT AND
COMMUNITY IT JUST. OKAY M.
THIRTY FIFTH. PAID STATUS WHILE
APPEALING AN INVESTIGATION AND
THIS ALLOWS THEM TO FULLY
EXERCISE THEIR DUE PROCESS
RIGHTS HOWEVER CLASSIFIED STAFF
GENERALLY HAVE THEIR CASES
SUSPENDED AND THIS MAKES IT MORE
DIFFICULT FOR THEM TO PRESENT
THE FACTS AND THEIR CAN. IT'S
MOST MINIMUM WAGE CANNOT DEFEND
THEMSELVES WHILE THE BILL'S
PILOT. MANY CLASSIFIED EMPLOYEES
HAVE THE ARBITRATION PROCESS AND
THEIR CBA AND OUR INTENT IS TO
RESPECT THAT PROCESS. RATHER IT
WILL GOVERN CASES WHERE THE- TO
THE GIRL BOARD AND PEELS THE
COLLAPSE A FEW WEEKS AT MOST
HERE TO TESTIFY AND ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS OF THE COMMITTEE MAY
HAPPENS MICHAEL YOUNG. AND IF IT
OF. MISTER CHAIRMAN BIRDS
MICHAEL YOUNG WITH THE
CALIFORNIA FEDERATION OF
TEACHERS I THINK ASSEMBLY WOMAN
CARILLO FOR BRING IN THE BILL
CFC IS SPONSORING A BILL TO
PROVIDE. THE WASTE PILE JIM WHEN
ACCESS TO THEIR DUE PROCESS
RIGHTS UNDER THE CURRENT VERSION
OF CODE AS WITH PIECES IT WOULD
CLASSIFY PUBLIC IS INITIALLY
DISCIPLINED TO TERMINATE OR- OR
OR- PAY EVERY. GARBAGE WE'RE-
THE WORD LAW DOESN'T ALLOW THEM
TO STAY IN PEACE STATUS
THROUGHOUT THE COMPLETION OF
THOSE DEPRIVE HEARINGS. THIS
BILL TO ALLOW WORKERS ACCESS
SAID THEIR ENTIRE DUE PROCESS
PROCEDURES UNDER THE ECHO AND
HAVE A TRULY JUST SYSTEM. WITH
WITH THAT WE RESPECT THE
ASTRONAUT THANK YOU. ARE THERE
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
MAY HAVE TWO MINUTES. OKAY.
DAVID HAWKINS CALIFORNIA COLLEGE
INDEPENDENCE IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. FEDERAL ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL EMPLOYEES
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION IN THE HEARING ROOM.
C. NINE ANY TWEETERS ON AB
TWENTY FOUR THIRTEEN. IN THE
HEARING ROOM. C. NONE QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
SEE ANY ALL RIGHT- I JUST
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT. AS A LONGTIME
TEACHER I KNOW WHO THE BACKBONE
OF- SCHOOLS ARE AND THEY ARE
CLASSIFIED EMPLOYEES SO MAKING
SURE THE CLASSIFIED STAFF AND
ACADEMIC STAFF ARE NEEDED IT
BLEY AND FAIRLY AS ALWAYS BEEN
IMPORTANT TO ME. YOU VERY MUCH
BRING IN THE.
THIS BILL WILL CREATE PARITY
BETWEEN THE PRACTICES THE
PERSONNEL INVOCATION FOR
CERTIFIED AND CLASSIFIED SCHOOL
EMPLOYEES WHILE PROTECTING
EXISTING AGREED WITH APPROPRIATE
EXCEPTIONS FOR IN. THERE IS
CLEAR EVIDENCE WRONG AS YOU
STATED THAT ONE KNOWS WHO KEEPS
OUR SCHOOLS AND COMMUNITY
COLLEGES SAY BEAUTIFUL SPECIALLY
FOR AND THEY ARE THIS TO BE TRUE
FAIRLY ON THE JOB. AT THE BILL
MISSION. YOU BYE BYE. THE VOTE
MADE A MOMENT ARSENAL PRIVILEGE
TO JUST SAY THANK YOU TO YOU
MISTER CHAIR FOR ALL OF YOUR
YEARS IN THE LEGISLATURE IN THE
ASSEMBLY THIS. TO YOU IRED
COMMITTEE AND I'M JUST. THE WORK
THAT YOU'VE DONE ON BEHALF OF
WORKERS AND ESPECIALLY FOR
STUDENTS THANK YOU THANK YOU
MISS GOODY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND AT THE APPROPRIATE BRING
FORTH THANK. AND NOW- JUST
MISTER GIBSON SOLD MISTER GIBSON
YOU MAY COME FORWARD. AND WE
WILL BE ON FILE ITEM. THIRTEEN
A. B. NINETEEN NINETY SEVEN.
BEGIN WHEN YOU'RE READY. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MR CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS MY WITNESS IS IN ROUTES
HERE TO SIT NEXT TO ME TO
PROVIDE- TESTIMONY- AT THE
PROPIONIC RIVE SO WITH THAT
BEING SAID THANK YOU. PRESENT
THE BILL NINETEEN SEVENTY. WHICH
SEEKS TO CREATE A DIVERSE
STAKEHOLDERS AND I WANT TO
UNDERSCORE STAKEHOLDERS
WORKGROUP WITHIN A CALIFORNIA
STATE UNIVERSITIES ACROSS THE
STATE TO EXPLORE. TRANSPARENT
CURRENT EMERGENCY RESPONSE
PROGRAMS THIS WORKGROUP AGAIN
WORKGROUP WILL INCLUDE FACULTY
STAFF STUDENTS AND CAMPUS HEALTH
AND SAFETY PERSONNEL WHICH ALSO
INCLUDES CAMPUS POLICE. WE WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT EVERYONE IS
INVITED EVERYONE IS AT THE TABLE
FOR THIS WORK GROUP ONE OF THE
FOUNDATIONS OF ENSURING OUR
STUDENTS RECEIVE A QUALITY
EDUCATION IS PROVIDING A STE C.
K. AND BOB ARE STILL. WHO ARE
NOT ONLY WHO STUDY BUT IN MANY
CASES ALSO LIVE ON CAMPUS AS IF
A SAFE SECURE- A CAMPUS
ENVIRONMENT IS ALSO A NECESSARY
FOR OUR FACULTY AND STAFF WHO
SPENDS LONG DAYS AND OFTEN LONG
NIGHTS ON CAMPUS TEACHING
PREPARING FOR THEIR NEXT CLASS
OR SUPPORTING STUDENTS IN OTHER
WAYS- STARTING WITH THE
WORKGROUP WILL. ALL STAKE-
CAMPUS POLICE TO FIND THE BEST
APPROACH TO ADDRESS AND REDUCE
CONCERNS REGARDING CURRENT IN
CINCY SPOTS BRAM AT S. CAMPUSES. CURRENTLY THERE TWENTY THREE A
CS USE CAP OF CAL. ONE OF WHICH
CAL STATE UNIVERSITY DOMINGUEZ
HILLS THAT I PROBABLY REPRESENT
IN MY DISTRICT IN CARSON. IN
CALIFORNIA MORE OFTEN THAN NOT
IF A STUDENT IS DEALING WITH A
SEVERE MENTAL HEALTH ISSUE
CAMPUS POLICE ARE CALLED ON TO
RESPOND TO THAT PARTICULAR
CRISIS ALTHOUGH LAW ENFORCEMENT
SERVES AN IMPORTANT ROLE AND I
WANT TO UNDERSCORE A IMPORTANT
AND VITAL ROLE. BEING OUR
SCHOOLS AND STUDENTS SAFE AND
SECURE IT IS IMPORTANT TO HAVE
TRAINED SPECIALISTS THAT FOCUS
ON. LUCIEN AND- FORMATIVE
JUSTICE TO BEST RESPOND TO NON
VIOLENT AND NON CRIMINAL
SITUATIONS ON CAMPUS THE WORK
GROUP WOULD ALSO BE REQUIRED TO
REPORT BACK TO THE LEGISLATURE
ON THEIR FINDINGS- JOINING ME TO
PROVIDE SUPPORTING TESTIMONY IS-
RUN A REP. JUST GOT A NOTE HE'S
COMING HE'S IN ROUTE OKAY- FROM
THE CALIFORNIA FACULTY
ASSOCIATION TO ANSWER TO DRESS
ANY QUESTIONS AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME. SEE HERE. YOU KNOW THE
VERSION PLEASE. THE OPPOSITION
AND WE HAVE NO OPPOSITION OR OF
RECORD. WIENER AND WHEN YOU'RE
WANTING TO SPEAK IN FAVOR OF THE
- CAN I FIND ONE PERSON I'M
SCARED. YES THEY ARE I'M SICK
I'M SORRY SIR. NO OPPOSITION SIR
NONE OF RECORD. MAYES SURE. WHAT
HAPPENS COMMENTS- UNDERSCORED
ELEMENT I AM PROUD. THANK YOU
FOR CONVENING THE STAKEHOLDER
WORKGROUP AND I DO THINK
DISCUSSION IS NECESSARY AND
IMPORTANT- BUT IN THE ABSENCE OF
YOUR WITNESS WHY DON'T YOU JUST
GO AHEAD AND CLOSE AND- THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. YES THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MR CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS THANK YOU FALL AGAIN
ALLOW ME TO PRESENT THIS BILL
FOR OUR YOUTH- TO REACHING THEIR
FULLEST POTENTIAL IT IS
ABSOLUTELY IMPORTANT THAT HE
HELPED. A SAFE. HEALTHY
ENVIRONMENTS OF FOR THOSE
STUDENTS. AB NINETEEN NINETY
SEVEN WILL PROVIDE OUR CSU
CAMPUSES FOR. BERNIE TO KERN. IN
PLACE IT ALL BRING STAKEHOLDERS
TO THE TABLE TO ADDRESS- THE
SAFETY ISSUES WITH STAKEHOLDERS
BEING AS I DESCRIBE INCLUDING-
LAW ENFORCEMENT IS A VERY
CENTRAL PART OF THE CONVERSATION
FORCED TO BE OF THAT CAR THEY
SHOULD AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
WHEN I VOTE WITH APPOINT A
SPECIAL PRIVILEGE THIS WILL BE
BY LAW. IS THAT MISS WILL BILL
INDICATED BEFORE YOU I PRIEST
SERVICE- I HAD A GREAT SENSE FOR
YOU AND THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
THE PEOPLE STATE OF. THANK IT IS
NOT YOUR. THE PLEASURE. THANK
YOU MISTER GIPSON. AND WE WILL
BRING IT UP WHEN WE THE CORE
THANK YOU AND- SEEING JUST ONE
OTHER ARE HERE. WILL GO WOULD
WITH THAT THE BILL AND THAT IS.
FILE I. TWENTY ONE MISTER. FILE
ITEM TWENTY ONE EIGHTEEN OH ONE
AND THEN WE'LL GO TO FILE ITEMS
TWENTY TWO. BEGIN WHEN YOU'RE
READY. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS- FIRST FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT THE
BILL AND ALSO FOR THE SUPPORT
YOUR COMMITTEE STAFF HAS GIVEN
ME AND WORKED WITH ME- AB
EIGHTEEN OH ONE ESTABLISHES
GENOCIDE AWARENESS DAY AS A
HOLIDAY WHICH WOULD BE OBSERVED
ANNUALLY ON APRIL TWENTY FOURTH
AS A HOLIDAY ALL PUBLIC SCHOOLS
CSU'S MANY COLLEGE WOULD BE
REQUIRED WELL UC'S WOULD BE
REQUESTED TO CLOSE DOWN. AND TO
BEGIN OFF. CAN ASIDE HAS BEEN AN
UNFORTUNATE REALITY SINCE THE
DAWN OF HUMANITY THAT HAS
IMPACTED MANY COMMUNITIES WHICH
HAVE FOUND REFUGE IN CALIFORNIA
WHETHER IT BE. ARMENIAN THE
SYRIAN JEWISH CAMBODIAN AS AND
AS WE'RE SEEING RIGHT NOW EVEN
UKRAINIAN. THE ACTIVE
SYSTEMICALLY RACING ANOTHER%
GROUP IS BORN OUT OF HATE
PREJUDICE AND A LACK OF EMPATHY
WE CAN ONLY RESOLVE THESE
FUNDAMENTAL HUMAN FLAWS THROUGH
CONTINUED RECOGNITION CONTINUED
AWARENESS AND CONTINUED
UNDERSTANDING. THIS BILL
REQUIRES THAT WE TAKE A DAY AS A
STATE TO REFLECT ON PREVIOUS AND
CURRENT ACTS OF GENOCIDE AND TO
RAISE AWARENESS TO. TRUMP IS I
WAS MANY INDIVIDUALS WITH
GENERATIONAL TRAUMA RECOGNITION
OF THAT TRAUMA AND AN
OPPORTUNITY TO HEAL THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME AND CONSIDERATION
WITH ME IS ME RUN TO MY CHIN
WITH THE ARMENIAN ASSEMBLY OF
AMERICA. THANK YOU. AT. TWO
MINUTES BEGIN WHEN YOU'RE READY
. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN- ON
BEHALF OF THE ARMENIAN ASSEMBLY
OF AMERICA- I THINK YOU AND
FELLOW MEMBERS- FOR HOLDING
TODAY'S HEARING ON ASSEMBLY BILL
EIGHTEEN OH ONE IF ADOPTED SB
EIGHTEEN OH ONE WITH. OR TO BE
ABLE TO LIST OF.HOLIDAYS THE
GENOCIDE WEDNESDAY THE ARMENIAN
SOME AMERICA SUPPORTS THE
ADOPTION OF EIGHTY AB EIGHTEEN
OH ONE AS IT ALIGNS WITH OUR
CORE VALUES AND PRINCIPLES
INCLUDING WITH THE IMPORTANCE
THAT WE ATTACH TOWARDS HUMAN
RIGHTS AND GENOCIDE EDUCATION.
WE CAN ONLY RESOLVE WHOLESALE
VIOLATIONS OF FUNDAMENTAL HUMAN
RIGHTS BY RECOGNIZING THEM AND
RAISING AWARENESS REFLECTING ON
BASIC HUMAN RIGHTS IS THE AIM OF
AB EIGHTEEN OH ONE. D. ONE DAY
IN OUR CALENDAR YEAR TO REFLECT
ON PREVIOUS AND CURRENT SADLY
CURRENT ACTS OF GENOCIDE AND
THROUGH SUCH ACTIONS HELP
PREVENT THE REALIZATION THE
FUTURE MASS ATROCITIES. TWO DAYS
AGO ON APRIL TWENTY FOUR
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
CALIFORNIANS EXTENDED FROM SAN
FRANCISCO TO LOS ANGELES AND
ORANGE COUNTY. AND FROM SAN%
DIEGO CON. ONE FRESNO COUNTY I'M
RATED A HUNDRED SEVENTH
ANNIVERSARY OF THE ARMENIAN
GENOCIDE PREMEDITATED AND
PERPETRATED BY THE OTTOMAN
TURKISH GOVERNMENT THE GENOCIDE
TOOK THE LIVES OF ONE POINT
MILLION ARMENIAN INCLUDING
MEMBERS OF MY FAMILY THE TOO MY
JOHNSTON A HOBBIT YEAH.
TWO MILLENNIA OLD HIRTH IN
SERVICE IN ARMENIA LOCATED IN
THE NORTHEASTERN REGION OF THE
MEDITERRANEAN SEA. DESPITE IN
RECOGNIZING THE ARMENIAN
GENOCIDE ITS STATE SPONSORED
DENIAL BY SUCCESSORS OF THE
OTTOMAN TURKISH EMPIRE INCLUDING
BY THE PRESENT DAY ADULT ON
ROUGE IN J. RACIAL PROBLEM GEN
WE'LL TRY THAT MANY EUROPEANS
CAN. THE AND BECAUSE OF JOHN
WHICH IS IN WITH ERTEGUN
MILITARILY AND GEOPOLITICALLY
ALSO VICIOUSLY DENIES THE
VERACITY OF THE ARMENIAN
GENOCIDE ESTABLISHMENT OF
GENOCIDE AWARENESS DAY ON APRIL
TWENTY FOURTH AS A CALIFORNIA
STATE HOLIDAY WOULD SERVE AS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO HEAL FOR MANY
PEOPLE SUFFERING FROM TRUMP
PROVISIONAL TRAUMA. MISSION OF
ALL THE SITES AND ALLOW
CALIFORNIANS TO CONTEMPLATE
ABOUT PAST AND PRESENT MASS
ATROCITIES WHILE MEMORIALIZING
ALL WHO HAVE SUFFERED. THANK Q.
ARE THERE ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT. ANYONE WANTS TO COME TO
THE MICROPHONE OF THEIR NAME.
SUPPORT OKAY ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION TO WANT TO GO TO THE
MICROPHONE ANY TWEETERS. SHINO
TWEETERS ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE. MR
LEVINE YEAH HELLO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR THE BILL THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TESTIMONY I WAS REALLY
CHANNELING INTO ENTER- THE
CEREMONY THAT WE HAD ON MONDAY
TO RECOGNIZE THE ARMENIAN
GENOCIDE IN THE PRIOR BILL WAS
TALKING ABOUT REMOVING THE NAME
OF SOMEONE WHO COMMITTED
GENOCIDE OR AND ATROCITIES
AGAINST. NATIVE AMERICANS
INDIGENOUS PEOPLE HERE IN
CALIFORNIA REMOVING THAT NAME
FROM- AND IN THE COMMENTS I HAD
ON THAT BILL THAT WAS ABOUT-
FINING ACCOUNTABILITY. AND I
THINK THAT WHEN WE REMEMBER
GENOCIDE WE SEARCH FOR THAT
ACCOUNTABILITY- EVEN IF WE
HAVEN'T HAD IT IN EXPERIENCED IT
YET- AND SO I I'M GOING TO
SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY THAT. I
ALSO WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR
FOR BRINGING THE BILL FORWARD-
ALSO TO ENCOURAGE HIM TO.
ADDRESS THE CONCERNS ON PAGE
FOUR OF THE ANALYSIS AND WORK
WITH THE DIFFERENT SEGMENTS TO
ENSURE THAT THEY ARE FULLY ABLE
TO IMPLEMENT- IN A TIMELY
MANNER. TO CONTINUE. TO DISCUSS
WITH THEM AND WITH THAT IF YOU'D
LIKE TO CLOSE. I APPRECIATE THE
CHAIR SUPPORT AND COMMENTS THANK
YOU FOR THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS
ALSO COMMENTS- I WANTED TO POINT
OUT THAT THERE WAS ALSO ANOTHER
SPEAKER WHO INTENDED TO SPEAK.
UP SERENO PRISTINE EXECUTIVE OF
THE JEWISH WORLD WATCH WHO HAD
PROVIDED TESTIMONY- LAST WEEK
WHEN THIS BILL WAS GOING THROUGH
GEO- I ALSO WANTED SAY- OF THE-
THANK YOU FOR THE COMMENTS IT.
YOU HAD A LOT OF THINGS I DON'T
WANNA ELONGATED FURTHER BUT- IT
IS IMPORTANT FOR US TO REMEMBER
AND TO SOMETIMES VOICE OUT. OF
THE- CHOOSE IN A PRAGMATIC SO
THAT WE MAKE SURE THAT THE SAME
EVENTS DON'T OCCUR AGAIN
UNFORTUNATELY SOMETIMES IT SEEMS
LIKE WHEN WE'RE NOT ADDRESSING
ISSUES APPROPRIATELY AND HOLDING
TO BETTER ACCOUNT THE
PERPETRATORS- HISTORY REPEATS
ITSELF SO WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL THANK
YOU. WILL BRING IT UP- WHEN ONCE
WE HAVE A CORE SO WITH THAT
WE'LL GO TO FILE ITEM TWENTY TWO
A. B. EIGHTEEN FIFTEEN. AGAIN
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT THIS BILL
AND ON THIS SPECIFIC BILL THANK
YOU TO THE COMMITTEE STAFF AND
TO YOU MISTER CHAIR FOR WORKING
WITH ME AND- SPENDING TIME- THEN
AS JUST YET LESS THAN TWENTY
FOUR HOURS AGO- EIGHTEEN FIFTEEN
WILL STILL FOCUS ON IMPOSING A
COST ON ACTORS. WHO ARE
DESTROYING THE CULTURAL HERITAGE
OF OTHER NATION STATES- BUT
WITHOUT SACRIFICING THE CORE
INTENT- THIS BILL WILL NARROW
ITS FOCUS TO THE SPECIFIC
PRECEDENT SETTING PROVISIONAL
ORDER THAT THE INTERNATIONAL
COURT OF JUSTICE RECENTLY ISSUED
IN DECEMBER OF TWENTY TWENTY TO
AYE ICJ ISSUED A PROVISIONAL
ORDER AGAINST AZERBAIJAN
REQUIREMENT THAT THEY TAKE ALL
NECESSARY MEASURES TO PREVENT
AND PUNISH. THE VANDALISM IN
AFFECTING CULTURAL HERITAGE
INCLUDING BUT NOT LIMITED TO
CHURCHES AND OTHER PLACES OF
WORSHIP. ATTENTION NEVER REALLY
IMPACT ACADEMIC AND THEREFORE WE
WILL BE MAKING THE PROHIBITION
ON CALIFORNIA UNIVERSITIES
INVITING A SPONSOR PROFESSOR OF
PERMISSIVE WE WILL CONTINUE
WORKING WITH COMMITTEE STAFF TO
FURTHER DEFINE THE UNDER DEFINED
TERMS IN THE BILL AND AMEND THE
LANGUAGE SO THAT MUSEUMS WILL BE
NOTIFIED OF THE JUDGMENT- THESE
CHANGES WILL BE MADE PRIOR TO
THE APPROPRIATIONS HEARING. AND
THE CALIFORNIA HAS. HAS A PLACE
ON THE GLOBAL STAGE PART OF THE
REASON FOR THIS BILL WAS
CALIFORNIA'S PLACE ON THE GLOBAL
STAGE TO SET US SET SANCTIONS
COUNTRIES THAT ACT CONTRARY TO
OUR VALUES BY LIMITING THE
ACCESS TO OUR SOUGHT AFTER
CULTURAL SPACES. HOLD TO STOP.
OF JUSTICE FOR TO WITH THAT
AGAIN I'M JOINED BY MISTER ME
ONTO MY CHEN FROM THE ARMENIAN
ASSEMBLY OF AMERICA VS. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN UP AS A
STUDENT OF HISTORY. I'D LIKE TO
ADD SOME CONTEXT HISTORICAL
CONTEXT TO WHAT ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
ARE IN- JUST JUST THE STATED OF
THE GOVERNMENT OF AZERBAIJAN
SPECIFICALLY HAS A HISTORY OF
COVERING UP. ITS STATE SPONSORED
ERASURE OF INDIGENOUS ARMENIAN
CULTURAL HERITAGE ON TERRITORIES
THAT IT CURRENTLY CONTROLS
AZERBAIJAN'S ENOUGH EACH OF ON
EXCLAVE IS A CASE IN POINT. A
SEMINAL FORENSIC STUDY PUBLISHED
IN TWENTY NINETEEN BY HISTORIANS
SIMON MCKEON AND SERRA PICKMAN
TRACKED AZERBAIJAN'S DESTRUCTION
OF EIGHTY NINE MEDIEVAL ARMENIAN
CHURCHES FIVE THOUSAND EIGHT
HUNDRED FORTY INTRICATECROSS
STONES AND TWENTY TWO THOUSAND
TOMBSTONES WHICH OCCURRED
BETWEEN NINETEEN NINETY SEVEN IN
TWO THOUSAND SIX. WE ARE
FORTUNATE TO HAVE SUCH
METICULOUS DATA THANKS TO THE
PAINSTAKING EFFORTS OF HISTORIAN
ARE DUMB I BOSNIAN WHO DECADES
EARLIER ANTICIPATED THE
ERADICATION OF ARMENIAN
RELIGIOUS AND CULTURAL RELICS.
IN THE KNUCKEY TAVON EXCLAVE. TO
ADD INSULT TO INJURY
AZERBAIJAN'S DYNASTIC ALI A
FAMILY DICTATORSHIP NOTORIOUS
FOR EXECUTING A COMPLEX GLOBAL
MONEY LAUNDERING OPERATION IN
MULTI BILLION DOLLAR SLUSH FUND
KNOWN AS THE AZERBAIJANI
LAUNDROMAT. GOT AWAY SCOT FREE
WITH ITS COMPLETE ANNIHILATION
OF ARMENIAN CULTURAL HERITAGE
THAT IT BROUGHT ENOUGH EACH OF
ON DESPITE CLEAR VIDEO EVIDENCE
CAPTURING BEFORE AND AFTER
FOOTAGE OF THE DEVASTATION. AND
WITH IMPUNITY THE ALI IBRAHIM
HAS EMBARKED ON A SIMILAR STATE
CONCEIVED CAMPAIGN OF ERASURE
AND DESTRUCTION IN PARTS OF THE
ARTSAKH REPUBLIC. FORMALLY KNOWN
AS THE GOING TO KARA HAT
AZERBAIJANI FORCES SUPPORTED BY
THE TURKISH MILITARY AS WELL AS
TO HOW TO CANARIES FROM SYRIA
OVERRAN DURING THE FORT FORTY
ONE. ON ARTS UP IN THE FALL OF
TWENTY TWENTY. SO WITH THAT
CONTEXT UP. OF THE COULD THE
CURRENT BILL AB EIGHTEEN FIFTEEN
IS SO IMPORTANT BECAUSE- THE
INTERNATIONAL COURT OF JUSTICE
DID SOMETHING UNPRECEDENTED BACK
IN DECEMBER OF. OF TWENTY TWENTY
ONE IN THE CASE ARMENIA VERSES
AZERBAIJAN WHERE CALLED UPON THE
GOVERNMENT OF AZERBAIJAN TO TAKE
ALL NECESSARY MEASURES TO
PREVENT AND PUNISH ACTS OF
VANDALISM AND DESECRATION
AFFECTING ARMENIAN CULTURAL
HERITAGE. THE ISSUE THOUGH IS
THAT THE I. C. J. DOES NOT HAVE
JURISDICTION TO ENFORCE SUCH
PROVISIONAL ORDERS THAT THE
ISSUE AND THAT'S WHY IT'S
INCUMBENT UPON BOTH THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT AND ALSO ON STATES
LIKE CALIFORNIA WHICH IS WHICH
IS A BEACON. FOR MORALITY AND
DEMOCRACY IN THE UNITED STATES
AND HAS LED THE WAY ON
EVERYTHING FROM DIVESTMENT SOUTH
AFRICA OF DAVID LED THE WAY
BEFORE THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT ON
A TESTAMENT FOR SOUTH AFRICA-
AND CERTAINLY. SPENT WITH TWO
TRIPS GOVERNMENT CONTROLLED
BONDS AND ASSETS WITH WHICH THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LED. IN THE
PREVIOUS UP. CYCLE SO WITH ALL
THAT FOR ALL THOSE REASONS ABOVE
THE ARMY ASSEMBLY SUPPORTS THE
PASSAGE OF AB AB FIFTEEN A. B.
EIGHTEEN FIFTEEN. I THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME. THANK YOU. AT ANY
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. ANY
WITNESSES WHO WANT TO GO TO THE
MICROPHONE IN SUPPORT. ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. ANYONE
WANNA GO TO THE MICROPHONE IN
OPPOSITION ANY TWEETERS AND ANY
QUESTIONS COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. C. NINE. THANK YOU TO
THE AUTHOR FOR WORKING WITH MY
COMMITTEE. AND OF FOR
INTRODUCING THE LEGISLATION AND
FOR GREEN TO WORK. WITH THE
COMMITTEE TO ADDRESS OUR
CONCERNS- I DIDN'T AS I LEARNED
FROM MISTER RAMOS I'VE LEARNED
MUCH. FROM MISTER NAZARIAN IS
WELL- THANK THE OF THE IS VERY
IMPORTANT HISTORICAL- FAX. AND I
LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO
WORK TOGETHER IN THE COMING
WEEKS AND IF YOU'D LIKE TO CLOSE
. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR JUST
THAT TWO QUICK ITEMS FIRST AND
FOREMOST- THANK YOU FOR WORKING
WITH ME AGAIN ON THIS ISSUE
THANK YOU TO YOUR STAFF FOR
WORKING WITH ME ON THIS ISSUE-
WHILE. WE DON'T SET PUBLIC
POLICIES ON THE INTERNATIONAL
LEVEL IT'S CRITICAL FOR US TO
ASSERT OUR VALUE IS. BY
DEMONSTRATING WHAT IT IS THAT WE
STAND FOR WHAT IT IS THAT WE
CARE ABOUT AND MAKING SURE THAT
WE LET THE INTERNATIONAL.
THEATER NO OF OUR VALUES SO THIS
IS THIS IS IN SOME WAYS A
PRECEDENT SETTING OPPORTUNITY TO
DEMONSTRATE THAT HERE IN. ONE
CORNER OF THE UNITED STATES OF
WHAT WE CHERISH AND VALUE AND
WHAT REFLECTS OUR THE MAKE UP OF
OUR POPULATION. IN THE- TRYING
TO IN OUR CODES SO THANK YOU FOR
YOUR SUPPORT AND WORK ON THIS I
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU
AND YOUR STAFF AND SECOND VERY
MUCH APPRECIATED WORKING WITH
YOU AND I REALIZED AS MISTER
GIPSON AID BEFORE ME THAT THIS
IS ALSO GOING TO BE MY LAST BILL
IN FRONT OF YOU SO- IT'S BEEN A
PLEASURE WORKING WITH YOU AND
HAVING BEEN COME TO THIS-
INSTITUTION WITH YOU BACK IN TWO
THOUSAND TWELVE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU IN LIKEWISE. VISIBLE. THE.
THAT'S MUCH IRWIN HIS IDEA YEAH
ALL RIGHT SO WHAT WELCOME A.
MIST WHEN PRESENTING FOR BAUER
K. FILE ITEM FOR. A. B. TWENTY
SIX TWENTY SEVEN. COMISI OTHER
WITNESS WHO NEEDS TO LEAVE THANK
YOU MISTER BAKER I DON'T THAT'S
CHAIR SORRY. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BAUER K. ON I
WOULD LIKE TO ACCEPT THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS VETERANS
FORMERLY INCARCERATED
INDIVIDUALS AND FORMER FOSTER
YOUTH OFTEN DON'T KNOW ABOUT THE
EDUCATIONAL RESOURCES THAT ARE
AVAILABLE TO THEM AT THE SAME
TIME COMMUNITY COLLEGES ARE
EXPERIENCING DECLINING
ENROLLMENT. AB TWENTY SIX TWENTY
SEVEN WILL RESOLVE THIS BY
CREATING THEM- YOU WOULD
AGREEMENT WITH LOCAL AGENCIES
THIS AIR DATA. ON TOP OF
STUDENTS WITH COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICTS THIS BILL WILL EXPAND
HIGHER EDUCATION OPPORTUNITIES
FOR ALL AND I HAVE SOME
WITNESSES WITH ME THAT WERE.
THAT HAD TO LEAVE SO- PLEASE.
THANK YOU CHAIR MEMBER'S MARK
MCDONALD- MGI ADVOCACY ON BEHALF
OF THE CONTRA COSTA COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISTRICT THE
CHANCELLOR'S OF THE- THE-
SPONSORS OF THE BILL- THE
CHANCELLOR COULD NOT BE HERE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT SO I'M GOING
TO READ- A- STATEMENT THAT SHE-
SHE PER PREPARED BUT FIRST I
WANT TO THANK YOUR STEP. FOR
THEIR EXCELLENT WORK ON THIS
BILL AND WORKING WITH US IN
MAKING IT A BETTER BILL IT.
TREMENDOUS WORK- OUR COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISTRICT LIKE SO MANY
ACROSS THE STATE IS FACING
ENROLLMENT CHALLENGES IT IS NOT
ABOUT THE QUALITY OF HIGHER
EDUCATION THAT COMMUNITY
COLLEGES PROVIDE RATHER THE PAN
HAS CREATED NEW BARRIERS THAT
ARE CAUSING STUDENTS TO DROP OUT
OR TAKE A FEW SEMESTERS OFF OR
THEY JUST DON'T HAVE THE
FINANCIAL ABILITY TO MAKE
IMPORTANT DECISIONS TO
PRIORITIZE HIGHER EDUCATION.
THEY NEED IN ORDER. A GOOD
PAYING JOB WE NEED TO FIND NEW
CREATIVE AND EFFECTIVE WAYS TO
REACH POTENTIAL STUDENTS AND AB
TWENTY SIX TWENTY SEVEN AS PART
OF THAT SOLUTION. LAST YEAR WE
BEGAN A TWO PRONG STRATEGY TO
ADDRESS OUR ENROLLMENT
CHALLENGES FIRST WE THOUGHT A
PARTNERSHIP WITH OUR PETER HIGH
SCHOOL DISTRICTS TO OBTAIN
CONTACT INFORMATION FOR TENTH
AND TELL TWELFTH GRADE STUDENTS
SO THAT WE CAN INFORM THEM OF
THEIR OPPORTUNITIES FOR DUAL
ENROLLMENT. SECOND SENSE SO MUCH
OF OUR WORK AND COMMUNITY
COLLEGES IS DEDICATED TO
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES WE
DECIDED TO PARTNER WITH CONTRA
COSTA COUNTY TO SEEK A SIMILAR
OUTRAGE SHEPHERD REACHING OUT TO
SPECIFIC COMMUNITIES. FOSTER
WITH. UNEMPLOYED OR
UNDEREMPLOYED AND THOSE WHO ARE
FORMERLY INCARCERATED OR JUSTICE
INVOLVED LIKE MANY UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES THESE ARE MEMBERS OF
OUR COMMUNITY WHO ARE OFTEN
PREYED UPON BY FOR PROFIT
PRIVATE EDUCATIONAL INSTITUTIONS
AND ULTIMATELY RACK UP HUGE DEBT. THIS BILL DOES NOT CREATE DATA
MINING BUT RATHER AS AN EFFORT
TO OBTAIN CONTACT INFORMATION
FOR ENROLLMENT PURPOSES ONLY WE
TAKE THIS RESPONSIBILITY TO
PROTECT PRIVACY OF THE
INFORMATION SERIOUSLY OUR GOAL
IS TO REACH OUT AND ENCOURAGE
THESE POTENTIAL STUDENT
POPULATIONS. TO TAKE ADVANTAGE
OF THE GREAT INSTRUCTION AND
SUPPORT SERVICES OFFERED BY OUR
COMMUNITY COLLEGES. WE ASK FOR
YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU
OTHER WITNESS. GOOD AFTERNOON
DANA NICKEL WITH READ GOVERNMENT
RELATIONS. OUR CLIENTS- SUPPORT
THIS BILL THAT WOULD BE THE
AMERICAN LEGION DEPARTMENT OF
CALIFORNIA AMVETS DEPARTMENT OF
CALIFORNIA CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTY VETERANS
SERVICE OFFICERS CALIFORNIA
STATE COMMANDER VETERANS COUNCIL
MILITARY OFFICERS ASSOCIATION
AMERICAN THE VIETNAM VETERANS OF
AMERICA. THE YOUNG MEN AND WOMEN
WHO SERVED OUR COUNTRY THE
MILITARY FACE A COMPETITIVE
DISADVANTAGE WHEN DISCHARGING
FROM THE MILITARY. THEY STOOD UP
TO PROTECT OUR FREEDOMS BY
MAKING A COMMITMENT TO DUTY.
THEY DID THIS AT A TIME IN OUR
LIVES WHEN MOST EIGHTEEN YEAR
OLDS WERE ATTENDING COLLEGE
BURNING TRADES IN BUILDING
RESUMS. UPON SEPARATION FROM
MILITARY SERVICE THESE VETERANS
MUST RE INTEGRATE INTO THE
CIVILIAN WORLD. HOWEVER THEY
HAVE ACCESS TO ONE OF THE MOST
OF. EVEN AFTER THE MID TWENTIETH
CENTURY. A POLICY WHICH ALLOWED
MANY VETERANS TO BE THE FIRST
ONES TO GRADUATE FROM COLLEGE IN
THE ENTIRE HISTORY OF THEIR
FAMILY. VAST NUMBERS OF WORLD
WAR TWO KOREA AND VIETNAM
VETERANS BECAME THE TEACHERS
SCIENTISTS ENGINEERS DOCTORS
NURSES AND TECHNICIANS. THE FUEL
THE TECHNOLOGY BOOM AND BUILT
THE CALIFORNIA DREAM. THIS
PROGRAM THE GI BILL STILL EXISTS
IS BEEN IMPROVED AND EXPANDED.
OVER THE YEARS. THERE ARE ALSO
OTHER MANY OTHER FEDERAL AND
STATE PROGRAMS AVAILABLE FOR
VETERANS AS WELL AS CURRENT
MILITARY MEMBERS TO ATTEND
COLLEGE. HOWEVER LIKE MANY
GOVERNMENT PROGRAMS AND BENEFITS
THEY'RE OFTEN OBSCURED BY THE
SHEER VOLUME OF INFORMATION
AVAILABLE TO EVERYONE BECAUSE OF
THE INFORMATION AGE. WHEN
VETERANS GET OUT OF THE
MILITARY. THEY ARE BUSY TRYING
TO SECURE HOUSING TINA JOB GET
THE KIDS IN THE LOCAL SCHOOLS
CETERA. AB TWENTY SIX TWENTY
SEVEN ONE HAS TO GET ABILITY OF
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES TO
PERFORM DIRECT OUTREACH TO
CALIFORNIA'S VETERANS. INFORM
THEM OF THE PROGRAMS AND
SERVICES AVAILABLE THANK YOU.
YOU ANY OTHER WHO WANT TO COME
TO THE MICROPHONE IN SUPPORT.
MICHAEL YOUNG WITH CALIFORNIA
FEDERATION OF TEACHERS AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU. ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN POSITION. ANY
TWEETERS. C. NINE ANY QUESTIONS
COMMENTS. YEAH WELL FIRST OF ALL
I DO EXPRESS THE OTHER MY
GRATITUDE FOR BRINGING FOR THIS
BILL AND- DOING EVERYTHING THAT
WE CAN PREVENTIONS AND EDUCATION
IS I THINK A PRIORITY AND THEN
AS PART OF WHO WE ARE IN THE
SELECTION. THE ONLY QUESTION OR
I DO HAVE AN IT'S OKAY IF YOU
DON'T HAVE THE ANSWER IS- IS
THERE KNOCKED OUT- IN THIS DAY
AND AGE. I WAS JUST LOOKING AT.
MY YOU KNOW ONE OF MY EMAIL
ACCOUNTS THAT IS JUST MY JUNK
ACCOUNT AND THERE'S LIKE FIVE
THOUSAND EMAILS I NEED TO GO
THROUGH IT I KNOW- BUT- IT DO WE
GET. INUNDATED WITH SO MUCH
INFORMATION I WANT TO KNOW IS
THERE KNOCKED OUT- YES THERE IS
A KNOCK OUT SO- THEY WILL. THEY
WILL REACH OUT CONTACTS- THE
LET'S SAY THE VETERAN AND THE
VETERAN HAS AN OPPORTUNITY RIGHT
AT THAT POINT TO OPT OUT IN THE
WILL. IF I WANTED THE AUTHOR FOR
WORKING WITH THE- COMMITTEE TO
ADDRESS OUR CONCERNS AND
ACCEPTING THE AMENDMENTS AND
WITH THAT IF YOU'D LIKE TO CLOSE
AND I WILL US UP AT PASS ON THAT
THANK YOU TO THE AUTHOR AND OF
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE VOTE
WENT. AND THANK YOU FOR
EXPLODED. SO WITH THAT WE WILL
GO TO FILE ITEM TWENTY THREE.
MISS PETRI NORSE. IF YOU'RE
READY. YOU MAY BEGIN WHEN YOU
ARE. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR ANTI
GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS HAPPY TO
JOIN YOU TODAY TO PRESENT
ASSEMBLY BILL NINETEEN EIGHTEEN
. REPRODUCTIVE FREEDOM IS UNDER
ASSAULT ALL ACROSS THIS COUNTRY
AND WHILE CALIFORNIA HAS BEEN A
STRONG LEADER IN PROTECTING
PROTECTING REPRODUCTIVE RIGHTS
EVEN HERE IN CALIFORNIA MANY
WOMEN IN OUR STATE LACK ACCESS
TO COMPREHENSIVE REPRODUCTIVE
CARE IN FACT 40% OF CALIFORNIA
COUNTIES DON'T HAVE A SINGLE
ABORTION PROVIDER. THIS BILL
WILL CREATE A REPRODUCTIVE
HEALTH SERVICE CORPS IN
CALIFORNIA AND THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE ACCESS AND
INFORMATION INSPIRED BY THE
NATIONAL HEALTH SERVICE CORPS
THIS PROPOSAL WILL GREATLY
STRENGTHEN OUR HEALTH CARE
EDUCATION PIPELINE RECRUITING
TRAINING AND RETAINING A DIVERSE
WORK FORCE AS MEDICAL
PROFESSIONALS TRAINED IN
REPRODUCTIVE SERVICES THEY WILL
THEN BE ASSIGNED TO TEAMS AND
UNDERSERVED AREAS ACROSS
CALIFORNIA. PROUD TO ADD TO
WORKING WITH A TERRIFIC. THESE
NOW. ARE WITH FLOOR TO TEACH AN
ZERO EIGHT CARRASCO AND OUR AND
STUDENT NURSE MIDWIFE AT AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA SAN
FRANCISCO. THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN ENOUGH
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS FOR HUNTER I'M THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF TEACHER. TRAINING
EARLY ABORTION FOR COMPREHENSIVE
HEALTH CARE WHERE PROUD SPONSOR
OF THIS BILL- FOR NINETEEN YEARS
TEACH HAS CULTIVATED THE NEXT
GENERATION OF DIVERSE
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CHAMPIONS
THROUGH ABORTION TRAINING AND
MENTORSHIP AND- PRODUCED AN
ACADEMIC CURRICULUM AND EARLY
ABORTION CARE FOR PRIMARY CARE
PROVIDERS. I AM THRILLED TO WORK
WITH ASSEMBLY WOMAN CAUGHT
BETWEEN NORRIS ON THIS BILL THAT
WOULD CREATE A CALIFORNIA
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH SERVICE
CORPS. THIS GREW OUT OF THE
CALIFORNIA FUTURES OF ABORTION
COUNTS AND THE HONOR OF SERVING
AS CHAIR OF THE WORK FORCE
WORKING GROUP. MODELED AFTER THE
NATIONAL HEALTH SERVICE CORPS
ESTABLISHED FIFTY YEARS AGO AB
NINETEEN EIGHTEEN WOULD DO FOR
ABORTION CARE ACCESS IN
CALIFORNIA. WHAT THAT N. H. AS
SEATED FOR PRIMARY CARE ACCESS
IN ON. AREAS OTHER SHIPMENTS BY
PENCE FOR ALL MEMBERS OF THE
HEALTHCARE TEAM AB NINETEEN
EIGHTEEN CREATES EDUCATIONAL
PATHWAYS THAT MEET THE REAL
NEEDS OF DIVERSE ASPIRING HEALTH
CARE PROFESSIONALS WE CAN'T GET
SERIOUS ABOUT DIVERSIFYING THE
HEALTHCARE WORKFORCE IF WE
AREN'T WILLING TO INVEST UP
FRONT IN THEIR DEVELOPMENT AND
THEIR CAREERS AND THE SOME FRONT
INVESTMENT WILL ENSURE THEIR
HEALTHCARE WORK. IS ABLE TO MEET
THE DATE THE NEEDS OF
CALIFORNIA'S DIVERSE POPULATIONS
. THIS BILL ALSO ADDRESSES
SOMETHING VERY CLOSE TO MY HEART
THE SHORTAGE OF OPPORTUNITIES
FOR ABORTION TRAINING GRADUATES
OF THE TEACH PROGRAM ARE THE
LUCKY FEW. THEY'RE PART OF JUST
6% OF FAMILY MEDICINE RESIDENTS
WERE GETTING ABORTION TRAINING
THROUGH THEIR RESIDENCY. AND FOR
ADVANCED PRACTICE NURSES THIS
TRAINING IS EVEN LESS ACCESSIBLE
. EVEN HEALTH CARE PROVIDERS WHO
ARE VERY COMMITTED TO PROVIDING
ABORTION CARE- HAVE A VERY HARD
TIME ACCESSING TRAINING THERE IS
NO ACCESS WITHOUT PROVIDERS AND
NINETEEN EIGHTEEN INVEST IN OUR
CAPACITY. TO TRAIN HEALTHCARE
PROVIDERS SO THEY CAN GAIN THE
NECESSARY SKILLS THEY NEED TO
PROVIDE ABORTION CARE
MISCARRIAGE MANAGEMENT OR
CONTRACEPTION. IT'S MEMBERS GET
THE TRAINING THEY WANT PROVIDE
CARE IN UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES
OF CALIFORNIA AND EXPAND ACCESS
ACCESS TO REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH
CARE FOR ALL. I URGE YOU TO VOTE
AB ON AB NINETEEN EIGHTEEN SO
THE CALIFORNIA HAS THE STRONGEST
BEST TRAINED REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH
WORK FORCE IN THE COUNTRY
CAPABLE OF MEETING THE NEEDS OF
ALL PEOPLE SEEKING CARE IN OUR
GREAT STATE. THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON MISTER CHANG COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. MY NAME IS- ACROSS GO
I'M CURRENTLY IN MY LAST QUARTER
OF MIDWIFERY PROGRAM AT UCSF.
I'M EXPRESSING STRONG SUPPORT
FOR THE REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH
SERVICE CARDS AS A WAY TO
INCREASE ABORTION ACCESS. IN
CALIFORNIA. AS A NURSE MIDWIFE
THERE ARE ALMOST NO AVENUES TO
BECOME PROFICIENT IN ABORTION
CARE. AS A STUDENT OR AFTERWARDS
AS A PROFESSIONAL. UNFORTUNATELY
LIMITATION ON OUR TRAINING HAS
RESTRICTED MIDWIFE TO OFFER
ABORTION AS PART OF THEIR CARE.
IN MY TWO YEAR PROGRAM I HAD
VERY LITTLE HANDS ON TRAINING.
WE RECEIVED ONLY A NINETY MINUTE
LECTURE AND MEDICAL ASPIRATION
OF OPTION. ONE OUR RESTORATION.
SKILLS SESSION AND ONE TWO TWO
FOUR HOUR SHIFTS. AT SAN
FRANCISCO GENERAL HOSPITAL
ABORTION CLINIC. THIS FRANCISCO
GENERAL HOSPITAL IN PERSON
TRAINING WERE MOSTLY
OBSERVATION. IN MY EXPERIENCE
LEARNING OPPORTUNITIES WERE
PRIORITIZE TO MEDICAL STUDENTS.
REALLY STATE WE ARE QUALIFIED TO
PROVIDE SAFE ABORTIONS. THIS CAR
CITY OF ABORTION TRAINING
CALIFORNIA CALIFORNIA HAS LED.
MIDWEST IN OTHER ADVANCED NURSE
PRACTITIONERS TO LEAVE THE STATE
TO INCREASE OUR PORTION
TRAINING. THE RELOCATION OF
PROVIDERS TO OTHER STATES LEAVE
THOSE AND RURAL COMMUNITIES LIKE
THE CENTRAL VALLEY WHERE I GREW
UP MOST IN NEED. I PERSONALLY
UNDERSTAND THE MEDICAL CHART OF
CONSEQUENCES AND RURAL
COMMUNITIES I GREW UP IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY WITH A PROBABLY
AN INCH OF FARMWORKERS. FOR THIS
REASON IF I HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY
TO INCREASE MY ABORTION TRAINING
AND CALIFORNIA I WOULD HELP TO
INCREASE ACCESS AND RURAL
COMMUNITIES IN ADDITION. PROVIDE
LANGUAGE AND CULTURAL CONGRUENCY
TO THE DIVERSE THAT THE NEXT
POPULATION OF CALIFORNIA. PLEASE
CONSIDER THE POSITIVE LONG TERM
IMPACT TO THIS TO THIS
REPRODUCTIVE JUSTICE. IN
CALIFORNIA BY PASSING THIS BILL
BILL FOR THIS FOR THIS REASON I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A YES VOTE
ON AB NINETEEN EIGHTEEN. THANK
YOU OTHER LIKE TO GO TO THE
MICROPHONE SAY YOUR NAME. GROUP
YOU REPRESENT. GOOD AFTERNOON
GENESIS GONZALEZ ON BEHALF
LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR LENNY
CARACAS IN SUPPORT. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR MARTIN ROSS
WHICH ON BEHALF OF NARAL PRO
CHOICE CALIFORNIA IN CALIFORNIA-
NURSE MIDWIVES ASSOCIATION AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU. HELLO CHAIR
I'M GONNA CHÁVEZ ABORTION
TRAINING COORDINATOR FOR TEACH
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB NINETEEN
EIGHTEEN. KIMBERLY ROBINSON WITH
BLACK WOMEN FOR WELLNESS AND
BLACK WOMEN FOR WELLNESS ACTION
PROJECT ALSO IN STRONG SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON LINDA WITH THE
BLACK WOMEN'S WELLNESS PROGRAM-
AND I'M IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
NINETEEN EIGHTY THANK YOU ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. ANY
WITNESSES WANTING TO GO TO THE
MICROPHONE IN OPPOSITION ANY TWO
WINNERS NOT SEEN ANY. COMMENTS
OR QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE. NO COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS I
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING
THIS FORWARD AND AS I HEARD THE
TESTIMONY FROM OUR WITNESSES
VERY MUCH REMINDED OF THE
MISSION OF THE- MEDICAL SCHOOL
IN MY DISTRICT UCR'S SCHOOL OF
MEDICINE- THAT IS HAS IS
MAINTAINED. TO MEET THE NEEDS OF
THE DIVERSE POPULATION OF MY
REGION- BOTH CULTURALLY
LINGUISTICALLY AND ALL OTHER
WAYS SO I HAVE A- BEEN VERY
PROUD TO. STAND UP FOR
REPRODUCTIVE RIGHTS AND WOULD
ADDED AS A CO AUTHOR. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR YES I'D BE HONORED
TO HAVE YOU AS A CO AUTHOR THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. IF YOU'D LIKE TO
CLOSE WELL THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE THANK YOU AND WE'LL
BRING IT UP AT THE- ONCE WE HAVE
A CORE. THANK YOU AND WITH THAT
WILL- INVITE MISTER GRAY. FILE
ITEM. FILE ITEM FOURTEEN. THE
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR
NUMBERS. THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY PRESENT AB. TWENTY
FIVE TWENTY TWO- THIS WILL
CREATE A FIRST OF ITS KIND FIRST
IN THE NATION LOAN FOR PROGRAM.
KÞT TO SUPPORT PUBLIC HEALTH
WORKFORCE. COVERT NINETEEN
THIRTIES TO ONCE IN A LIFETIME
HEALTH CRISIS INTO AN ALREADY
pPUBLIC HEALTH ENVIRONMENT WITH A
RESPONSE RESTING LARGELY ON
LOCAL HEALTH DEPARTMENTS. THE
CHALLENGES BROUGHT ON BY THE
PANDEMIC AND LEAD US TO THE AXIS
OF OVER TWO HUNDRED PUBLIC
HEALTH LEADERS THROUGHOUT THE
COUNTRY. IT AT LEAST CALIFORNIA
RESULTING IN A HISTORIC LOSS OF
PUBLIC HEALTH KNOWLEDGE. PUBLIC
HEALTH EMPLOYEES WHO HAVE WORKED
THROUGHOUT THE PANDEMIC REPORT
INCREASED INSTANCES OF ANXIETY
DEPRESSION. HIGHLIGHTING THE
NEED FOR RETENTION INCENTIVES IN
SUPPORT. THE SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY
IN PARTICULAR EXPERIENCE
INEQUITABLE BURDEN WITH VALLEY
COUNTIES REPRESENTING MORE THAN
50% OF THE COUNTIES WITH THE TOP
TEN HIGHEST DEATH ATES FROM
COVERT NINETEEN THROUGHOUT THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. THIS IS
REGION WHICH ALREADY HAS SOME OF
THE LOWEST RATIO OF LICENSE
HEALTH CARE PROFESSIONALS IN THE
STATE AS THE CHAIRS WELL AWARE-
AND ALSO REPRESENTS REGION- VERY
SIMILAR. JUST TO ILLUSTRATE THE
CHALLENGES MERCED COUNTY WHERE I
LIVE REPORTER 52% TURNOVER RATE
OF PUBLIC HEALTH STAFF POSITIONS
SINCE TWENTY SEVENTEEN. WHEN YOU
COMBINE ALL THESE PROBLEMS AND
COUPLE IT WITH THE VALLEY'S
HISTORIC ECONOMIC DISADVANTAGES
IT BECOMES CLEAR THAT MORE NEEDS
TO BE DONE. THE CLINICAL
HEALTHCARE WORKFORCE IS
SUPPORTED BY A WIDE VARIETY OF
BOTH STATE AND FEDERAL LOAN
REPAYMENT PROGRAMS IN ADDITION
TO EMPLOYER BASED. MOVEMENT
NUMBER TEN. THESE LOAN REPAYMENT
PROGRAMS ALLOW LICENSE HEALTH
CARE PROFESSIONALS ACROSS THE
WHOLE SPECTRUM TO WORK FOR
DEFINED SERVICE PERIOD IN
EXCHANGE FOR FULL. OR PARTIAL
LOAN REPAYMENT OR EVEN LOAN
FORGIVENESS. UNFORTUNATELY THESE
PROGRAMS EXCLUDE ALL NON MEDICAL
HEALTHCARE WORKERS INCLUDING THE
MAJORITY OF PUBLIC HEALTH
POSITIONS. RATHER THAN ASK
PUBLIC HEALTH WORKERS TO COMPETE
FOR THE ALREADY OVER SUBSCRIBED
RESOURCES PROVIDED TO THESE
OTHER PROGRAMS AB TWENTY FIVE
TWENTY TWO WOULD GIVE THEM THEIR
OWN PROGRAM DEDICATED TO THE
QUARTERBACKS OF THE COVERT
NINETEEN RESPONSE HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. I WANT TO THANK CMA
MERCED COUNTY AND THE SAN
JOAQUIN VALLEY PUBLIC HEALTH
CONSORTIUM WHO PUT IN THE
LEGWORK TO HELP ME DEVELOP THIS
PROPOSAL. I HAVE WITH ME TODAY
MISTER CHAIR DENIS CUEVAS
ROMERO- FROM THE CALIFORNIA
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION HERE IN
SUPPORT- CAN PROVIDE SOME
TESTIMONY CERTAINLY ASK OR
ANSWER ANY. ANY QUESTIONS THE
COMMITTEE MAY HAVE. THANK YOU
MAY BEGIN WHEN YOU'RE READY
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN BIRDS
DENNIS LET US FROM METAL- WITH
THE CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION PRESS BONTA TO THE
BILL. LIKE WORKFORCE'S DURING
THE PANDEMIC BURNED OUT AND
ISSUES RELATED TO RETURN RIDE
RETENTION AND RECRUITMENT HAS
BEEN ALL TOO REAL OUR MEMBERS
UNDERSTAND THE DIRE NEED TO
PROTECT AND BUILD THIS IMPORTANT
WORK FORCE BECAUSE OF THE
CRITICAL WORK ON HEALTH EQUITY
HEALTH PROMOTION AND CHRONIC
DISEASE PREVENTION THE
CALIFORNIA FUTURE HEALTH
WORKFORCE COMMISSION IN TWENTY
NINETEEN IDENTIFIED. SCARCE A
WIDE HEALTH. SKEWS ME HEALTH
PROFESSIONAL SHORTAGE CRISIS
PUBLIC HEALTH DEPARTMENTS HAVE
BEEN UNDERSTAFFED AND
UNDERFUNDED FOR DECADES DESPITE
VARIOUS RESPONSIBILITIES THEY
ARE WITH. AS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GRAY MENTION AB TWENTY FIVE
TWENTY TWO WOULD BE FIRST OF ITS
KIND- THE BILL IS ANOTHER TOOL
TO AND SENSE OF INCENTIVIZE
RECRUITMENT FOR NEW TALENT AND
RETAINING THE EXISTING WORKFORCE
PARTICULARLY IN UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES THANK YOU FOR YOUR
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY IN HERE
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS THANK
YOU ANY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
LIKE TO GO TO THE MICROPHONE. C.
NINE ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES.
OKAY. ANY ANY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY FIVE TWENTY
TWO MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS TOYOTA
WE HAVE THE MERCED COUNTY SUIT-
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS A CO
SPONSOR SUPPORT- DR- THANK YOU
THANK YOU. ANY OPPOSITION TO AB
TWENTY FIVE TWENTY TWO. C. NINE
ANY TWEETERS AB TWENTY FIVE
TWENTY TWO ALSO SEEING NINE.
WHAT OKAY THE SECRETARY IS GOING
TO CALL THE ROLL TO ESTABLISH
KERR. MEDINA CHOI ARAMBULA BLOOM
GABRIEL IRWIN. KILEY LEVINE LOW
SANTIAGO BALLADARES WEBER. FORM
IS ESTABLISHED- ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
SECOND FIRST IN A SECOND R. I. I
WANTED TO THE AUTHOR THEN I'M
PREPARED TO SUPPORT THE MEASURE
TODAY I BELIEVE THE STATE SHOULD
COME UP WITH INCENTIVES TO
RECRUIT BUT IT WILL WORK FOR- I
ENCOURAGE. AT THE AUTHOR. CAN
YOU TO WORK. WITH MY COLLEAGUES
HAVE SIMILAR MEASURES ADDRESSING
THE ISSUE. AS WELL AS DETERMINE
OF THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
AXES IN INFORMATION. ENTITY
MINISTER. AND IF YOU'D LIKE TO
CLOSE THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
PRECIADO YOUR COMMENTS AND
CERTAINLY WILL WORK DILIGENTLY
WITH MY COLLEAGUES. ARE YOU AN
EXCELLENT PIECE OF PUBLIC POLICY
WITH NO OPPOSITION AND THANK YOU
FOR YOUR SUPPORT I RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOU ABOUT. WE HAD A FIRST BY. MISS VALID THERE IS A SECOND
BY- BUT MR LEVINE MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
APPROACH SINCE COMMITTEE MEDINA
HI MEDINA I CHOI CHOICE HI
ARAMBULA ARAMBULA ACT MMHM. BLOW
THEM UP GABRIEL IRWIN IRWIN I
CURRENTLY. KILEY I LEVINE LEVINE
I LOW SANTIAGO BALLADARES
BUILDERS I WEBER. EIGHT ZERO THE
BILL IS OUT WE WILL LEAVE IT
OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU. YEAH
OKAY OKAY. THAT'S WHERE WE'RE
GONNA TAKE OUTLINES AND THEN
WE'LL WE'LL MOVE ON WITH A- SIX
BILLS SHOULD SHOULD I MAKE A
MOTION TO A BILL THAT HAS BEEN
PRESENTED. WITH YEAH OKAY. WE'RE
GONNA DO ADD ONS IS A MATCH HI.
WELL RIGHT WILL WE CAN WE CAN
START ON YEAH YEAH THAT'S WHAT
WE'RE GONNA DO. OKAY YEAH SO
WE'RE WE'RE GONNA TAKE A VOTE
AND THEN WE'LL GO TO THE NEXT
ITEM. AND IT WILL NEED MOTIONS.
SO FILE ITEM TWENTY FOUR AB
NINETEEN THIRTY SIX SO MOVED.
OKAY NUMBER. TWENTY FOUR. THE
MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE MEDINA
HI MEDINA I SAW A- CHOI I
ARAMBULA. RUMBLE I'D BLOOM LOOM
II GABRIEL IRWIN IRWIN I KILEY
KILEY II LEVINE LEVINE I LOW
SANTIAGO VALLADARES GALLAGHER I
WEBER. WEBER AVE IT WORSENED
DURING THEIR. NINE ZERO NINE
ZERO THAT BILL IS OUT WE LEAVE
IT OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS. YEAH
YEAH YEAH. FILE ITEM ONE AB
SEVENTEEN OH FIVE THE. THE
MOTION IS DUE PASSED THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE. MEDINA
MEDINA I SAW A CHOI I ARAMBULA.
FILE ITEM WEBER ONE. ARAMBULA HI
BLOOM BLOOM I GABRIEL IRWIN
IRWIN I HIGHLY HIGHLY I'D LEVINE
LEVINE I'D LOW SANTIAGO
BALLADARES. VALLADARES I WEBER
WEBER I'D. THANK. NINE ZERO AB
SEVENTEEN OH FIVE IS OUT WILL
LEAVE IT OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS
. FILE ITEM TWO A. B. TWO THREE
ONE FIVE THE MOTION IS TO PASS
THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE ON
IN A MOTION AND A SECOND- MEDINA
HI MEDINA I CHOI. CHILE NOT
VOTING ARAMBULA ARAMBULA I BLOOM
BLOOM HI GABRIEL. IRWIN IRWIN I
KILEY KILEY NOT BOATING LEVINE
LEVINE AYE LOW SANTIAGO
BALLADARES CALAVERAS AYE WEBER.
WEBER I. IT'S A- SEVEN ZERO AB
TWENTY THREE FIFTEEN IS I WILL
LEAVE IT OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS
FILE. R. A. SIX TWENTY SEVEN I
IN A MOTION AND A SECOND. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
DANA HI MEDINA I SAW A- CHOI
VOTING ARAMBULA ARAMBULA I BLOOM
BLOOM HI GABRIEL IRWIN. IRWIN I
KILEY KILEY EYES LEVINE LEVINE I
LOW SANTIAGO BALLADARES
VALLADARES HI WEBER. WEBER HI.
EIGHT EIGHT ZERO AB TWENTY SIX
TWENTY SEVEN IS OUT WILL LEAVE
IT OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS. FILE
ITEM EIGHT AB TWENTY FOUR
THIRTEEN I NEED A MOTION AND A
SECOND. I NEED A SECOND. THE
MOTION IS DO YOU PASS TO THE
FLOOR. MEDINA NUMBER EIGHT AB
TWENTY FOUR THIRTEEN. MEDINA HI
MEDINA I SAW A CHOI I ARAMBULA
ARAMBULA AYE BLOOM BLOOM HI
GABRIEL- WHEN- WHEN I HIGHLY
KILEY NARROW LEVINE BUT I LOW
SANTIAGO VALLADARES. BALLADARES
NOT VOTING WEBER WEBER I. SEVEN
ONE SEVEN ONE AB TWENTY FOUR
THIRTEEN IS OUT. FILE ITEM FILE
ITEM NINE AB TWENTY FOUR FIFTY
NINE I NEED A MOTION AND A
SECOND. THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE MEDINA HI MEDINA I SAW
A- CHOI I ARAMBULA. ARAMBULA I'D
BLOOM BLOOM I GABRIEL IRWIN.
IRWIN I HIGHLY HIGHLY AYE LEVINE
LEVINE I LOW SANTIAGO BALLADARES
VALLADARES HI WEBER WEBER II.
NINE ZERO AB TWENTY FOUR FIFTY
NINE IS OUT LEAVE IT OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS. FILE ITEM TEN AB
TWENTY FOUR NINETY ONE I NEED A
MOTION AND A SECOND. THE MOTION
IS TO PASS TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE. MEDINA HI MEDINA HI
CHILE CHOI I ARAMBULA ARAMBULA
I'D BLOOM. BLOOM HI GABRIEL
IRWIN. WHEN I KILEY. KILEY II
LEVINE LEVINE I LOW SANTIAGO
VALDEZ BALLADARES I WEBER. WEBER
I'D. NINE ZERO AB TWENTY FOUR
NINETY ONE IS OUT LEAVE IT OPEN
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS. FILE ITEM
THIRTEEN AB NINETEEN NINETY
SEVEN I NEED A MOTION AND A
SECOND. SECOND. GET A SECOND
WITH THE- NUMBER THIRTEEN AB
NINETEEN NINETY SEVEN. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE MEDINA
ALL RIGHT MEDINA I CHOI CHU I
KNOW ARAMBULA ARAMBULA ALLY
BLOOM. BLOOM I GABRIEL IRWIN.
IRWIN NOT VOTING KILEY KILEY
NARROW LEVINE. LEVINE I LOW
SANTIAGO BALLADARES NO THERE IS
NOT VOTING WEBER. WEBER HI. TO
CALL. FIVE TWO AB NINETEEN
NINETY SEVEN IS ON CALL. FILE
ITEM TWENTY ONE A. B. EIGHTEEN
OH ONE I NEED A MOTION AND A
SECOND. WITH ALL. THE SECOND.
FILE ITEM TWENTY ONE AB EIGHTEEN
NO ONE. OKAY THE MOTION IS DUE
PASSED TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE MEDINA HI MEDINA I SAW
A- CHOI I ARAMBULA AROUND JULY
BLOOM. BLOOM I. GABRIEL IRWIN.
LEVINE I LOW SANTIAGO VALIDUS
VALIDUS I WEBER WEBER II. NINE
NINE ZERO AB EIGHTEEN NO ONE IS
UP. WITHOUT THEM WE'LL LEAVE IT
OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS. FILE
ITEM TWENTY TWO A. B. EIGHTEEN
FIFTY FIVE EIGHT EIGHTEEN
FIFTEEN THE MOTION IN THE SECOND
. THANK. BUT THE MOTION IS TO
PASS TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE. MEDINA HI MEDINA I
CHOI CHOI NOT BOATING ARAMBULA.
IT NAY IT IS TO CLARIFY- I'M I'M
RECOMMENDING YES AND YES HE-
ACCEPTED THE IMMENSE. ARAMBULA I
BLOOM BLOOM I GABRIEL IRWIN-
WHEN I KILEY. KILEY NARROW
LEVINE LEVINE I LOW SANTIAGO
VALIDUS VALIDUS I WEBER. WEBER
AVE. SEVEN ONE SEVEN ONE A. B.
EIGHTEEN FIFTEEN IS OUT LEAVE IT
OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS. FILE
ITEM TWENTY THREE A. B. NINETEEN
EIGHTEEN I NEED A MOTION AND A
SECOND. OKAY THE MOTION IS TO
PASS THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE MEDINA HI MEDINA I SAW
A- CHOI SO I KNOW ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA AYE BLOOM BLOOM I
GABRIEL IRWIN IRWIN I HIGHLY
KILEY NARROW LEVINE LEVINE I LOW
SANTIAGO BALLADARES VALLADARES
NO WEBER. WEBER HI. SIX THREE AB
NINETEEN EIGHTEEN IS ON CALL.
FILE ITEM. THANK WE GET TWENTY
FIVE WOULDN'T BE SURE OKAY
HE SAID AND THEN WE'LL GO BACK
TO. PRESENTATIONS CONSENT
CALENDAR ITEM OCEAN IN THE
SECOND. MEDINA HI MEDINA I CHOI
CHOI I ARAMBULA ARAMBULA AYE
BLOOM BLOOM I GABRIEL IRWIN
IRWIN I KILEY KILEY EYES LEVINE
LEVINE I LOW SANTIAGO BALLADARES
BALLADARES I WEBER. WEBER I'D-
ZERO NINE ZERO CONSENT CALENDARS
OUT AND WE WILL LEAVE IT OPEN
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS AND NOW I
INVITE MR JONES SAWYER FILE ITEM
FIFTEEN A. B. SIXTEEN FIFTY FIVE
FOR ILLNESS. EIGHT GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS I AM
HERE TODAY PRESENT AB SIXTEEN
FIFTY FIVE JUNETEENTH STATE
HOLIDAY AT. FOR THOSE WHO MAY
KNOW JUNE TWO YOUTH IF THE
ANNUAL CELEBRATION OF JUNE
NINETEENTH EIGHTEEN SIXTY FIVE
WHEN WORD OF FREEDOM REACHED THE
LAST INSULATE BLACK PEOPLE IN
PUBLISHED IN BAIT THIS IS. A
FINAL COMBAT STATE LABOR
EMPLOYED. SHE WAS ISSUED BY
PRESIDENT ABRAHAM LINCOLN AFTER
TWO LONG YEARS IN EIGHTEEN SIXTY
THREE DEVELOP FREEDOM RAN FOR
OVER THREE MILLION BLACK
AMERICANS THAT DAY MARKED THE
BEGINNING OF A FIGHT TO PROVIDE
FAIR AND EQUAL TREATMENT. FOR TO
REMIND. D. THE COMPANY IN RECENT
YEARS WE HAVE WITNESSED
SIGNIFICANT EFFORTS BY BOTH
FEDERAL AND STATE GOVERNMENTS TO
NOW IS TO HISTORY AND ADDRESS
THE PLIGHT OF THE BLACK AMERICAN
COMMUNITY DESPITE THE PROP IN
MAY STILL HAVE A LONG WAY TO GO
DID YOU TEETH STATE HOLIDAY ACT
. THE MEASURE. THIS DAY A PURPLE
HOLIDAY AS IMPACTFUL AS THESE
RESOLUTIONS MAY BE THIS DAY IN
AMERICAN HISTORY DESERVES ITS
PROPER RESPECT UNDER AB SIXTEEN
FIFTY FIVE- WILL OFFICIALLY
BECOME A PAID HOLIDAY FOR STATE
EMPLOYEES UNION ART WAS THE KING
SISTER SARAH. AB THIRTY FIVE
HAVE COME TO JOIN UP THERE
ALREADY OF. JUNETEENTH A PAID
STATE HOW SAYS TAX. NEW YORK
VIRGINIA WASHINGTON AND ILLINOIS
MORE SIGNIFICANTLY DESPITE WILL
MARK IN HISTORY A MOMENT FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS TO REFLECT UPON
BLACK AMERICAN HISTORY AND A
BEARS A PERSISTENT OUR COMMUNITY
TO THIS DAY. HERE TO PROVIDE
TESTIMONY BOARD IS STOP BERATES
. A WITH CALIFORNIA'S EMPLOYEES
. A COLD. OF BILL. IT MAY BEGIN
. THE NEW MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS SANDRA BARRERA ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
EMPLOYEES ASSOCIATION WE ARE CO
SPONSORS OF THIS BILL FIRST I'D
LIKE TO THANK THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FOR AUTHORING THE BILL
THANK IS THAT ARE. OR I WOULD
LIKE TO ALLOW MYSELF WITH
ASSEMBLY JONES LAWYERS COMMENTS
ALL CHEN BAD THAT. INCOME FORTY
ENTIRE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
EMPLOYEE TO ANY DAY. BY THE- OF
THE DEBT. I'M ON FORTY MANY DID
NOT COMPLY WITH THAT LAW WHEN
HAS. EIGHT IN. OKAY IS JUNE
EIGHTEENTH AS A GIRL. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER JONES SAWYER OR POINTED
THE LIST OF STATES THAT PER JUNE
TASTE HOLIDAY. I AM FOR CAP
WANTED TO CREATE FOR WERE PEOPLE
TOWARDS JUNE. I RESPECTFULLY I
FOR YOUR I. VOTING. OTHER THAT I
CAN IF YOU GIVE YOUR NAME AND
THE OR IN YOU'RE RIGHT. HI MY
NAME'S JOHNSON FOR VICE THE
LEGISLATURE IS FOR THE SENATE
FOR CALIFORNIA ME COLLEGES THANK
YOU IN A STRONG. THANK ARGHEZI
INVITES CHAIRMAN RELATIONS FOR
THE STUDENT ASSOCIATION STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. I DON'T KNOW
ABOUT BUT I'M A STUDENT AND I'M
A STRONG SUPPORT. ACTUALLY
JOHNSON ON BEHALF OF PACIFIC GAS
AND ELECTRIC COMPANY IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. ALYSSA YOM ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY EMPLOYEES UNION AND
THE WRITERS GUILD OF AMERICA
WEST IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON
USHERED IN SWANSON WITH THE CAL
STATE STUDENT ASSOCIATION AND WE
ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU
SO MUCH THANK YOU. OKAY NEED A
WITH THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL OF
CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT THANK YOU. DAVE AGAIN REPRESENTING THE
COUNTY SUPERINTENDENTS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
. MICHAEL YOUNG WITH A
FEDERATION TEACHERS ONE OF THE
COSPONSORS THE BILL A STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. CAN WITH SEEK
HELP MAKE COLLEGE INDEPENDENTS
SUPPORT THANK YOU. ANY WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION. ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION WANTED TO GO TO THE
MICROPHONES. ANY CLEANERS C.
NINE WILL GO TO THE COMMITTEE.
DR WEBER. COLLEGE EYES DR WEBBER
OKAY IT'S ALL RIGHT- I JUST WANT
TO THANK- WHEN JONES SAWYER AND-
THE SPONSORS OF THE BILL I AM
VERY PROUD CO AUTHOR OF THIS
SPELL. JUNETEENTH AS A PART OF
AMERICAN HISTORY AND JUST LIKE
WE CELEBRATE OTHER THINGS
IMPORTANT THINGS IN AMERICA.
WITH BECAUSE INDEPENDENT HEY
THIS IS CELEBRATING THE
INDEPENDENCE OF THE LASSEN
SLAVES AFRICANS AND THEIR
DESCENDANTS IN THIS COUNTRY AND
SO WE NOW RECOGNIZE ON A FEDERAL
. LEVEL WE NEED THAT WITH A
LEVELIZED. I THANK YOU. LOOK
FORWARD TO THIS PASSING ACT LOOK
FOR THE GOVERNOR'S. THANK YOU
THANK YOU MANY OF. THIS QUESTION
. ALL RIGHT ALSO A STRONG TO
BELIEVE THAT SHOULD MAKE IT A
STATE HOLIDAY- SUPPORTING THE
BILL AND I JUST ASK THAT THE
AUTHORED CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
THE STATEMENTS TO MAKE SURE THAT
THERE ARE OF ANY COMPLICATION IN
WOMEN. THE SOME QUESTIONS YES WE
WILL AND IF WE HAVE A MOTION. OH
I'M SORRY WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
I. BOATS SO WE HAD A THE MOTION
BY DOCTOR RUN BLIND NEED A
SECOND DOCTOR WEBER SECOND.
MA'AM SIR PLEASE CALL. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE MEDINA
HI MEDINA I SAW A- CHOI I
ARAMBULA. ARAMBULA I'D- BLOOM I
GABRIEL IRWIN IRWIN I'D KILEY
KILEY I. LEVINE LEVINE AYE LOW
SANTIAGO. CALAVERAS WEBER WEBER
I. EIGHT EIGHT ZERO THE BILL IS
OUT WILL LEAVE IT OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS THANK YOU KAMALA
VOTE OF FILE ITEM SIXTEEN.
MISTER CAR A. B. TWENTY SIX
TWENTY FOUR.
AGAIN WHEN YOU ARE READY THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MISS CHAIR MEMBERS
AND- SB LAST MY PEER HERE SO
THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER CHAIR
FOR YOUR SERVICE- AND I.
TRANSFER SECONDING THE MOTION ON
THE LAST ONE I DID NOT SERVE ON
THIS COMMITTEE I WAS VERY
EXCITED ABOUT THE BILL. OF AB
TWENTY SIX TWENTY FOUR. WOOD
CLOSING PRICE TRANSPARENCY
COMPARES THE GAPS BY REQUIRING
THE CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITIES IN CALIFORNIA
PRETTY COLLEGES AND ENCOURAGING
THE UNIVERSITY UNIVERSITY
CALIFORNIA DISPLAY ASKED ME TO
COURSE MATERIALS 475% OF COURSES
OFFERED ON THE ONLINE COURSE
SCHEDULE PLATFORM- CURRENT.
FEDERAL HIGHER EDUCATION
OPPORTUNITY THOUSAND EIGHT
REQUIRES CAMPUSES RECEIVING
FEDERAL FUNDS TO DISCLOSE
TAXPAYER COSTS AND SBN NUMBERS
FOR TEXTBOOKS ON THE COURSE
SCHEDULE HOWEVER. IN THE DECADE
SINCE HIGHER EDUCATION. WRITTEN
TYPES MATERIAL STUDENTS ARE
EXPECTED TO PURCHASE HAS WIDENED
TO INCLUDE DIGITAL HOMEWORK
PLATFORMS AND OTHER NEW
TECHNOLOGIES THAT ARE NOT
CAPTURED. ADDITIONALLY COURSE
MATERIAL COSTS MAKE UP A
SIGNIFICANT PORTION OF THE COST
OF SECONDARY EDUCATION
ESPECIALLY AT COMMUNITY
COLLEGES. UNLIKE BEES IN TUITION
COURSE MATERIAL COSTS ARE NOT
FIXED WHICH MAKES IT CHALLENGING
FOR STUDENTS TO PLAN AHEAD.
THESE TYPES ADDITIONAL MATURE.
UP TO BINGO USE AS HAVE KNOWN
AND RECOUP COSTS ON THE COURSE
AS THEY COULD WITH SOME PHYSICAL
MATERIALS SUCH AS RESELLING A
TWENTY SIX TWENTY FOUR HOURS A
SIMPLE MEASURE UNABLE TO. FORM
THE COURT PATIENT IN A MANNER
THAT WORKS BEST FOR THEM
FINANCIALLY. TESTIFYING DAVID
GENGE ATTRACT STUDENTS
SACRAMENTO STATE UNIVERSITY AND
RATHER PATEL A STUDENT AT UCLA
AND CAL BURKE STUDENT CHAPTER
CHAIR. MAY BEGIN GOOD AFTERNOON
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MY NAME IS
DAVE AGAIN SONOMA JUNIOR AT
SACRAMENTO STATE UNIVERSITY I'M
A RECENT ADDITION TO THE HORNET
COMMUNITY HAVING TRANSFERRED
LAST FALL FROM ALLAN HANCOCK
COLLEGE IN SANTA MARIA. MY PLAN
IS TO GRADUATE NEXT SPRING HELLO
SAN JUAN SCHOOL I'M HERE TODAY
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY
SIX TWENTY FOUR TO ENSURE TWO PM
. THAT'S ME. COLLEGE COURSE. IN
FOR. PASSAGE IS THE TIME BUDGET
SAVE REQUIRED MATERIALS WHEN I
REGISTERED FOR CLASSES AT ALLAN
HANCOCK I WAS IMMEDIATELY
INFORMED OF THE COST OF MY
REQUIRED BILLS PUTTING MY
SPANISH TEXTBOOK. VISUAL BOOK
COST ME TWO HUNDRED SIXTY TWO
DOLLARS YES JUST FOR ONE BUT IT
WAS NOT FOR PERMANENT OWNERSHIP
RATHER IT ACTS TO THIRTY ON THE
- LIKE SOME OTHER CALL. STUDENTS
I'M MORE. PAYCHECK TO PAYCHECK
AND DOING MY BEST TO BALANCE MY
EXPENSES HAVING THIS INFORMATION
ADVANCE GAVE ME THE TIME TO WORK
AROUND THE COST RATHER THAN. A
WEEK OR TWO. THE FIRST DAY OF
CLASS AND IN TURN HELP ME MANAGE
MY STRESS WHEN IT CAME TO. THE
LAST THING COLLEGE STUDENT WANTS
TO SEE IS THE UNEXPECTED PRICE
TAG FOR A BOOK OF DEVICE OR
PROGRAMS THEY DIDN'T KNOW THEY
WERE GONNA THAT WE'RE GOING TO
BE NEEDED UNTIL THE ELEVENTH
HOUR. PROVIDING THIS COST
INFORMATION TO AS MANY STUDENTS
AS POSSIBLE. ESPECIALLY WHEN
STUDENTS ARE ALREADY STRUGGLING
TO COVER THE INCREASING BASIC
COSTS. OF HOUSING FOOD AND GAS
IT'S A SMALL BUT IMPACTFUL
MEASURE. STRONG SUPPORT FOR THE
- OF THE OPPORTUNITY HERE. THANK
YOU. THANK GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
MEDINA AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS BROUGHT UP
TO TELL HIM THE UC STUDENT AND
THE CHAPTER CARE APPROPRIATE
STUDENTS AT UCLA RUNS ARE FORTY
TEXTBOOKS CAMPAIGN. CALPERS IS A
PUBLIC INTEREST ADVOCACY GROUP
WITH STUDENT CHAPTERS AT COLLEGE
CAMPUSES ACROSS. I AM PROUD TO
BE HERE TODAY TO SEE AB TWO SIX
TWO FOUR WHICH WILL HELP COLLEGE
STUDENTS LIKE MYSELF BETTER PLAN
FOR OUR ACADEMIC SUCCESS BY
EXPANDING PRICE APPEARED SEE OF
COURSE MATERIALS. COURSE
MATERIALS ARE ONE OF THE LARGEST
OUT OF POCKET EXPENSES STUDENT
SPACE AND ONE OF THE LEAST
PREDICTABLE. ONE SUMMER I HAD TO
SPEND OVER TWO HUNDRED DOLLARS
ON ONE CLASS I DEPEND ON
FINANCIAL AID EVERY QUARTER BUT
- I. CAN SPENT ON MY COURSE
TWENTY. THE CARD. IN RISK LOSING
MONIES MY KNEE AND LIVE EXPENSES
THAT'S WHY IT'S SO IMPORTANT
THAT STUDENTS KNOW HOW MUCH
COURSE. US BEFORE THE REGISTER
FOR CLASS THANKFULLY THE FEDERAL
HIGHER EDUCATION OPPORTUNITY ACT
REQUIRES CAMPUSES RECEIVING
FEDERAL FUNDS TO DISCLOSE TAX
THE COST ON THE SCHEDULE. A LOT
. MY EXPANDED TO INCLUDE DIGITAL
HOMEWORK PLATFORMS AND OTHER
MATERIALS NOT INCLUDED UNDER THE
LAW FOR EXAMPLE ONE QUARTER I
HAD TO SPEND ONE HUNDRED AND
TWENTY FIVE DOLLARS ONLINE
HOMEWORK PLATFORM AB TWO SIX TWO
FOUR CLOSES THIS PRICE
TRANSPARENCY GAP. FOR DISCLOSURE
OF COURSE MATERIALS COSTS ON THE
COURSE SCHEDULE WILL HELP
STUDENTS BETTER PLAN AND BUDGET
FOR EDUCATION. HAVING THIS
INFORMATION AHEAD OF TIME ALSO
HELPS STUDENTS SAVE MONEY ON
SHIPPING COSTS. THE PRICE OF
BOOKS GET MORE EXPENSIVE ONE I
AM INFORMED OF MY COURSE
MATERIALS ONE TO TWO WEEKS
BEFORE CLASSES START BECAUSE THE
COST OF SHIPPING INCREASES THE
FASTER WE NEED THE MATURE BILLS.
BEING ME LAST TIME TO. THESE
THREE NINE. I THOUGHT THANK YOU
THANK YOU. ANY OTHER WITNESSES
AND SOME. OF LIKE TO GO TO THE
MY LOAN. GIVE YOUR NAME
ORGANIZATION EXCUSE ME
ORGANIZATION YOU'RE WITH. HELLO
MY NAME IS KAYLA ENABLE I'M HERE
REPRESENTING THE MICHELSON
CENTER FOR PUBLIC POLICY WERE CO
SPONSORING THIS BILL AND- I HOPE
YOU BUT I. THANK YOU ANY OTHER
WAY IN SUPPORT. CNN ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION WHATEVER
THE MICROPHONE YOU IN OPPOSITION
YOU MAY SIT HERE AT THE TABLE.
NO SIR TWEET TWEET OKAY GOT IT.
WE WILL GO TO TWEENS OIL WITH
THE CSU AND WE DON'T HAVE A
POSITION ON THE BILL BUT WE PLAN
TO KEEP PART WORKING WITH THE
AUTHOR'S OFFICE THANK YOU THANK
YOU OTHER TRAINERS- JOHNSON
PRASAD VICE RESOLUTELY FARES
DISTANCE AT. TWENTY THREE CALL
IS AND WE PLAN TO TAKE- S. SAN.
THANK YOU. QUESTION COMMENTS
FROM THE GOOD. C. NINE I THANK
THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING THE BILL
FORWARD I REMEMBER HOW MUCH
BOOKS CLASS WAY BACK IN THE
SEVENTIES WHEN I WAS GOING TO
SCHOOL AND THEN WHEN I WAS A
INSTRUCTORS WELL. AND SIGN UP IN
THE- WHATEVER WE CAN TO ENSURE
THAT STUDENTS HAVE AN MORE
ACCURATE PICTURE FOR THE TOTAL
COST OF ATTENDANCE I ASKED THE
AUTHOR THAT MOVING FORWARD HE
ADDRESSES THE COMMENTS IN
REGARDS TO THE FEASIBILITY OF
CSU AND UC AND UP AND IN
IMPLEMENTING THESE MEASURES.
WORK WITH. THANK YOU THAT YOU
MAY CLOSE THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
SURE FOR YOU IN YOUR STAFF'S
WORK ON THIS- WE MORE. ONE FIRST
. DISTRICT HOLES CERTAINLY LOOK
FORWARD SINCE AND UC. THANK YOU
HAVE A MOTION. TO GET A MOTION.
SO. MOVED BY DR REVELERS SECOND
BY MR LEVINE AND MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. THE MOTION
IS DUE PASSED TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE MEDINA
HI MEDINA HI CHARLIE CHOI I'D
ARAMBULA ARAMBULA I BLOOM. OKAY
IRWIN IRWIN I KILEY LEVINE
LEVINE I LOW SANTIAGO VALIDUS
VALIDUS I WEBER WEBER HI. SEVEN
ZERO BILL IS OUT WILL LEAVE IT
OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS AND WITH
THAT WE'LL GO TO FILE ITEM
SEVENTEEN. NO I'M SORRY FILE
ITEM EIGHTEEN. AB. TWENTY FOUR
FIFTY SIX. THIS IS THE CORRECT
SOME YEAH YES THANK YOU MISTER-
CHAIRED THIS BILL MAY LOOK
FAMILIAR TO YOU MR LEVINE- USE
THAT TOOK A LOOK AT THIS ISSUE
THREE YEARS AGO. SALAS
IMITATIONS OF FINANCE FOR.
SENSUALLY MISTER MEDINA YOU AND
I'VE BEEN TRYING TO REVAMP AND
REBOOTED EXPAND CAL GRANT AND
FINANCIAL AID IN CALIFORNIA AND
ONE THING WE KNOW IS TOO MANY
STUDENTS- GRADUATE WITH TWO DAD
PART OF THE PROBLEM IS THE CAL.
IT'S.
TAKE TWELVE UNITS WELL TWELVE
UNITS TIMES TWO SEMESTERS TIMES
FOR YEARS IS NINETY SIX UNITS
NOT A HUNDRED TWENTY SO THEY
COME UP SHORT FOR THE LAST YEAR
WHEN THEY'RE TRYING TO FINISH
THEIR RUN OUT OF THEIR CALDERON
ELIGIBILITY. TAKE A LOOK AT IT
SHE SAID THIS AND THANKS TO THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR WORKING WITH
US WE HEARD SOME OF THE FOLKS
CONCERNING ABOUT CHANGE THE
APPLES OF IT IS FAR WHAT MEMORY
MINIMUM- UNITS SHALL BE SO WE
WENT IS A DIFFERENT APPROACH.
HERE THE BACK FUTURE LEVINE WAS
BETTER COUPLE YEARS AGO SO
RUMORED TO BE LOOKING AT THIS
THROUGH LEGISLATION AND THE
BUDGET. DEBATE PLEASE. CLARIFY
AND EXPAND THAT STUDENTS CAN
TAKE CAL GRANT- CAN'T TAKE
COURSES IN THE SUMMER USE THEIR
CAL GRANT. AND NOT LOSE SOME
OTHER STATE FINANCIAL AID
ELIGIBILITY- WE KNOW THAT WHEN
STUDENTS ATTEND ONE MORE YEAR.
BOB I'M I'VE CALLED IT'S OVER.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE COLLEGE
BECAUSE- THE HOUSING COSTS IN
YOUR LOSS OF FOR THE REST OF THE
COST R. C. THEY CAN'T. WONDER
WHY STUDENTS THIS SUMMER. WITH
THAT. THANK YOU YOUR SITUATION
ASK THE RIVAL. WITNESS ANY
WINDOWS IN SUPPORT I GUESS HI I
. COULD CHAIRMAN DINNER AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
NATHAN DIETRICH I AM ASSOCIATE
VICE PRESIDENT FOR PUBLIC
AFFAIRS AT THE AT SIGN STATE I
AM PLEASED TO BE HERE TODAY ON
BEHALF OF SOCCER MOST PRESIDENT
ROBERT NELSEN. AND THE
UNIVERSITY CARE. BEFORE I BEGIN
I WANT TO NOTE THAT THE
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
SYSTEM HAS YET TO TAKE A
POSITION ON THIS BILL BUT IS
SUPPORTIVE. OF THE DIRECTION THE
BILL TAKEN A RECENT CASE.
UPDATED BILL LINE THE CSU'S
MISSION AND REFLECTS THE CSU.
INCREASING ACCESS ENSURING
AFFORDED ME AN IMPROVING TIME
2 DEGREES I EIGHT WEEK ON
APPROVING ACCESS SUMMER. HAS
HELPED INCREASE OUR GRADUATION
RATE IN TWENTY FIFTEEN OUR
GRADUATION RATE FOR FIRST TIME
FRESHMAN CHRIS ONLY EIGHT
PERCENT. IS NOT APPROACHING
THIRTY PERCENT. TAKING CLASSES
IN THE SUMMER ALLOW STUDENTS
STATE TRACK CATCH UP OR GET
AHEAD IN THEIR STUDIES. WE
pWANTED COURAGE. THEY USE A
SUMMER SESSION AND SUPPORT
STUDENTS WHEN THEY- CLASSES.
SUMMER COURSES OVER FIVE HUNDRED
SECTIONS NOW UP FROM OVER THREE
HUNDRED TROUBLE YEARS AGO AND
NOW OVER SIX THOUSAND STUDENTS
TAKING SUMMER SESSION OUR
EXPERIENCE SHOWS THAT THE LESS
BEARS THERE ARE SUPER SESSION
THE MORE STUDENTS WILL GET WE
BELIEVE THIS BILL REDUCES SUCH
BARRIERS AND WE GREATLY
APPRECIATE THIS SUMMER MCCARTY
TAKEN THIS ISSUE ON THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PATIENCE. THERE WOULD.
I'M TO THE MARKER AND- ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. ANY
TWEETERS. TWEETERS. MAY
RODRIGUEZ ON BEHALF EDUCATION
TRUST WEST WHILE WE DO NOT HAVE
AN OFFICIAL POSITION WE
APPRECIATE THE ENGAGE WITH THE
AUTHOR HIS OFFICE OF OFFICIALLY
REMOVED ARE OPPOSED POSITION AND
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
THEM ON THIS BILL FOUR THANK YOU
. MY NAME IS AND THAT IS ALL
THAT I MEAN FOR THEIR POLITICAL
SCIENCE STUDENT AT SACRAMENTO
STATE. I'M IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL BECAUSE IT'LL HELP STUDENTS
LIKE ME GRADUATE DEBT FREE.
THANK YOU. ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
OKAY TO THE OTHER I'LL BE
SUPPORTING THE MEASURE TODAY BUT
ENCOURAGE YOU TO CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH THE COMMITTEE STAFF AN
APPROPRIATE STAKEHOLDER GROUPS
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT THIS
MEASURE DOESN'T COMPETE WITH OUR
OTHER BILL CAL GRANT REFORM BILL
. THANK YOU I'LL KEEP OUR EYES
ON THE PRIZE MISTER CHAIR- CAL
GRANT REFORM DEBT FREE COLLEGE
IN CALIFORNIA. IS OUR QUEST AND
WE WILL GET THERE THIS IS A
PIECE OF THE PUZZLE. THANK YOU
THANK YOU WITH THE ARRIVAL. OF
THE MOTION. I NEED A MOTION
SECOND. OKAY SO FIRST FIRST FIVE
MR LEVINE SECOND BY DOCTOR CHOI
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. THE QUESTION IS DO YOU
PASS TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE MEDINA HI MEDINA I'D
CHOI. CHOICE I'D ARAMBULA BLOOM
GABRIEL IRWIN IRWIN I KILEY
LEVINE LEVINE I LOW SANTIAGO
BALLADARES VALLADARES I WEBER.
WEBER I'D. OR CALL SIX ZERO BILL
IS ON CAR WILL LEAVE IT OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS AS WELL. AND NOT
SEEING ANY OTHER AUTHORS HERE.
I'M SORRY. NINETEEN FILE ITEM
NINETEEN TWENTY SIX FIFTY TWO.
YES YOU MISTER- SHARE AT THIS
BILL IS ABOUT FOOD FINANCIAL
ASSISTANCE FOR STUDENTS IN
CALIFORNIA REGARDLESS OF THEIR
IMMIGRATION STATUS WE KNOW THAT-
THE OF COLLEGES ALWAYS- TUITION
ITS BOOKS FOOD HOUSE. AND TO
MEET OUR STUDENTS UNFORTUNATELY
OUR FOOD IS HERE WE HAD POLICIES
IN CALIFORNIA TO HELP OUR
MEMBERS. RELATED TO WHAT. SLIP
THROUGH THE CRACKS AT FOOD HOW
FRESH PROGRAMS- SO WITH THIS
THIS WOULD STEP UP AND CREATE A
STATE- PILOT PROJECT WELL WHO
COMPLETE THEY THE DREAM ACT
APPLICATION WHO ARE UNDOCUMENTED
MAY BE A POSSIBLE FOUR EIGHT MR
FINANCIAL AID- EFFORT TO COVER
FOOD. PUTTING THEM OUR WITH
THEIR COUNTERPARTS BECAUSE
THEY'RE IN THE SAME CLASSROOM
THEY GET THE SAME AID FOR
FINANCIAL AID THEY GET THE SAME
OTHER BENEFITS BUT FOR THIS ONE
THEY'RE NOT ABLE TO- HAVE THE
SAME OPPORTUNITY SO. I WITH THAT
ASK THE RIGHT THING. WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT YES GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS ALEX TO GO ON WITH THE
STUDENT AID COMMISSION. A TWENTY
SIX FIFTY WOULD ESTABLISH A
STATE FUNDED FOOD SUPPORT PILOT
PROGRAM FOR STUDENTS WHO
COMPLETE THE CALIFORNIA DREAM
APP APPLICATION OR QUEDA. ALLOW
THE STATE TO LEVERAGE EXISTING
INFRASTRUCTURE TO PROVIDE AND
DOCUMENT STUDENTS WITH AN
OPPORTUNITY TO OFFSET STUDENTS
SECURITY EXPERIENCE WITH
STREAMLINED APPROACH. COLLEGE
AFFORDABILITY MEANS MORE. JUST A
- STUDENTS SHOULD BUT THEY'RE
BASED NEEDS. A RECENT REPORT ON
STUDENT EXPENSES AND- STUDENT
RESOURCE SURVEY THIS YEAR PORT
ONE THREE COLLEGE STUDENTS
REPORTED EXPERIENCING FOOD
INSECURITY. MONGKOK SOON AND
EXHAUST BY THE ONSET OF THE
PANDEMIC AS UNDERSCORED IN THE
COMMISSION SUMMER TWENTY TWENTY
ONE COLBERT NINETEEN SURVEY- OR
INTENSE EXPERIENCE AN AVERAGE OF
53% AND WEEKLY AN INCREASE OF
53% IN THEIR FOOD EXT. WE HAVE
TO. ALL ACCESS CAL THESE
UNDOCUMENTED STUDENTS ARE ABLE
THE EXISTING PROGRAM HOWEVER
IT'S PRESENTED IN THE
COMMISSION'S LATEST REPORT
BRENDA AND SUE POPULATION ACCESS
THESE. I'M BY THE FEDERAL
FEDERAL RULES PROHIBIT- FROM
ACCESSING. CURRENTLY THERE IS AN
ESTIMATED SEVENTY TO NINETY
THOUSAND UNDOCUMENTED STUDENTS
IN CALIFORNIA THEY'RE EXCLUDED
FROM THE PROGRAM AS CALIFORNIA
CONSIDERS ENDING THE FEDERAL
PROGRAM AND BRING SUPPORT TO-
IMMIGRANT AND DOCUMENT IS THIS
APPROACH WOULD REPRESENT A MEANS
OF DOING SO WITHOUT REPLICATING
THE BARRIERS AND ASH. TWENTY SIX
FIFTY TWO IS CRITICAL TO
ENSURING SECURITY FOR MOST
VULNERABLE ON BEHALF OF THE SUNY
COMMISSION WE THINK MR MCCARTY
AFTER I. THANK YOU OF A GET
AFTERNOON COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY
NAME IS SHAHZEB PRASAD VICE FOR
THE LEGISLATIVE AFFAIRS INSIDE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNICATE IS THAT
ACTUAL VOICE FOR OVER ONE POINT
EIGHT MILLION. STUDENTS I LIKE
TO THINK ASSEMBLY. IN ON A LOT
OF SLATED TO THAT ACCIDENTS
EDUCATIONAL- CALIFORNIA IS HOME
TO AN ESTIMATED TWO POINT FIVE
MILLION UNDOCUMENTED STUDENTS
ANDIF THEY PROVIDE BACK TO THE
U. S. ECONOMY AFTER PURSUING
THEIR EDUCATION MEIST OFTEN.
COMMUNITY COLLEGE HOWEVER DOCKET
STUDENTS ARE STILL EXPECT
EXPLICITLY DENIED ACCESS TO
FEDERAL BENEFITS AND I WAS OUT
AND I WERE HERE LAST WEEK DURING
THE FIVE HOUR MEETING- WE WERE
IMMENSE YEAH TWENTY EIGHT AND
WHICH WAS AND- FRESH BILL AND
SOME. ALL I KNOW WHAT. HI AND
DARK STUDENTS AND LOT OF
STUDENTS IN THE COMMUNICATOR
SYSTEM ARE FROM THE UNDER
REPRESENTED MINORITY LOWER
INCOME BACKGROUND ON OFTENTIMES
NONTRADITIONAL IT IS IMPORTANT
THAT WE PROVIDE ACCESS TO THE
STUDENT GEN BUT THE Q. COLLAR
SYSTEM CONTINUES TO BE EQUITABLE
AND ALLOW A PATHWAY TO. STUDENTS
AND FOR TO A HIGHER EDUCATION
SYSTEM WHEN MY DAD IMMIGRATED
FROM THE FIJI ISLANDS INTO
AMERICA HE WANTED TO PURSUE THE
AMERICAN DREAM AND ENSURE THAT
HE COULD IN TURN EDUCATE AND IF
IT. GET A PROVIDE. ME AS-
COMPANY NOT KNOWING WHAT'S
HAPPENING IN AMERICA AS WELL AS
- HAVING THE RESOURCES TO
CONTINUE HIS EDUCATION HOWEVER-
I AM A FIRST GENERATION COMMUNE
COLLEGE STUDENTS AND WORKING
HARD TO ACHIEVE THE AMERICAN
DREAM ON BEHALF OF MY DAD AND SO
MANY OTHERS IN MY FAMILY WHO
HAVE IMMIGRATED FROM EITHER
MAKES. AND IT'S FOUR IN. REMOTE
BILITY TO THE STUDENTS SO THEY
CAN CONTINUE THEIR EDUCATIONAL
PATHWAY AND I RESPECTFULLY URGE
THE COMMITTEE TO V<c.cyan> THANK YOU</c>
THANK YOU ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT. COME TO THE MICROPHONE. HEY GOOD AFTERNOON KITCHENER
LONDON ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA UNDOCUMENTED HIGHER
EDUCATION COALITION IN STRONG
SUPPORTER OF AB TWO SIX FIVE TWO
THANK YOU THANK YOU ARE THERE
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION AB
TWENTY SIX FIFTY TWO. ANY
CLEANERS AB. TWENTY SIX FIFTY
TWO NINE QUESTIONS COMMENTS BY
THE- COMMITTEE. THAT'S WHY THIS
. YEAH SO I JUST HAVE- THE
LITTLE THE SIMPLE QUESTION HOW
DID WE COME TO THE DOLLAR
AMOUNTS WHICH IS. WHICH IN MY
UNDERSTANDING TWENTY EIGHT
HUNDRED. AND IS IT WOULD BE AN
EIGHT DOLLARS EIGHT EIGHT EIGHT-
THAT PUTS US IN A LITTLE BEHIND
THAT MAKE SOME EQUITABLE THE
CALIBRATION ON ANNUAL BASIS- SO
IT WAS TWO HUNDRED THIRTY FOUR
DOLLARS A MONTH STUDENTS DO WANT
TO EAT EVERY MONTH OF THE YEAR
AND THE WAY YEAH. I AND SO
TWELVE MONTHS VERS RIGHT LOOK AT
THEM THAT'S THE INTENT OKAY. DR
WEBER. SO ACTUALLY HAPPENING
BANG. AS THAT WAS THE GOAL. YEAH
IS A LITTLE BIT LESS THINK OF.
OKAY I'M. HOW ARE WE LIKE GOING
TO ULTIMATELYBUDGET FOR IT
BECAUSE IF YOU'RE ASSUMING THAT
WE HAVE ABOUT NINETY MILLION THE
FOR FIRST YEAR WHAT IF WE HAVE
LIKE STUDENTS THE NEXT YEAR IS
GONNA HAVE TO COME BACK THE
LEGISLATIVE EACH TIME.
HOW YEAH WELL LIKE A LOT OF
BILLS IN THIS KEEPING ALL OF OUR
BILLS- THE GOVERNOR USERS ALIKE
MONEY IN THE- HE DID AND IF
THERE WAS A RACIST- IT WOULD BE
A PROGRAM WHICH SHOULD BE
ADJUSTED EVERY YEAR BASED UPON.
IT'S AN ESTIMATE BY HOW MANY
STUDENTS ARE ELIGIBLE- YEAR TO
YEAR WE KIND OF KNOW WHAT IT
WOULD BE- YOU KNOW BUT I GUESS
THE BIG. AS WE ARE CONCURRENTLY
BE BOUGHT THIS WITH INTERPLAY.
WITH THE STATE BUDGET ALLOCATION
. OKAY SO THERE'S NO CONCERN OF
GOING OVER REALLY WELL THERE IS
I THINK WE HAVE TO FIND THIS
AND- I THINK THE BIG PICTURE
HERE IS THAT. AB K. PROGRAM. SO
MANY BARRIERS WHICH EXCLUDE
COLLEGE STUDENTS AND IT'S IS
SHOULDN'T BE THAT COMPLICATED
ELIGIBLE BASED UPON YOUR INCOME
MANY TIMES AND THEN YOU'RE
ACCOSTED ON THE CITY YOU CAN
JUMP THROUGH ALL THESE HOOPS AND
SO. EIGHT A LOT BILLS. CALFRESH
TYPE BENEFITS FOR OUR STUDENTS-
IN PERFECT WORLD WE WOULD L.
BEGET DRAWDOWN FEDERAL MONEY FOR
CONFERENCE THIS IS A POPULATION
THAT'S EXCLUDED BECAUSE OF THEIR
IMMIGRATION STATUS OF COPS. SO
THIS IS ONE OF THE CITY
COMMISSION WORKGROUP IDEAS TO
TRY TO- SIGN. FOR COLLEGE
STUDENTS WELCOME BACK TO
LEGISLATIVE BODY EVERY YEAR IN
THE BUDGETARY ACT. CORRECT OKAY
AND THEN IS THE FOOD IS THE
MONEY SPECIFIC FOR FOOD OR WHAT
IT COULD BE USED FOR ANYTHING
OUT WHAT THE AMENDMENT- I TWO
IT. YES MADE ON. THIS TO- CHECK
TO SEE HOW THEY DID USE THEM-
USING THE EBT PROCESS IS
EXTREMELY COST PROHIBITIVE- SO
THERE ISN'T LIKE SAME KIND OF
FOOD SERVICE CARD. I'M THAT
MISTER INSTITUTION AND THEY WILL
MONITOR THAT AND THEN AFTER TWO
YEARS THEY WILL CHECK BACK IN.
HOW WE CAN GO BACK. HM HOUSE UP
. EVEN THOUGH THIS IS
SPECIFICALLY OR WERE THINKING
THAT THIS IS GOING TO GO FOR
FOOD THEY MAY NOT NECESSARILY
USE DIFFERENT THAT. I HAVE TO
USE IT FOR THAT I. THEY WILL NOT
BE BILLED THERE WILL BE NO
PROHIBITION I MEAN THERE WILL BE
NO RESTRICTIONS ON THE CARD IN
THERE WILL. IT WILL BE. WHEN I
WAS A CHILD. SAM SMITH TOWN AND
THAT COUNTIES FOR FOOD SO THERE
WOULDN'T BE ANYTHING LIKE THAT
BECAUSE THAT IS NOT. SOMETHING
WE HAVE AT. STAKE GEN. THANK YOU
. THANK YOU- I WANT TO THANK THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FOR WORKING WITH
COMMITTEE STAFF. THE NEW YORK
MEN'S PROVIDE ADDITIONAL BAD
BENEFITS TO AB FIVE FOUR EIGHT
STUDENTS WHO CURRENTLY DON'T
HAVE ACCESS TO STATE FRONT RUN
FOOD PROGRAMS AB. DE TO
REPRESENT. SYSTEM THAT OVERLOOKS
A GROUP OF STUDENTS WHO NEED
NUTRITIONAL SUPPORT HAPPY TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL DO WE HAVE A
MOTION I GET A- MOVED BY. MISS
IRWIN SECONDS ACT BUT MR LEVINE.
AND MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AS AMENDED TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE MEDINA HI MEDINA I
CHOI. CHARLIE NOT VOTING
ARAMBULA BLOOM GABRIEL IRWIN.
IRWIN I KILEY LEVINE LEVINE I
LOW SANTIAGO BALLADARES NO THERE
IS NOT VOTING WEBER. WEBER AVE.
FOUR ZERO THE BILL'S ON CALL
THANK YOU AND NOW WE'LL GO TO
FILE ITEM TWENTY FIVE AB TWENTY
SIX SIXTY SIX MISTER SOPS. THANK
YOU MR CHAIRMAN BURZUM FIRE
PROUD TO PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY SIX SIXTY SIX WHICH
ESTABLISHES A GRANT PROGRAM. TO
ESTIMATES. PLEADING LIGHT
SHOWERS WOULD NOT PAY ACCORDING
TO THE CALIFORNIA FUTURE HEALTH
WORKFORCE COMMISSION JUST ONE
THIRD OF CALIFORNIANS WHO LIVE
WITH A MENTAL ILLNESS RECEIVE
THE CARE THEY NEED DUE TO
SHORTAGE. OF BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
CARE WORKERS OKAY TO OF CAL
FIFTY SIX CAP MENTAL HEALTH
PLANS MEET ACCESS REQUIRE.
ENDEMIC AND HAS NOW WORSENED AB
TWENTY SIX SIXTY SIX ONE PREVENT
OIL TREATMENT ACTS IN CALIFORNIA
HELP THOSE PROFESSIONALS THAT
ARE STRUGGLING TO FINISH THEIR
EDUCATION BEGIN. THE WORK OF
HEALING OUR COMMUNITIES I WITH
ME TO TESTIFY TODAY IS- JENNIFER
ALLEY WITH THE OFTEN USES.
MARRIAGE AND FAMILY THERAPISTS.
WELCOME I'M GOOD AFTERNOON I'M
JENNIFER ALLEY WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
MARRIAGE AND FAMILY THERAPIST
REPRESENT THIRTY FOUR THOUSAND-
M. F. T.'S IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND WE'RE VERY
PLEASED TO SUPPORT THIS BILL.
AFTER JURORS TO COMPLY YOUR
MASTER'S DEGREE IN ONE SET
COMPLETE- REGISTER WITH THE
BOARD OF BEHAVIORAL SCIENCES AND
THEN COMPLETE THREE THOUSAND
HOURS. CLINIC EXPERIENCE PRIOR
TO TAKING YOUR FINAL LICENSING
EXAM- THE THREE THOUSAND
CLINICAL HOURS- MAYBE IN AN
UNPAID INTERNSHIP AT THE SAME
TIME THAT THEIR- STUDENT LOANS
AREN'T IN OUR DO OF FOR
REPAYMENT SIX MONTHS AFTER
GRADUATION SO ANY. INSTEAD CAN
BE AFFORDED TO MEN A FEW.
SINCE LONG TERM TO THE RESIDENTS
IN THE STATE THANK YOU THANK YOU
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
REP REBECCA GONZALES WITH THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS CALIFORNIA CHAPTER DID
ASK ME TO MENTION THEIR SUPPORT
HER APOLOGIES FOR NOT BEING ABLE
TO IT. THANK YOU. ANYWAY IS IN
OPPOSITE. ANY TWEETERS.
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. J. NINE- TO SUPPORT
THIS MEASURE TODAY HOWEVER I
ENCOURAGE YOU TO WORK WITH YOUR
COLLEAGUES HAVE SIMILAR MEASURES
ADDRESS ISSUE AS WELL AS THE
CHAIRMAN OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE ACT SENATOR MADE.
ENTITY TO ADMIT THEY ARE ALSO
ENCOURAGED TO ADDRESS POLICY
CONCERNS IS OUT AND ON THREE AND
FOUR MILLION OUNCES IF YOU'D
LIKE TO CLOSE I THINK IT WAS WE
WILL- CALL THAT INTO
CONSIDERATION DO YOU TO MOVE IT
RIGHT. K. AT THIS WELL WITH
COLLEGE TO SEE IF WE CAN- JUST
ENJOYING AUTHOR OTHER'S OFFENSE
SIMILAR. TO PRECIADO WRIST ASK
LIVE UP THANK YOU IF I HAVE A
MOTION. THE MOVE. WELL BY DR
CHOI SECOND BY SO THEY WILL
VALID THE MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
THE ROLL THE MOTION IS TO PASS
TO THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
MEDINA HI MEDINA I CHOI CHOICE I
ARAMBULA BLOOM. GABRIEL GABRIEL
I- IRWIN I KILEY LEVINE LOW
SANTIAGO VALLADARES. NOW THERE
IS I WEBER WEBER I. SIX ZERO
BILL IS ON CALL. AND NOT SEEN
ANY OTHER AUTHORS- YOU BOOK. YOU
TO GO. OKAY MISTER WHEN YOU'RE
PRESENTING FOR BERMAN MR BERMAN
. TAKE OFF. SO THAT IS FILE ITEM
FIVE YEAH YEP FILE ITEM FIVE AB
TWENTY SIX NINETY FIVE. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR THE DEMAND FOR
CYBERSECURITY WORKERS IS GROWING
FAR FASTER THAN THE SUPPLY
DRIVEN BY AN INCREASING NUMBER
OF CYBER IT'S WORTH OF ATTACK.
CALIFORNIA AND THE COUNTRY
RESEARCH WORKFORCE SHORTAGE WITH
OVER SIXTY THREE THOUSAND OPEN
POSITIONS IN THE STATE AND OVER
FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND CYBER
SECURITY- OPENINGS ACROSS THE
COUNTRY ADDRESSING THIS CRITICAL
CYBERSECURITY WORKFORCE GAP IS
ESSENTIAL TO BE PREPARED FOR THE
CURRENT TO MEET THE CURRENT AND
FUTURE SITE THREATEN THE-
CYBERTHREAT- FORTY. CAL SIDE
SECURE WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT AND
EDUCATION STRATEGY REPORT WE
NEED A COORDINATED AND LINKS
EDUCATION TRAINING A WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT PROGRAM. TWENTY
THREE STATEWIDE CYBERSECURITY
CAPABILITIES AND ENHANCEDCYBER
RESILIENCY TO ADDRESS THE URGENT
CYBERSECURITY WORKFORCE GAP AB
TWENTY SIX NINETY FIVE WHAT
ENTRUSTED. CALIFORNIA'S UNIVERSE
BE WITH ESTABLISHING THE CYBER
SECURITY REGIONAL ALLIANCES AND
MULTI. STAKEHOLDER PARTNERSHIPS
PILOT PROGRAM THE GOAL OF THIS
PILOT PROGRAM IS TO INCREASE THE
PIPELINE OF STUDENTS PURSUING
CYBERSECURITY CAREERS AND
DEVELOP THE CYBERSECURITY
WORKFORCE TO MEET INDUSTRY. GOOD
AFTERNOON TURN MEMBERS MY NAME
IS SELECTING A WITH THE SILICON
VALLEY LEADERSHIP GROUP WE ARE
PROUD TO SUPPORT AB TWENTY SIX
NINETY FIVE TO HELP GROW AND
DIVERSIFY CALIFORNIA'S CURRENTLY
UNDERSTAFFED CYBERSECURITY
WORKFORCE. FIVE THIRTY IS A
GROWING AREA OF IMPORTANCE FOR
CALIFORNIA CONSUMERS AND
RESIDENTS THE RISING NUMBER OF
CYBERATTACKS GAINST BOTH THE
PUBLIC AND PRIVATE SECTORS
IMPERILLED FINANCIAL. PEOPLE
EDUCATIONAL AND HEALTH
INDUSTRIES ALL WHILE THREATENING
THE SECURITY OF OUR CITIZENS
MOST PRIVATE INFORMATION. THE
LEADERSHIP GROUP INTO THE
ETHICALLY SUPPORTS THE CREATION
OF THIS PILOT PROGRAM TO ALIGN
MULTIPLE UNIVERSITIES AND
INDUSTRY PLAYERS AROUND A NEW
CYBERSECURITY ECOSYSTEM. AND
pFOR YOUR SUPPORT AB TWENTY SIX
NINETY FIVE. THANK YOU ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. OF AB.
TWENTY SIX NINETY FIVE. CAN COME
FORWARD TO THE MICROPHONE. BE
ANY TALKING WITH TECHNET IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK
YOU ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. ANY TWEETERS. QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
SECOND I THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING THE BILL FORWARD WE HAD
A MOTION BY MISS WELL THAT IS
SECOND BY. MISTER GATE MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE MEDINA
HI MEDINA I CHOI CHOI I ARAMBULA
BLOOM GABRIEL GABRIEL I IRWIN
IRWIN I KILEY LEVINE LOW
SANTIAGO. VALLADARES GALLAGHER I
WEBER WEBER HI. SIX ZERO THE
BILL IS ON CALL. ALL RIGHT
SHOULD A DEMEANOR OF. OKAY THIS
MAY BE THE LAST BILL ITEM NUMBER
TWENTY AB TWENTY EIGHT TONY
CHAIRMAN MEDINA. WHEN. THANK YOU
MISTER AND MEMBERS TODAY I
PRESENT A. B. TWENTY EIGHT
TWENTY. AB TWENTY EIGHT TWENTY
WOULD ELIMINATE THE CALIFORNIA
ONLINE COMMUNITY COLLEGE CALL
BRIGHT AND REINVEST THE FUNDS.
NEEDED COMMUNITY CALL.
CALIFORNIA ONLINE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE WAS CREATED THROUGH THE
TWENTY EIGHTEEN BUDGET ACT TO
SERVE WORKING ADULTS WITH NO
POST SECONDARY CREDENTIALS TO
SHORT TERM ONLINE PROGRAMS
LINKED TO INDUSTRY NEEDS.
CALIBRATE HASN'T ROLLED ONE
THOUSAND STUDENTS BUT ONLY
EIGHTY HAVE COMPLETED A
CERTIFICATE PROGRAM. CALIBRATE
ALSO REPORTED THAT FIVE HUNDRED
AND FIFTY SEVEN STUDENTS HAVE
WITHDRAWN FROM THE VARIOUS
PROGRAMS SINCE THE COLLEGE WENT
LIVE IN TWENTY NINETEEN. AFTER
SPENDING MORE THAN A HUNDRED AND
FORTY MILLION DOLLARS TO LAUNCH
COBB RIGHT COLLEGE THE SCHOOL
REMAINS UNCREDITED AND HAS
FAILED TO REACH THE ENROLLMENT
GOALS AND OTHER BENCHMARKS. IN
OCTOBER OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE
CALIBRATE REPORTED OVER 60% OF
ITS NEW ENROLLEES DROPPING OUT.
WITH ONLY A HUNDRED AND TWENTY
NINE AND ROWLEY'S AND SEVENTY
NINE WITHDRAW WITHDRAWALS FOR
THE CURRENT FISCAL YEAR. TOTAL
ENROLLMENT REMAINS AT FIVE
HUNDRED AND EIGHTEEN EVEN WHEN
THE STATE AUDITOR'S FINDINGS
THAT IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE THE
FIFTEEN MILLION ONGOING ANNUAL
FUNDS PAY FOR ONLY FIVE
INSTRUCTORS. EXISTING COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISTRICTS HAVE PROVEN
THEMSELVES ABLE TO QUICKLY
RESPOND AND ADAPT TO COVERT
NINETEEN PANDEMIC BY BY
PROVIDING. ALMOST ALL OTHER
COURSES ONLINE. THROUGHOUT THIS
PANDEMIC THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
SYSTEM HAS BEEN ABLE TO BUILD ON
EXISTING ONLINE INFRASTRUCTURE
AND EXPAND VIRTUAL RESOURCES TO
HELP MEET THE VERY NEEDS OF THE
OVER TWO POINT ONE MILLION
STUDENTS ATTENDING A HUNDRED AND
FIFTEEN COMMUNITY COLLEGE. THIS
SESSION I HAVE MET WITH THE
EXECUTIVE TEAM ITS CALIBER RIGHT
AND I AM IMPRESSED BY THE RECENT
WORK TO EXPAND PARTNERSHIPS WITH
OTHER UNIVERSITIES AND BUILD ON
THEIR EXISTING PROGRAMS.
MOREOVER I UNDERSTAND THAT MORE
STUDENTS IN THE PAST SIX MONTHS
ARE COMPLETING THEIR PROGRAMS
BUT EVEN SO. I REMAIN
QUESTIONING I HAVE REMAINING
QUESTIONS AROUND THE TRUTH
FISCAL CLASS NEEDED TO MAINTAIN
THE COLLEGE AND I'M STILL
CONCERNED BY THE LACK OF DATA ON
THEIR ON JOB PLACEMENT. I AM
LOOKING FORWARD TO ONGOING
CONVERSATIONS WITH CALIBRATE BUT
AT THIS POINT WE NEED MORE
EVIDENCE THAT THE COLLEGE IS
REALLY WORTH THE COST WHEN IT
TAKES. FROM UNIT JUST. B. TWENTY
EIGHT TWENTY WOULD REDIRECT THE
FUNDS CURRENTLY INVESTED IN CAL
BRIGHT AND WOULD GO TO THE BASIC
NEEDS CENTER STUDENT HOUSING FOR
COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS AND
THE STATE FINANCIAL AID FOR
COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS. ON
BEHALF OF AB TWENTY EIGHT TWENTY
I HAVE WENDY. WORLD WHEN CUT
PRESIDENT OF THE FACULTY
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGE AND MICHAEL
YOUNG LEGISLATIVE ADVOCATE FOR
THE CALIFORNIA FEDERATION OF
TEACHERS. THANK YOU MEMBERS
MICHAEL YOUNG WITH THE
CALIFORNIA FEDERATION OF
TEACHERS ONE OF THE CO SPONSORS
OF AB TWENTY EIGHT TWENTY I
REALLY CAN'T SAY IT BETTER THAN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MEDINA ALREADY
HAS- WE DO BELIEVE THAT- THE
PROGRAM OFFERINGS THAT PROVIDE
ABOUT COBB RIGHT ARE DUPLICATIVE
OF PROGRAMS THAT CAN BE A
PROVIDED IN OUR PROVIDED THROUGH
OUR COMMUNITY COLLEGE SYSTEM
CURRENTLY. WE BELIEVE THAT THE
FUNDING THAT'S ALLOCATED TOWARDS
CALIBRATE PRESENTLY COULD BE
BETTER SERVED BEING FUNNELED
THROUGH THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
SYSTEM TO SERVE OUR STUDENTS-
AND LASTLY IT WE JUST BELIEVE
THAT THIS PROGRAM HAS FAILED TO
MEET THE BENCHMARKS IN THE GOALS
THAT IT WAS. STATED SAID TO TRY
S. N. GIVEN THE ORDER FROM LAST
YEAR AND THE LOWER AND- HE- A
LACK OF CONNECTION WITH.
INDIVIDUALS GOING THROUGH THE
PROGRAM BEING CONNECTED TO GOOD
HIGH PAYING JOBS THIS JUST
DOESN'T SEEM TO BE AN ADEQUATE
USE OF THE RESOURCES LIMITED
RESOURCE SPEARHEADING CAL. AND
THESE RESOURCES WE BETTER SERVE
BEING- GOING THROUGH THE-
COMMUNITY COLLEGE SYSTEM. THE
DURING THE CALL THE NINETEEN
PANDEMIC WE SHOWN THAT A
COMMUNITY COLLEGES CAN GROW AND
EXPAND THEIR OWN OFFERINGS AND
REACH OUT TO STUDENTS IN.
VARIOUS WALKS OF LIFE. HE
BETWEEN TWENTY EIGHT AND THINK
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FOR BRINGING BILL
. THE YOU. THANKS OKAY I'M GOOD
EVENING MY NAME IS WENDY
BURROWING COOPER I'M THE
PRESIDENT OF THE FACULTY
ASSOCIATION OF THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES ARE PROUD CO
SPONSOR OF AB TWENTY EIGHT
TWENTY THE FACULTY HAVE HAD
CONCERNS ABOUT CALIBRATE SINCE
ITS INCEPTION WE REMAIN DEEPLY
OPPOSED AS CALIBRATE CONTINUES
TO FAIL TO MEET ITS PROMISES IN
LATE FEBRUARY REPORTED AN ACTIVE
ENROLLMENT OF JUST OVER ONE
THOUSAND STUDENTS. MOST S. TAGS
TWO MILLION IS FOR EACH OF THE
SEVENTY TOTAL CERTIFICATE
COMPLETIONS AND WITH ONE STUDENT
RECEIVING EMPLOYMENT PLACEMENT
WITH ONLY 15% OF CALIBRATED
PLOYS BEING FULL TIME FACULTY
CALIBRATES CLEARLY IN VIOLATION
OF THE 50% OFF. EVEN FOR
CALIBRATE COMPETENCY BASED NON
CREDIT PROGRAMS THAT AWARD
COMPLETION WITH DIGITAL BADGES
WERE ALREADY BEING OFFERED AT
THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGES. EXISTING LAW REQUIRES
CALIBRATE TO NOT DUPLICATE
PROGRAMS HOWEVER THREE OF THEIR
FOUR GRAMS ALREADY OFFERED IN
OTHER DISTRICTS. WITH THE NEED
TO MOVE PROGRAMS ONLINE DUE TO
COVE IT AND WITH THE NEW WITH
NEWT- TECHNOLOGY INVESTMENTS
DISTRICTS ARE OFFERING BUT THEIR
PROGRAMS ONLINE INCLUDING
COMPETENCY BASED THIS. IN TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN FACT STATE
WERE BETTER WAY OUT YOU PREACH
PRESSURE RESPONSES THAN DECREE A
NEW BECAUSE- OF THOSE. TO THE
BIG NEEDS OF OUR- RECOGNIZE THAT
CAL HAS EMPLOYED SKILLED FACULTY
WHO ARE IT'S AN ASSET TO OUR
STUDENTS WE RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
THAT THE FACULTY POSITIONS OF
CALIBRATE BE ABSORBED INTO OTHER
DISTRICTS THANK YOU. THANK YOU-
BEFORE WE GO TO OR THE
SUPPORTERS IN THE ROOM- LET ME
SEE IF THERE'S ANY MAJOR
OPPOSITION WITNESSES. OKAY IF
NOT THE IN THE HEARING ROOM OF
THOSE WHO ARE US IN SUPPORT OF
THAT THE YOU CAN LINE UP WITH
THE MICROPHONE AND THE STATE
YOUR- PATTERN AND THE YOUR
POSITION. THANK YOU DAVID
HAWKINS OF THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGE INDEPENDENCE-
WE ARE ALSO A CO SPONSOR AND
SUPPORT THE BILL THANK YOU. ID
ONE OF THE.
GOOD AFTERNOON OR EARLY EVENING
AND GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN
ENOUGH I SURE CHOI AND MEMBERS
OF THE ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON
HIGHER EDUCATION I AM JOINED
TODAY BY CALIBRATES BOARD OF
TRUSTEE PRESIENT PAMELA HAINES
WILL ALSO DELIVER TEST.
CONSERVATIVE SEWER SERVES AS THE
PRESIDENT OF OUR ACADEMIC SENATE
WILL SPEAK DURING PUBLIC COMMENT
HEY ARE YOU. IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSE OPPOSITION. I'M SORRY
OPPOSITION OPPOSITE THE YEAH YOU
YOU CAN COME OVER HERE. YEAH
MAKE A PRESENTATION I GAVE YOU A
CHANCE WHY LOCAL. GOOD AFTERNOON
SURE MEDINA VICE CHAIR CHOI AND
MEMBERS OF THE ASSEMBLY HIGHER
EDUCATION ASSEMBLY COMEDIAN AT
HIGHER EDUCATION I'M JOINED
TODAY BY CALPERS BOARD OF
TRUSTEES PRESIDENT PAMELA HAINES
WILL ALSO DELIVER TESTIMONY AND
MICHAEL STEWART. WHO SERVES AS
THE PRESIDENT OF OUR ACADEMIC
SENATE WILL SPEAK DURING PUBLIC
COMMENT. THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY WITH YOU WE HAD
HELP. LASER FOCUSED ON BUILDING
THIS NEW COLLEGE FROM THE GROUND
UP. HI WE HAVE GROWN ENROLLMENT
BY HUNDRED AND 10% LAUNCH OUR
SALESFORCE ADMINISTRATION
PROGRAM TO THE PUBLIC AND ARE
NOW DEVELOPING. A LICENSE
OCCASIONAL NURSING TRAINING
PROGRAM IN PARTNERSHIP WITH SEIU
UNITED HEALTHCARE WORKERS. WE'VE
ALSO WELCOME CSEA AS ARE
CLASSIFIED LABOR PARTNER AND CTA
AS OUR FACULTY UNION AND PLAN TO
ORDER HUNDRED CERTIFICATE OF
COMPETENCY IN THE WEEKS AHEAD.
FURTHER WE TAKEN TO HEART AND
ACCEPTED EACH OF THE IMPORTANT
RECOMMENDATIONS MADE BY THE
STATE AUDITOR LAST SPRING. AND
WE ARE ON TRACK TO THE- BILL ON
THEIR FIRST. CALVET IS LESS THAN
HALFWAY THROUGH IT STARTED
PERIOD AND WE OPENED FOR
ENROLLMENT ONLY A SHORT TIME
BEFORE THE PANDEMIC BEGAN. WE
HAVE MET EVERY MILESTONE
OUTLINED IN FOUNDING LEGISLATION
WE ARE TWO YEARS AHEAD OF
SCHEDULE ON ACCREDITATION WE ARE
GUIDED BY A BOARD APPROVED
STRATEGIC VISION WHICH LAYS OUT
AN AGGRESSIVE BUT ACHIEVABLE SET
OF GOALS AND A CLEAR PATH
FORWARD THROUGH THE END OF
TWENTY TWENTY THREE AND BEYOND.
CRITICALLY OUR STUDENT BODY
REFLECTS THAT MISSION 92% OF OUR
LEARNERS ARE AT LEAST TWENTY
FIVE YEARS OLD WHICH IS MORE
THAN DOUBLE THE SAYS. RIGHT 34%
OR PARENTS OR CAREGIVERS AND
MORE THAN TRIPLE A SYSTEM WIDE
RATE 24% IDENTIFIES BLACK THIRTY
THREE CENTS LET NEXT 19% IS
EIGHT. THIS POP LEARNERS IS
RARELY THE BENEFICIARY OF
FOCUSED DATED. DRIVEN DESIGN AND
RESEARCH. THERE SIX. ACROSS THE
CAL COMMUNITY COLLEGE. THAT CAN
GENERATE FOR NONTRADITIONAL
STUDENTS TO EARN A CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE APPROVED CERTIFICATE. IS
LESS THAN 6% THIS IS NOT JUST A
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGE
PROBLEM. THIS IS CONSISTENT WITH
THE NUMBERS NATIONWIDE. ARE
TRADITIONAL SYSTEMS OF EDUCATION
WEREN'T DESIGNED TO SERVE THESE
COMMUNITIES OF LEARNERS THIS IS
WHY WE'VE PARTNERED WITH UC
IRVINE'S TOP RANKED SCHOOL OF
EDUCATION. FOR MULTI YEAR
RESEARCH PROJECT TO APPLY
BEHAVIORAL SCIENCE AND DATA
ANALYTICS. TO ACTIVITIES ACROSS
THE STUDENT LED I CALLED THE DR
STRONG OUTCOMES FOR ADULT
LEARNERS NOT JUST OF THE BENEFIT
OF CALIBRATED ALSO TO THE
BENEFIT OF THE SYSTEM. THE
WHOLE. CREDIT BE WE NEED
INSTITUTIONAL DEDICATE FOCUS. ON
THIS COMP EQUATION TO BE THE
FLEXIBLE SKILLS BASED PUBLIC
OPTION FOR CALIFORNIANS. AS WE
STRIVE TO SEEK ALTERNATIVES TO
PREDATORY FOR PROFIT COLLEGES
THAT THE STATE HAS BEEN PLAGUED
WITH. THANK YOU FOR YOUR TME
AND I'LL YIELD THE FLOOR TO THE
NEEDS. THANK YOU PRESIDENT
MINION AND GET GOOD EVENING GOOD
AFTERNOON I GUESS IT IS EVENING
BUT COME UP CHAIR MEDINA VICE
CHAIR CHOI AND MEMBERS OF THE
ASSEMBLY HI COMMITTEE ON THIRD
ASSEMBLY HIGHER EDUCATION. AS
THE CALPERS BOARD OF TRUSTEES
AND THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGES SYSTEM WIDE OF
GOVERNORS I HAVE A YOU INTO THE
CHALLENGES FACED BY THE SYSTEM
AND INDIVIDUAL CAMPUSES ACROSS
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE SYSTEM
ENROLLMENT HAS DROPPED BY 20%
SINCE THE START OF THE PANDEMIC
AND THE STUDENTS WHO ARE LEAD UP
A HIGH GRADE ARE ARE OLDER
STUDENTS AND ARE BLACK AND
WHITE. STUDENTS THESE ARE GROUP
THAT ALREADY HAVE SOME OF OUR
LOWEST SUCCESS RATES AND WHEN
THEY LEAVE THE RARELY RETURN.
CALVET REPRESENTS AN EDIT
INNOVATIVE SHIFT IN
INSTITUTIONAL DESIGN IN ALREADY
WE ARE SEEING STUDENTS GRAVITATE
TOWARD TOWARDS THE COLLEGES
UNIQUE MODEL. AND EQUALLY
CRITICAL IS THAT CALIBRATED
FOCUSED ON FIGURING OUT HOW TO
SERVE NONTRADITIONAL STUDENTS ON
FIGHT ON FIGURING OUT COMPETENCY
BASED EDUCATION WITHIN THE
CONTEXT OF THE PUBLIC COMMUNITY
COLLEGE. WE AS ASSIST NEED HELP
RIGHT AND AS PRESIDENT OF THE
BOARD OF GOVERNORS I WOULD LIKE
TO SAY THAT THERE IS NO MERIT TO
THE LOGIC THAT DISSOLVING
CALIBRATE AND ALLOCATING ITS
FUNDS ACROSS THE SYSTEM WOULD
SOLVE THE COMPLEX EQUATION FOR
SUPPORTING ADULT LEARNERS. WE
DIDN'T SERVE ADULT LEARNERS WELL
BEFORE THE PANDEMIC AND SYSTEM
WIDE ENROLLMENT NUMBERS INDICATE
THAT WE'RE NOT SERVING THEM WELL
NOW EITHER. NOW IS THE TIME FOR
CALIBRATE FOR INNOVATIVE AND
CREATIVE SOLUTIONS FOR SHARED
CHALLENGES NOW IS THE TIME FOR
FLEXIBLE PROGRAMS FOR DEEP
EXPLORATION OF ONLINE EDUCATION
AND SKILLS BASED LEARNING.
ALBERT'S BOARD OF TRUSTEES HAS
THE UTMOST CONFIDENCE IN THE
COLLEGE'S NEW LEADERSHIP AND
STRATEGIC VISION AND WE HAVE
BEEN EXCEEDINGLY IMPRESSED BY
THE TEAM'S PROGRESS DURING THE
SHORT TIME IN THE MIDST OF A
GLOBAL PANDEMIC. ARE FOR THIS
NATION PROVIDED A SEVEN YEAR
START UP PERIOD TO BUILD A NEW
KIND OF COLLEGE FROM THE GROUND
UP AND WE NEED THE IME AND
SPACE DO THE IMPORTANT WORK.
KILBRIDE CARRY SIGNIFICANT VALUE
TO THE SYSTEM. ING IT WOULD HURT
STUDENTS AND WE CAN THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE SYSTEM AS A
WHOLE. I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE
IMPORTANT CONVERSATION. I'M
PRESIDENT IN AN AND I ARE HAPPY
TO ANSWER ANY OF YOUR QUESTIONS
. THANK YOU ANY OF THE PEOPLE IN
THE ROOM IN A POSITION YOU CAN-
STATE YOUR TITLE IN THE NAME AND
THE POSITION. THANK YOU DAVID OF
THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGES CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED. ANY OTHER
PERSON. HELLO MY NAME IS MICHAEL
STEWART AND I'M A FACULTY MEMBER
AT CAL RIGHT COLLEGE I WORK IN
THE I. T. PROGRAM AND I SERVE AS
THE ACADEMIC SENATE PRESIDENT
FOR CALVARY COLLEGE WE SUPPORT
THE CONTINUED OPERATION OF
COLLEGE AND ARE UNITED BY THE
BELIEF THAT OUR INNOVATIONS IN
ONLINE LEARNING CAN MAKE THE
COLLEGE MORE PERSONAL FLEXIBLE
AND RESPONSIVE TO THE STUDENTS
NEEDS I THINK THAT'S ENOUGH YOUR
POSITION IS- IN OPPOSITION YOU
JUST A STATE MY NAME AND- YOUR
POSITION SORRY THANK THANK YOU.
YEAH ARE ANY OF THE PERSIAN. ALL
RIGHT- COMMITTEE MEMBERS ANY
QUESTIONS OR STATEMENTS. OKAY.
KAMALA HARRIS. I'LL JUST SAY
THAT I THINK THAT THE VAST
MAJORITY OF LEGISLATORS IN THIS
BUILDING. BUT IT'S ALSO OUR
RESPONSIBILITY AS THE
LEGISLATURE TO BE FISCALLY
RESPONSIBLE. AND THE PROGRAM HAS
HAD OVER ONE HUNDRED AND FORTY
MILLION DOLLARS INVESTED WITH
LESS THAN SEVENTY. OUR STUDENTS
ACTUALLY GETTING A CERTIFICATE
SO. THAT IS COMPLETELY. THE
ANTITHESIS OF WHAT FISCALLY
RESPONSIBLE IS IN MY OPINION- SO
I APPLAUD YOUR WORK BUT WE HAVE
TO THINK OF EVERY CALIFORNIA
STUDENT AND DOING WHAT'S BEST
FOR EVERY CALIFORNIA STUDENT- SO
I AM GOING TO SUPPORT THIS BILL
I THINK THAT WE'VE HAD OF IT OF-
RESERVATIONS ABOUT THIS I
APPLAUD THE WORK YOU'VE TRIED TO
DO- BUT IT. AFTER WE NEED. THE
QUESTION WHAT IS THE PLAN TO
THIS SO IF DESTRUCTOID WHAT IS
THE PLAN FOR THE STUDENTS THAT
ARE CURRENTLY ENROLLED IN A
HEALTH. AND I THINK AS WE ARE
VERY CONCERNED ABOUT THE IMPACT
IT'LL HAVE ON EVERY DEDICATED
MEMBER OF THE REPRESENTED
FACULTY AND STAFF AT OUR
INSTITUTION THAT WE ARE ALSO
DEEPLY CONCERNED THAT WE'RE IN A
PERIOD OF ENROLLMENT GROWTH. AS
STUDENTS ARE REACHING OUT TO US
AND MORE THAN 90% OF THEM WHEN
WE ASK WHY ARE REACHING OUT
BECAUSE OF THE FLEXIBILITY OF
THE MODEL THESE ARE THE SAME
STUDENTS THAT ARE. SO RESERVE
INSTITUTION OF A PROFOUND IN IN
IN IN IN PACKED FULL INTO THEIR
LIVES THIS IS OFTEN THEIR ONLY.
OPPORTUNITY TO REALLY ACCESS AND
EDUCATIONAL WORK EXPERIENCE AND
AT AT A TIME IN WHICH THE WAY
THAT THEY'RE EXPERIENCING LABOR
MARKET OPPORTUNITIES THE WAY
THAT THEY'RE EXPERIENCING THE
EDUCATION MARKET IS PROHIBITIVE
FOR THEM AND WE KNOW THIS
BECAUSE WE'RE HEARING IT FROM
OUR STUDENTS RIGHT WE THIS ISN'T
A GAS THIS IS. WE BUT A STUDENTS
BY THE NAME OF BRANDY WHO WORKS
AS AN ASSISTANT AND DOESN'T SEE
ANY OPPORTUNITY FOR UPWARD
MOBILITY BUT FOR OUR CRM PROGRAM
AND THAT THAT HER PURSUIT OF THE
CRM PROGRAM IS UNLOCKING WITHIN
HER ORGANIZATION AN OPPORTUNITY
FOR HER TO GET MORE SUSTAINABLE
WAGES AND EITHER READ LIFE AND
SHATTERING THE SHINS AT THE TOP
WHICH WE ARE ACTUALLY NOT
SUCCEEDING IN SERVING THE
STUDENTS THEIR FOLLY OUT OF OUR
PATIENTS NOT. TO COMMUTE.
SUCCESS FOR THE STUDENTS WILL
HAVE A PROFOUND IMPACT ON THE
THOUSAND STUDENTS THAT WE HAVE
pHAVE A PROFOUND IMPACT ON OUR
ABILITY TO REALIZE A STRONG
RECESSIONARY RECOVERY NOT JUST
FOR FOLKS YOU WARNING FROM ADULT
LEARNER POPULATIONS BUT-
NATIONWIDE. AND- A WHILE SINCE
WE'VE YOU KNOW NEW COLLEGES OR
WHATEVER HAVE BEEN ESTABLISHED
BUT DOES ANYBODY HAVE ANY DATA
ASKED TO LET ME KNOW HOW- HOW
LONG IT USUALLY TAKES FOR A
BRAND NEW COLLEGE OR SYSTEM TO
BE- SIX ESTO AND FINANCIALLY
PROP. IT'S A IT'S A GREAT
QUESTION AT THANKS FOR ASKING
AND I THINK A COUPLE THINGS TO
NOTE ONE IS AND WE'RE ONLY
HALFWAY THROUGH OUR SEVEN YEAR
START UP. WINDOW SO THE
LEGISLATURE ANTICIPATED THAT IT
WOULD TAKE SEVEN YEARS FOR US TO
DEVELOP AND ESTABLISH A SCALABLE
SOLUTION THAT COULD THEN DIAL
OUR PROPONENTS WE'VE EXCEEDED
PROGRESS IN THAT REGARD BY
SETTING UP STRONG FOUNDATION
THAT ALLOWS TYLENOL. OKAY THE
TIME WHEN WE ARE CAN. FALLOUT OF
EDGE GEN A- VERY FEW EXAMPLES OF
OTHER INSTEAD. THAT ACTUALLY
BUILT FROM THE GROUND UP ALL THE
THINGS THAT ARE REQUIRED TO
REALLY. UP THE USER. NINE THE
STEW. CENTER AT YOU KNOW THE
NEEDS AND THE AND THE CONDITIONS
AND EXPERIENCES OF STUDENTS HOLD
THE MOST IMPORTANT SEAT AT THE
TABLE MS OF DESIGNING THE
EDUCATIONAL OFFERING. M. ANOTHER
EXAMPLE OF THAT IS WESTERN
GOVERNORS UNIVERSITY'S WHEN WE
LOOK AT THE GROWTH TRAJECTORY OF
WESTERN GOVERNORS UNIVERSITY'S.
YOU KNOW FOLKS WERE. WILLING
VERY EARLY IN THE PROCESS TO
HOLD THEM OUT FOR THE COUNT AND
FOUR YEARS LATER THEY ONLY HAD A
HANDFUL OF GRADUATES. YOU SEE
WHERE THEY'VE BECOME NOW THIS
CAN BE AN OPPORTUNITY FOR A
PUBLIC POLLUTION LIKE THAT HERE
IN CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU. ANY OF
THE QUESTIONS. OKAY I THINK I IN
IT THIS IS SO NOT A OUR QUESTION
NOW BUT THAT MIGHT- A STATEMENT-
I WAS SO SHOCKED WHEN I- WENT
ABOUT THIS BILL- THAT THE- CARE
BRIGHT THE L. ONLINE COLLEGE I
THOUGHT THAT THAT WAS STOLEN
FUTURE TREND BUT THE- NOW Y.
ASSISTER LOW ENROLLMENT AND NOW
HAS NOT BEEN. SUCCESSFUL AT THAT
THE WITH THE UP AND THEN MAKE A
THE PEOPLE I THOUGHT THE
STUDENTS WERE USED TO NOW ONLINE
CLASSES AND THOUGH IT WOULD
BECOME RICHER- FOR LEARNING BUT
THE- THEY IN THERE ARE MORE
BEHAVIORS SO A SECOND. AND IN
THERE AND OF- TO SAFEGUARD OUR
FUNDS SET TO BE MORE EFFICIENTLY
USED AND- FOR THAT- I WOULD BE-
SUPPORTING AND THE HOUSES LIKE
TO ENTERTAIN A MOTION. THAT MOVE
BY ARAMBULA AND SECOND BY-
ASSEMBLY MEMBER VALLADARES-
DOCTOR CHOI IF I MAY JUST YEAH
YEAH YEAH YOU'LL YOU'LL SEE A
TIME OF HELLO SIR CLOSE- YOU
KNOW WHEN THE COW RIGHT WAS
FIRST INTRODUCED. I THINK THERE
WERE VERY HIGH EXPECTATIONS- OF
THE PROGRAM I'M- CERTAINLY- IT
WAS GIVEN TO US AS AS A- WAY TO
DO- WHAT WHAT I JUST HEARD FROM
THE OPPOSITE END OF THE BILL AND
THAT TO ME. EIGHT NET OF. DO IS
BEING MET BUT I THINK THE
NUMBERS SPEAK FOR THEMSELVES AND
UNFORTUNATELY. IT IS NOT PROVEN
TO BEEN SUCCESSFUL NIGHT OF
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
ON THE BILL. THANK YOU MOTION
HAS BEEN MADE TO AND THE SECOND
ED- TO- TO PASS A TOOL WHAT THE
COMMITTEES THAT PROCREATION
APPROPRIATIONS SUBCOMMITTEE OKAY
HELLO PLEASE THE CALDERON. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE MEDINA
HI MEDINA I CHOI AYE CHOI AYE
ARAMBULA. ARAMBULA I'D BLOOM.
BLOOM I GABRIEL GABRIEL I IRWIN.
IRWIN I KILEY LEVINE LOW LOW I
SANTIAGO BALLADARES VALLADARES I
WEBER. WEBER NOT VOTING. OKAY
ALYSSA OUT THOUGH WITH HER EIGHT
ZERO. AND BACK TO CHAIR.
FILE ITEM TWENTY SEVEN MISTER
WARD. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS AB SEVENTEEN NINETEEN
ALLOWS COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICTS THE ABILITY TO MANAGE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING UNITS FOR
STUDENTS AND STAFF IN THE
OPPORTUNITY TO APPLY FOR THE
NECESSARY TAX CREDITS THIS BILL
WILL ALLOW COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICTS WITH THE APPROPRIATE
EXIT. IN CALIFORNIA'S EXHAUST
HOUSING CRISIS I LIKE TO PRESENT
MY WITNESS IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL MARKET DONALD REPRESENTING
THE SAN DIEGO COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICT. THANK YOU ARM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS MARK MCDONALD ON
BEHALF OF THE SAN DIEGO AND
PERALTA COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICT SIZE THESPONSOR AND
SUPPORTER OF THE MEASURE-
HOUSING FOR COMMUNITY COLLEGE
FACULTY STAFF THAT IS NEAR THEIR
PLACE OF WORK CAN BE TIME. READ
AN AIR FOR THOSE CAN.JIM FOR
YOU. AB SEVENTY NINETEEN WOULD
PROVIDE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICTS WITH SIMILAR AUTHORITY
THAT HAS ALREADY BEEN GRANTED TO
K. TWELVE THROUGH. MR GABRIEL'S
PREVIOUS PIECE OF LEGISLATION.
THAT WOULD PROVIDE A TOOL FOR
COMMUNITY COLLEGES TO HELP
PROVIDE EMPLOYEES WITH THE BALL
HOUSING AND- HELP INCENTIVIZE
CALIFORNIANS TO WIN TO WORK ACT
COMMUNITY COLLEGES WHAT- YOUR
SUPPORT YOU. YEAH. YEAH WE GOT
IT RIGHT. ANYWAY THIS IS NOT.
AND YOU CAN. I KNOW I JUST HAVE
A QUICK STATEMENT. MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS MIKE WEST ON BEHALF OF
THE STATE BUILDING AND
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL WE
APPRECIATE THE ONGOING
CONVERSATIONS WE'VE HAD WITH
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WARD AND THE
STAFF INCLUDING ONE THIS
MORNING. WE LOOK FORWARD TO
SPENDING THE BILL IN A WAY THAT
BEST HELPS ENSURE CONSTRUCTION
WORKERS ON THESE PROJECTS ARE
SKILLED AND TRAINED BUT WE
REMAIN OPPOSED. COMMENDED THANK
YOU. ANY MURATSUCHI. VOTING
WITHIN CITY THAT. A QUESTION ARE. THANK YOU THE- ARE RELIGIOUS-
ALSO NEEDED ARE. AT LEAST AS
SEVERE. HE HAS TO. OTHERS THAT
IS IN- REALLY CONVERSE AND SO
WILL CAN TO LOOK AT GOING FOR.
AND THANK YOU MISTER TO THANK
YAPA FOR OUT TO CONTINUING TO
WORK WITH MY STAFF TO ADDRESS
THEIR CONCERNS WE'RE DEDICATING
TO CONTINUE THAT WORK WITHOUT A
RESPECTFULLY REQUESTED THESE AYE
VOTE. ADAMO SACRAMENTO DIEGO-
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
COMMITTEE BUT- MEDINA HI CHOI
CHU I KNOW ARAMBULA ARAMBULA I'D
BLOOM BLOOM HI GABRIEL GABRIEL I
IRWIN. IRWIN I KILEY LEVINE LOW
LOW I SANTIAGO CALAVERAS. WELL%
THERE IS I WEBER. WEBER AVE. ONE
EIGHT ONE WE CAN DO THAT OVER
FOR. YEAH. WE WILL GO ON TO- DO
ADD ONS. YES THAT THOSE ARE ALL
THE BILL'S. TO THE CONSENT
CALENDAR FIRST. GABRIEL GABRIEL
I LOW. LOW I SANTIAGO. CONSENT.
ELEVEN ZERO THE CONSENT CALENDAR
IS OUT. FILE ITEM ONE AB.
SEVENTEEN OH FIVE GABRIEL
GABRIEL I LOW LOW I SANTIAGO.
ELEVEN ZERO AB SEVENTEEN OH FIVE
IS OUT FILE ITEM TO AB TWENTY
THREE FIFTEEN GABRIEL. THE TEAM
NUMBER TWO- I GABRIEL I LO LO I
SANTIAGO. NINE ZERO AB TWENTY
THREE FIFTEEN IS A FILE ITEM FOR
AB TWENTY SIX TWENTY SEVEN
GABRIEL GABRIEL I LO LO I
SANTIAGO. TEN ZERO AB TWENTY SIX
TWENTY SEVEN IS OUT. AB NUMBER
FIVE I MEAN FILE ITEM FIVE AB
TWENTY SIX NINETY FIVE ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA AYE BLOOM BLOOM I.
KILEY LEVINE LOW LOW I SANTIAGO. NINE ZERO A. B. TWENTY SIX
NINETY FIVE IS OUT. FILE ITEM
EIGHT AB TWENTY FOUR THIRTEEN
GABRIEL. GABRIEL I LO LO I
SANTIAGO. NINE ONE AB TWENTY
FOUR THIRTEEN IS OUT FILE ITEM
NINE AB TWENTY FOUR FIFTY NINE
GABRIEL. GABRIEL I LO LO I
SANTIAGO. ELEVEN ZERO AB TWENTY
FOUR FIFTY NINE IS UP FILE ITEM
TEN AB TWENTY FOUR NINETY ONE.
GABRIEL GABRIEL I LO LO I
SANTIAGO. ELEVEN ZERO AB TWENTY
FOUR NINETY ONE IS OUT. FILE
ITEM THIRTEEN AB. NINETEEN
NINETY SEVEN. GABRIEL GABRIEL I
LO LO I SANTIAGO. NINE TWO
SEVEN. I'M SORRY SEVEN TWO A. B.
NINETEEN NINETY SEVEN IS UP.
FILE ITEM FOURTEEN AB TWENTY
FIVE TWENTY TWO GABRIEL GABRIEL
I LO LO I SANTIAGO. TEN ZERO AB
TWENTY FIVE TWENTY TWO ALL ARE
IN THE WRONG ONE- I WAS ON THE
NO YOU'RE YOU'RE FINE AND WEBER
. WEBER HI. THANK. YES LEVIN
ZERO A. B. TWENTY FIVE TWENTY
TWO IS OUT. FILE ITEM FIFTEEN AB
SIXTEEN FIFTY FIVE GABRIEL.
APRIL I LO LO I SANTIAGO
BALLADARES BALLADARES AVE.
ELEVEN ZERO MAY BE. TWENTY FIVE
TWENTY TWO IS OUT NOW. SIX FIVE.
A. B. SIXTEEN FIFTY FIVE IS UP
ELEVEN ZERO. FILE ITEM USING
FILE ITEM SIXTEEN AB TWENTY SIX
TWENTY FOUR. LOOM. YES BLOOM I
GABRIEL GABRIEL I KILEY LOW
LEVEL I SANTIAGO.
YEAH. TEN ZERO A. B. TWENTY SIX
TWENTY FOUR IS OUT. FILE ITEM
EIGHTEEN AB. TWENTY FOUR FIFTY
SIX. ARAMBULA ARAMBULA AYE BLOOM. BLOOM I GABRIEL GABRIEL I
KILEY LOW LOW I SANTIAGO. NONE
OF THOSE CONSENT. SO TEN ZERO AB
TWENTY FOUR FIFTY SIX IS OUT.
FILE ITEM NINETEEN AB TWENTY SIX
FIFTY TWO ARAMBULA UNTIL I AND
BLOOM BLOOM I GABRIEL GABRIEL I
KILEY LOW LOW I SANTIAGO. EIGHT
ZERO AB TWENTY SIX FIFTY TWO IS
OUT. FILE ITEM TWENTY AB TWENTY
EIGHT TWENTY. KILEY LEVINE
SANTIAGO. EIGHT ZERO AB TWENTY
EIGHT TWENTY IS OUT. FILE ITEM
TWENTY ONE AB EIGHTEEN OH ONE.
GABRIEL GABRIEL I LO LO I
SANTIAGO. ELEVEN ZERO A. B.
EIGHTEEN NO ONE IS OUT. FILE
ITEM TWENTY TWO AB EIGHTEEN
FIFTEEN GABRIEL. GABRIEL NOT
VOTING LOW LOW I SANTIAGO. EIGHT
ONE A. B. EIGHTEEN FIFTEEN IS
OUT. FILE ITEM TWENTY THREE AB.
NINETEEN EIGHTEEN. GABRIEL HI
GABRIEL I LO LO I SANTIAGO.
EIGHT THREE AB NINETEEN EIGHTEEN
IS OUT FILE ITEM TWENTY FOUR AB
NINETEEN THIRTY SIX GABRIEL
GABRIEL I LO LO I SANTIAGO.
ELEVEN ZERO AB NINETEEN THIRTY
SIX IS OUT. FILE ITEM TWENTY
FIVE A. B. TWO SIX SIX SIX.
ARAMBULA ARAMBULA AYE BLOOM
BLOOM I KILEY LEVINE LOW LOW I
SANTIAGO. NINE ZERO AB TWENTY
SIX SIXTY SIX IS UP FILE ITEM
TWENTY SEVEN AB SEVENTEEN
NINETEEN. HIGHLY LEVINE SANTIAGO. EIGHT ONE AB SEVENTEEN
NINETEEN IS OUT. OKAY SANTIAGO
IS ON ITS WAY TO YOU TWENTY SIX
YEAH. THERE'S IN CONCERT. YEAH
YEP. THEY WERE MISSING THANK YOU
GOOD GOOD. FOR MR RESTAURANT THE
OTHER. THAT IS ON ITS WAY. RIGHT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU. THERE IS. SEVEN EIGHT- FILE.
THERE ARE NONE. YEAH. WE DO HAVE
WAS A LITTLE. YEAH YEAH YEAH
YEAH. THE CONSENT CALENDAR
SANTIAGO SANTIAGO HI. TWELVE
TWELVE ZERO CONSENT CALENDARS
OUT FILE ITEM ONE AB SEVENTEEN
OH FIVE SANTIAGO SANTIAGO I.
TWELVE ZERO AB SEVENTEEN OH FIVE
FILE ITEM TO AB. TWENTY THREE
FIFTEEN. SANTIAGO SANTIAGO HI.
TEN ZERO TWENTY THREE FIFTEEN IS
OUT FILE ITEM FOR AB TWENTY SIX
TWENTY SEVEN SANTIAGO SANTIAGO I. ELEVEN ZERO AB TWENTY SIX
TWENTY SEVEN IS UP FILE ITEM
FIVE AB TWENTY SIX NINETY FIVE
KILEY LEVINE SANTIAGO SANTIAGO
HI. ZERO AB TWENTY SIX NINETY
FIVE IS UP FILE ITEM EIGHT AB.
TWENTY FOUR THIRTEEN. SANTIAGO
SANTIAGO HI. TEN ZERO AB TWENTY
FOUR THIRTEEN IS OUT FILE ITEM
NINE AB TWENTY FOUR FIFTY NINE
SANTIAGO. SANTIAGO I'D. TWELVE
ZERO AB TWENTY FOUR FIFTY NINE
IS OUT FILE ITEM TEN AB TWENTY
FOUR NINETY ONE SANTIAGO
SANTIAGO I. TWELVE ZERO AB
TWENTY FOUR NINETY ONE IS OUT
FILE ITEM THIRTEEN AB. NINETEEN
NINETY SEVEN. SANTIAGO SANTIAGO
I. EIGHTY TWO AB NINETEEN NINETY
SEVEN IS OUT FILE ITEM FOURTEEN
AB TWENTY FIVE TWENTY TWO
SANTIAGO SANTIAGO I. TWELVE ZERO
AB TWENTY FIVE TWENTY TWO FILE
ITEM FIFTEEN AB SIXTEEN FIFTY
FIVE SANTIAGO SANTIAGO I. TWELVE
ZERO A. B. SIXTEEN FIFTY FIVE IS
A- FILE ITEM SIX IN AB TWENTY
SIX TWENTY FOUR SANTIAGO
SANTIAGO I KILEY. ELEVEN ZERO A.
ITEM EIGHTEEN AB. TWENTY FOUR
FIFTY NINE KILEY SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO HI. ELEVEN ZERO AB
TWENTY FOUR FIFTY SIX IS OUT
FILE ITEM NINETEEN AB. TWENTY
SIX FIFTY TWO. KILEY SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO I. NINE ZERO AB TWENTY
SIX FIFTY TWO IS OUT FILE ITEM
TWENTY AB TWENTY EIGHT TWENTY
KILEY LEVINE SANTIAGO. SANTIAGO
HI. NINE ZERO AB TWENTY EIGHT
TWENTY IS OUT. FILE ITEM TWENTY
ONE AB. EIGHTEEN OH ONE.
SANTIAGO SANTIAGO I. TWELVE ZERO
A. B. EIGHTEEN NO ONE IS OUT
FILE ITEM TWENTY TWO AB EIGHTEEN
FIFTEEN. SANTIAGO SANTIAGO I.
ONE NINE ONE A. B. EIGHTEEN
FIFTEEN IS OUT FILE ITEM TWENTY
THREE AB NINETEEN EIGHTEEN.
SANTIAGO SANTIAGO I. NINE THREE
AB NINETEEN EIGHTEEN IS OUT.
FILE ITEM TWENTY FOUR AB
NINETEEN THIRTY SIX SANTIAGO
SANTIAGO I. TWELVE ZERO A. B.
NINETEEN THIRTY SIX IS OUT. FILE
ITEM TWENTY FIVE AB TWENTY SIX
SIXTY SIX HIGHLY LEVINE SANTIAGO
SANTIAGO HI. TEN ZERO AB. TWENTY
SIX SIXTY SIX FILE ITEM TWENTY
SEVEN AB SEVENTEEN NINETEEN
KILEY LEVINE SANTIAGO SANTIAGO I. NINE ONE AB SEVENTEEN NINETEEN
IS OUT. SO I'D LIKE TO EXTEND MY
GRATITUDE TO THE COMMITTEE STAFF
THE SPEAKER'S OFFICE STAFF THE
RULES COMMITTEE STAFF THE
LEGISLATIVE DATA CENTER AND ALL
WHO ENSURED THAT THE HEARING
COULD TAKE PLACE.
THE BIG. AB ONE. JUST REMEMBER
THIS ONE. YEAH BY. FILE ITEM A
TO FOURTH. THE VOTE WAS TEN ONE
THE BILL IS OUT. WHERE DURING.
YOU ARE. GOOD. ZERO S. U. S.
SENATE YEAH WE ARE RIGHT.
CONTROL NINE. FOR IT IS. FIVE
THIRTY. GOOD I SAY. JUGGLING
ALSO. THANK YOU. FOR CALLING ON
IRAN. YEAH BILL. AND. THE MAN OF
GOOD NIGHT YOU ARE.